EDUCATION ASSEMBLY. EDUCATION
COMMITTEES.
AND WE'RE EXCITED TODAY TO
TACKLE A VERY INTERESTING TOPIC
RELATING TO STATEWIDE KID TO
TWELVE EDUCATION GOVERNANCE AND
CLOUD THE ISSUES INVOLVED REALLY
DO APPRECIATE EVERYONE BEING
HERE TODAY AND ALL THE FOLKS
WHO'VE.
PREPARED. I WOULD LOVE TO ASK
THE SERGEANTS TO MAKE SURE WORK
CALM THE MEMBERS SO SO WE GET
EVERYONE HERE TO. HEAR THE THE
GREAT DISCUSSION.
I'M.
WHAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THE
HEARING TODAY TO DISCUSS THE
STRENGTHS AND WEAKNESSES OF OUR
CURRENCY LEVEL GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE. WITH THE REST
EDUCATION IN THE STATE
SPECIFICALLY THE ROLE OF THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION THE
ROLE OF THE SUPERINTENDENT
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION.
CALIFORNIA HAS A INTERESTING AND
SOMETIMES FRUSTRATING SYSTEM OF
GOVERNANCE.
I'VE BEEN MANY STUDIES.
RECOMMENDATIONS LAWSUITS BALLOT
INITIATIVES.
THERE IS A TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION REPORT
THAT ASKS WHO'S IN CHARGE.
AND THE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
REPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
EXCELLENCE STATES THAT EVERYONE
IS IN CHARGE. AND NO ONE IS
ACCOUNTABLE.
SO WHERE DOES NOTEWORTHY POINT
RIGHT NOW WHERE WILL BE AS WE
KNOW ONE THING THAT THE ONLY
THING WE KNOW. OF FOR SURE WITH
THE CARDS EDUCATION GOVERNS IS
THAT WE WILL HAVE A NEW GOVERNOR
AND A NEW SUPERINTENDENT OF
INSTRUCTION. AT THE SAME TIME
NEXT YEAR AND I THINK THIS
PROVIDES US WITH AN OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE A DEEP DISCUSSION ABOUT
GOVERNANCE ROLES WHILE KEEPING
THE CONVERSATION FOCUSED ON.
OFFICES AND STRUCTURES AND NOT
THE INDIVIDUALS HOLDING THOSE
OFFICES AND SO WE'RE EXCITED
ABOUT THE PROSPECTS OF TODAY'S
HEARING ALL THAT WE MAY LEARN
FROM IT. GOT A VERY FULL AGENDA
AND I LIKE TO KEEP US ON TRACK
ON TIME.
WE ASKED MEMBERS TO TAKE TO GET
HERE SEEMS A CANNON AND I ASKED
MY MY FELLOW CHAIR AYE O'DONNELL
IF YOU'D LIKE TO MEET PATH MAKE
SOME OPENING REMARKS.
YES SIR THANK YOUAND GOOD
MORNING AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO THIS CONVERSATION AND OWNERS
FIRST THANK SENATOR ALLEN
INFECTIOUS ENTIRE TEAM. SOME OF
WHOM ARE UP HERE UP FOR HELPING
PUT TODAY TOGETHER AND ALSO.
.
BUT COMMON SENSE MEDIA FOR THEIR
SUPPORT AND AND AND.
SOME OF THEIR IDEAS AND BRING US
TO THIS.
HEARING TODAY.
LOOK TOWARD THE CONVERSATION
AND.
.
LOOK GOOD LOOKING REALLY STATE
LEVEL GOVERNANCE AND ALL THAT
INTERTWINES WITH STUDENT
OUTCOMES.
BECAUSE I WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE FOCUSING ON HERE IS
CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
IF THERE ARE THINGS WE CAN DO
AT THE STATE LEVEL TO CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP BE THE AND
GOVERNMENTS OTHERWISE WE SHOULD
BE DOING THEM.
WITH FORCE NAM SO.
AGAIN I THINK.
CENTER AROUND AND IT'S FUNNY AT
WHEN I LOOK IT. UP. EDUCATION
GOVERNANCE'S STATE OF CALIFORNIA
I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT EVERYONE'S
IN CHARGE BUT I HONESTLY
EVERYONE'S ACCOUNTABLE.
SO I THE GOOD WITH THE
CONVERSATION TODAY.
SO BAIT YOU BUDGET MISTER SHARON
AND I DO ALSO WANT TO.
EXTENDS GREAT GRATITUDE TO THE
OUR INCREDIBLE EDUCATION.
CHIEF CONSULTANT IN MORE BURKE
WHO DID A GREAT JOB PUTTING THIS
WHOLE THING TOGETHER AYE WE GET
SOME PERSPECTIVES FROM ALL OVER
THE CITY CALIFORNIA BUT WE ALSO
I WILL HAVE SOME PERSPECTIVES
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND I'M
EXCITED TO HAVE.
FOLKS FROM THE EDUCATION
COMMISSION OF THE STATES
WHO WILL BE PRESENTING ALL OF
THE LATER TO GIVE US AN OVERVIEW
OF THE WAY THE DIFFERENT STATES
DO IT. POSSIBLE REALLY WILL BE
DELVING INTO LOTS OF DIFFERENT
IDEAS AND STRUCTURES AND AND TO
HOPEFULLY HAVE SOME. SOME GOOD
THOUGHTS COMING OUT OF HIS
HEARINGS LET'S START WITH
KENNETH AYE AYE CAPTAIN CABIN.
COUPON OKAY SORRY. KENNETH
COUPON IS SEEN FISCAL POLICY
ANALYST WITH OUR LIST OF
ANALYST'S OFFICE TO START US
OFF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND GOOD
MORNING AYE CHERRIES AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. ARE BUILDING
UPON.
YOUR OPENING REMARKS A
CALIFORNIA'S ELECTED LEADERS AND
THE PUBLIC HAS BEEN STUDYING
DEBATING AND REFINING THE STATE
SYSTEM A KEY TWELVE GOVERNMENTS
FOR NEARLY A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
YEARS.
I THINK ONE REASON GOVERNANCE
HAS BEEN SUCH A STUBBORN ISSUE
FOR YOU IS TO HEAR SIZE OF THE
SYSTEM THAT CALIFORNIA HAS.
MORE THAN SIX MILLION STUDENTS
NEARLY A THOUSAND DISTRICTS MORE
THAN TEN THOUSAND SCHOOLS.
I SAID TURNING TO PAGE ONE OF
OUR HAND OUT. A STATE GOVERNANCE
TODAY REALLY REVOLVES AROUND
FOUR MAIN ENTITIES
OF THE GOVERNOR WHO PROPOSES THE
EDUCATION BUDGET TEN APPROVED IT
VETOES BILLS. YOU AS THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVES EDUCATION
FUNDING AND THE NEXT DAY POLICY.
ARE THE STATE BOARD WHICH
IMPLEMENTS REGULATIONS. THAT
IMPLEMENT STATE LAWS AND STATE
SUPERINTENDENT WHO ADMINISTERS
AYE EDUCATION PROGRAMS IN THE
STATE.
AND ALTHOUGH THAT SOUNDS LIKE A
FAIRLY CLEAR DIVISION OF
RESPONSIBILITIES TO LAW.
AND A LITTLE BIT PLAYER HERE IN
PRACTICE.
IN ADDITION THOSE FOUR DON'T
INCLUDE NEARLY A DOZEN OTHER
AGENCIES THAT HAVE GOVERNMENT'S
RESPONSIBILITIES IN SPECIFIC
AREAS.
I FOR EXAMPLE NO DISCUSSION OF
TEACHER ISSUES WOULD BE COMPLETE
WITHOUT A DISCUSSION OF THE WILL
OF THE CUP COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING.
A SAW TURNING TO PAGE TWO A
TODAY'S DISCUSSION REALLY BEGINS
IN EIGHTEEN FORTY NINE.
AFTER SOME CONSIDERABLE DEBATE
ABOUT THE FRAMERS OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST CONSTITUTION
I DECIDED AT THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT WOULD BE AN
ELECTED POSITION.
I THROUGH STATUTE THE
SUPERINTENDENT RECEIVED A MANY
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT YOU WOULD
STILL RECOGNIZE TODAY LIKE APART
SCHOOL FUNDING.
SUPERINTENDENT ALSO DIDN'T MANY
DUTIES THAT TODAY WOULD BE DONE
BY DISTRICT LIKE BUILDING SCHOOL
BUILDINGS.
THREE YEARS LATER THE
LEGISLATURE CREATED THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION. OF THE
BOARD'S MEMBERSHIP INITIALLY
CONSISTED OF STATE OFFICIALS
COULD IN THE GOVERNOR STATE
SUPERINTENDENT.
AND LATER THE BOARDEXPANDED TO
INCLUDE EVEN SOME LOCAL
OFFICIALS LIKE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS LARGE COMPANIES.
BY THE LEGISLATURE ALSO GAVE THE
BOARD PRODUCT FOR EDDIE TO SET
AND POWER TO SET REGULATIONS FOR
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM.
OVER THE NEXT FEW GET DECADES
THE BALANCE OF POWER SHIFTED A
COUPLE TIMES.
I DELEGATES TO CALIFORNIA SECOND
CONSTITUTIONAL CONVENTION
DECIDED THAT EDUCATION HAD
BECOME TOO CENTRALIZED.
AND THEY DECIDED THAT I HAD TO
REMOVE MOST OF THE STATE BOARDS
POWERS AND SHIFT THAT DOWN TO
THE COMING.
I OVER THE NEXT FEW DECADES ARE
AFTER EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE.
I STATE GOVERNANCE ALLEGE THEIR
UP REVOLVED AROUND THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT WITH THE BOARD OF
EDUCATION AMENDED TO MORE OF AN
ADVISORY BODY.
I TURNING TO PAGE THREE OUR THE
STATE GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE THAT
WE KNOW TODAY LARGELY. IN
NINETEEN TWELVE
I THAT YEAR THE VOTERS REPEAL
THE PREVIOUS CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT THAT HAD SPECIFIED THE
MEMBERSHIP OF THE STATE BOARD.
AS PART OF THAT SCENE CHANGE
THEY ALSO GAVE THE LEGISLATURE
THE AUTHORITY TO DECIDE HOW
APPOINT MEMBERS TO BE SELECTED.
AT THAT TIME THE LEGISLATURE ONE
OF THE BOARD THAT WOULD CONSIST
MORE AT THE LAY PUBLIC. AND IT
DECIDED TO MAKE ALL BOARD
MEMBERS APPOINTEES OF THE
GOVERNOR.
HOW THE LEGISLATURE ALSO
SIGNIFICANTLY STRENGTHEN THE
BOARDS OF A POWER AT THAT TIME?
IT RESTORING THE BOARD'S
AUTHORITY TO ISSUE RULES AND
REGULATIONS FOR THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM AND IT MADE THE BOARD
RESPONSIBLE FOR POLICY. AND ALSO
REQUIRED THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT TO COMPLY WITH
ALL OF THE POLICIES THAT THE
BOARD HAD APPROVED.
IN NINETEEN TWENTY AT THE
LEGISLATURE COMPLETED ITS FIRST
MAJOR REVIEW OF EDUCATION
GOVERNANCE.
EITHER PICK GRIPPED THE
COMMITTEE REPORT CRITICIZED WHAT
IT CALLED THE STATE'S DOUBLE
HEADED SYSTEM OF GOVERNANCE.
AND IT PREDICTED THAT CONFLICT
BETWEEN THE STATE BOARD AND THE
SUPERINTENDENT WAS INEVITABLE.
IT RECOMMENDED ABOLISHING THE
POSITION OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT AND REPLACING IT
WITH AN EXECUTIVE WHO WOULD BE
APPOINTED DIRECTLY BY THE STATE
BOARD.
OF THE LEGISLATURE NEVER TOOK UP
THAT RECOMMENDATION BUT OVER THE
NEXT SEVERAL DECADES A NUMBER OF
OTHER STUDIES WERE CONDUCTED AND
NAY I'VE MADE SIMILAR
RECOMMENDATIONS. ARE AS THE
NINETEEN TWENTY STUDY.
IN THREE CASES THE STATE GOT AS
FAR AS PLACING A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT ON THE BALLOT BUT IN
EACH CASE THE VOTERS ULTIMATELY
REJECTED THE PROPOSED CHANGES.
SO OVER THE PAST ONE HUNDRED
YEARS OF THE LEGISLATURE'S MADE
A NUMBER OF SMALLER CHANGES TO
STATE GOVERNMENTS.
I BUT THE STATE A GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE YOU KNOW TODAY HAD
LARGELY A MERGED I BY THE EARLY
NINETEEN HUNDREDS.
TURNING TO PAGE FOUR OF THE
STATE BOARD TODAY CONSISTS OF
ELEVEN MEMBERS ALL APPOINTED BY
THE GOVERNOR.
I THE CONSTITUTION ASSIGNS SIGNS
THE BOARD TO TWO DUTIES ONE IS
APPROVING TEXTBOOKS FOR USE IN
GRADES ONE THROUGH EIGHT.
AND THE SECOND IS APPROVING THE
APPOINTMENT OF THE
SUPERINTENDENTS FOUR SENIOR
DEPUTY IS.
STATE LAW GIVES THE BOARD MANY
OTHER RESPONSIBILITIES SOME OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT I APPROVING
STATEWIDE ACADEMIC STANDARDS IN
CHRIST SUBJECT AREAS.
I ADOPTING REGULATIONS TO
IMPLEMENT CERTAIN STATE LAWS ARE
THE LC FF SPENDING REQUIREMENTS
ARE A GREAT EXAMPLE OF THAT
AUTHORITY BEING EXERCISED.
AND HEARING WAIVER REQUESTS
SUBMITTED BY SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
BOB PAGE FIVE GIVE YOU SOME
SENSE OF THE CURRENT STRUCTURE
OF THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT.
I THE CONSTITUTION ESTABLISHES
THAT POSITION AND REQUIRES IT TO
BE ELECTED BY THE VOTERS
BUT DOESN'T ASSIGNING
SUPERINTENDENT ANY SPECIFIC
DUTY.
I THROUGH STATUTE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS GIVEN THE
SUPERINTENDENT THREE MAIN GOALS.
PERHAPS THE MOST IMPORTANT IS
TO MANAGE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
ANOTHER DUTY AS TO SERVICE THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER AND SECRETARY
OF THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION.
AND THE THIRD IS TO SERVE ON
VARIOUS BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
AS AN EX OFFICIO MEMBER. TO THE
MOST NOTABLE TO BOARDS.
BUT PROBABLY INCLUDE THE
TRUSTEES AT THE UC AND CSU
SYSTEMS.
AS THE HEAD OF THE DEPARTMENT
ABOUT THE SUPERINTENDENT HAS
MANY DIFFERENT RESPONSIBILITIES
SOME OF THE MOST IMPORTANT ARE
ADMINISTERING STATE AND FEDERAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
A OVERSEEING SOME KEY STATEWIDE
FUNCTIONS LIKE DEVELOPING
CURRICULUM FRAMEWORKS
A STANDARDIZED DIDN'T
ASSESSMENTS INSTRUCTION
MATERIALS SCHOOL FACILITIES
STANDARDS. AND OVERSEEING OUR
SYSTEM OF FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
ARE OFFICES OF EDUCATION.
I TURNING TO PAGE SIX A STATE
LAW THAT SETS FORTH THE BASIC
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE STATE
BOARD AND SUPERINTENDENT.
I THE BOARD HAS THE AS THE LA
PHRASES THAT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ALL QUESTIONS OF POLICY. AND THE
SUPERINTENDENT IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR EXECUTIVE AND ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNCTIONS.
ALTHOUGH THAT'S A FAIRLY CLEAR
LINE ON PAPER I THINK IF YOU
EXAMPLES WILL SHOW YOU HOW THOSE
ARE ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES
ARE SOMETIMES DISPUTED IN
PRACTICE.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY THREE FOR
EXAMPLE.
THE STATE BOARD DIRECTED THE
SUPERINTENDENT TO REPRESENT ITS
OPPOSITION
TO A BILL IN THE LEGISLATURE
THAT WOULD HAVE GIVEN.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS MORE AUTHORITY
TO CHOOSE WHICH TEXTBOOKS THEY
WANTED TO USE.
I THE SUPERINTENDENTS I DECLINED
TO CONVEY THAT OPPOSITION NOTING
THAT I GREATER TREACHERY
TEXTBOOKS IS ONE OF HIS CHOIR.
APPLY A PART OF HIS QUICK
PLATFORM.
I THAT DISPUTE AND DENSELY ENDED
WITH AN OPINION BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WHO NOTED. THAT THE
STATE THE SUPERINTENDENT HAS TO
FOLLOW THE DIRECTIVES OF THE
BOARD BUT THE BOARD CAN'T TAKE
ANY ACTION TO REMOVE THE
SUPERINTENDENT FOR FAILING TO
COMPLY.
PERHAPS THE BEST KNOWN DISPUTE
OCCURRED DURING THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES I THE SUPERINTENDENT AT
THAT TIME IT SHOULD MORE THAN A
HUNDRED ADVISOR HE'S TELLING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
HOW TO INTERPRET STATE LAWS AND
IMPLEMENT STATE PROGRAMS?
I THE STATE BOARD CONTENDED THAT
THOSE ADVISORIES REALLY
REGULATIONS AND THAT THEY
UNDERMINE THE BOARDS WILL AS A
POLICY MAKING BODY.
I THEY INSISTED THAT THE
SUPERINTENDENT CLEAR ALL ALL OF
THOSE ADVISERS WITH THE BOARD
FIRST
I WHEN THE SUPERINTENDENT AYE
REFUSED AYE THE TO EIGHT THE TWO
ENTITIES AND THAT UP IN COURT.
IN AND EARLY NINETEEN NINETIES
APPELLATE COURT DECISION THE
COURT RULED AT THAT THE
SUPERINTENDENT. UNDER STATE LAW
MUST FOLLOW THE BOARD'S LEAD ON
ALL ISSUES OF POLICY.
AND FINALLY A DISPUTE IN
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN
ILLUSTRATES SOME OF THAT
CONFUSION THAT CAN OCCUR AMONG
THE FIELD WITH THOSE ENTITIES
DON'T AGREE. ARE AT THAT TIME OF
THE VOTERS SAID JUST APPROVED
PROPOSITION TWO TWO SEVEN. AYE
WHICH ACQUIRED ENGLISH LEARNERS
TO BE TAUGHT IN ENGLISH AND
RESTRICTED BILINGUAL PROGRAMS.
I THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT
ISSUED AN OPINION THAT THIS
THESE RESTRICTIONS ARE JUST PART
OF THE EDUCATION CODE. AND THE
STATE BOARD COULD WAVE TO HIM AS
IT COULD WITH ANY OTHER
PROVISION OF LAW.
SOME DISTRICTS ARE PUT TOGETHER
THEY WAIVERS AND WENT TO THE
STATE BOARD BUT THEN THE STATE
BOARD DECLINED ISSUE THEM
ISSUING A DIFFERENT OPINION THAT
FOUND THAT IT DIDN'T HAVE ANY
AUTHORITY TO WAIVE INITIATIVES
APPROVED BY THE
VOTERS.
I SAID TURNING TO PAGE SEVEN.
OVER THE PAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS
FIVE MAJOR STUDIES HAVE EXAMINED
KEY TWELVE GOVERNANCE AND MADE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR A FIREMAN.
I IN BROAD STROKES ALL OF THOSE
STUDIES CONCLUDED THAT THE
CURRENTS
ACTUALLY HAS SIGNIFICANT
SHORTCOMINGS.
I THE FIRST MAJOR CONCERN WAS
THAT THE CURRENT SYSTEM A LACKS
CLEAR LINES OF AUTHORITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY. HAVING MULTIPLE
GOVERNANCE ENTITIES MEANS THE
PUBLIC HAS DIFFICULTY HOLDING
ANY ONE ENTITY RESPONSIBLE FOR
EDUCATIONAL QUALITY AND RESULTS.
A THINK THAT LINE WAS A CONCERN
IS BEST EXPRESSED BY THE LINE
THE CHAIRMANSHIP AT THE
BEGINNING.
JUST THE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
REPORT A AYE WHICH CONCLUDED
THAT THE PROBLEM WITH STATE
GOVERNMENTS IN CALIFORNIA IS
THAT EVERYONE IS IN CHARGE AND
NO ONE IS ACCOUNTABLE.
THE STUDIES ALSO RAISED CONCERNS
THAT THE CURRENT SYSTEM DOES NOT
PROMOTE COHERENT POLICY MAKING.
I THE GOVERNOR THEY NOTED THAT
THE GOVERNOR LEGISLATURE AND
STATE BOARD ALL RELY ON THE
SUPERINTENDENT IMPLEMENT THE
POLICIES.
BUT THE SUPERINTENDENT IS
ELECTED INDEPENDENTLY ANSWERABLE
TO A DIFFERENT CONSTITUENCY AND
MAY HAVE DIFFERENT POLICY
PRIORITIES.
I FINALLY ALL OF THE STUDIES I.
CITED MANY EXAMPLES OF
DUPLICATION FOR EXAMPLE THE
GOVERNOR OFTEN APPOINTS
I THEIR OWN EDUCATION GOVERNOR'S
OFTEN APPOINT THEIR OWN
EDUCATION ADVISERS. WHOSE
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE VERY
SIMILAR TO THOSE I DONE BY THE
STATE BOARD AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION.
SO TURNING TO PAGE EIGHT OF THE
STUDIES I MAKE A SERIES OF
RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND.
OFF FIVE REALLY ENVISION A.
THAT THE GOVERNOR WOULD BE THERE
SORT OF CLEAR HEAD OF THE
STATE'S EXECUTIVE FUNCTIONS.
AND WHAT THAT TENDERLY GENERALLY
TENDS TO MEAN IS THAT SOME OR
EVEN ALL. OF THE POLICY MAKING
AND ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS
THAT TDAY ARE SPREAD ACROSS THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF THE
STATE BOARD AND OTHER AGENCIES.
I WOULD BE CONSOLIDATED INTO AN
OFFICE THAT REPORTS TO THE
GOVERNOR.
I REGARDING THE SUPERINTENDENT
OF THE STUDY'S RECOMMENDATIONS
REALLY FOR A LONG SPECTRUM. ARE
THE NINETEEN NINETY SIX STUDY
CALLED FOR THE MOST DRAMATIC
CHANGE IT RECOMMENDED ABOLISHING
THE POSITION OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT.
AND REPLACING IT AYE WITH
SOMEONE WHO'D BE APPOINTED BY
THE GOVERNOR HOW TO PERFORM ALL
OF THE ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS.
BY THE OTHER TWO STUDIES
RECOMMENDED RETAINING ELECTED
SUPERINTENDENT BUT MAKING THIS
POSITION RESPONSIBLE FOR SCHOOL
ACCOUNTABILITY.
I UNDER THIS AYE RECOMMENDATION
THE SUPERINTENDENT WHICH REALLY
ENVISIONED AS SORT OF AN
INDEPENDENT VOICE FOR SCHOOL
IMPROVEMENT WITH SPECIFIC
DUTIES.
THAT MIGHT INCLUDE A COLLECTING
AND PUBLISHING ACCOUNTABILITY
DATA. IDENTIFYING LOW BUT LOW
PERFORMING SCHOOLS OVERSEEING
ASSISTANCE TECHNICAL SUPPORT AND
ISSUING REPORTS TO THE PUBLIC ON
HOW WELL THE SCHOOL SYSTEM WAS
PERFORMING.
AT THE FINAL TWO STUDIES
RECOMMENDED MORE MODEST CHANGES
SO THEIR PROPOSALS I RETAIN THE
SUPERINTENDENT TWIST MUCH OF THE
POSITIONS CURRENTLY ALL. I WITH
SOME REFINEMENTS TO CLARIFY
RESPONSIBILITIES AND STE AND
ONLY A JUST A FEW QUID ADEQUATE
NATION I TYPE FUNCTIONS
TRANSFORM TO THE GOVERNOR.
RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING THE
STATE BOARD ALSO FELL ALONG
SPECTRUM I TO STUDY IS
RECOMMENDED COMPLETELY
ELIMINATING THE BOARD'S POLICY
MAKING POWER IS AND
RECONSTITUTING THE STATE BOARD
AS A BODY THAT WOULD. ADVICE THE
GOVERNOR ON KEY EDUCATION
ISSUES.
I TO ABOUT ONE STUDY ENVISIONED
IT NARROWING THE BOARD'S
AUTHORITY BY ELIMINATING BOTH OF
ITS CONSTITUTIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES.
BUT AND BUT ALLOWING IT TO DO
TASKS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
EXPLICITLY ASSIGNED TO IT.
AND I THE FINAL TWO STUDIES
RECOMMENDED MAINTAINING THE
BOARDS CURRENT GOAL AS A
REGULATORY BODY THAT WOULD
CONTINUE TO BE APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR.
ALSO TURNING TO THE FINAL PAGE
OF OUR HAND OUT LET ME LEAVE YOU
WITH JUST A FEW CLOSING.
THOUGHTS AS YOU THINK ABOUT
POTENTIAL GOVERNANCE CHANGES.
I THE FIRST IS THAT THERE ARE
SOME CONSTITUTIONAL LIMITS ON
YOUR ABILITY TO CHANGE THE KEY
ACTORS IN THE SYSTEM. OF THE
CONSTITUTION REQUIRES BOTH THE
STATE BOARD AND STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION.
ON THE OTHER HAND YOU HAVE VERY
BROAD AUTHORITY TO CHANGE THE
RULES AND RESPONSIBILITIES OF
THOSE ENTITIES.
NEARLY ALL OTHER ASPECTS OF
STATE GOVERNANCE RANGING FROM
THE METHOD OF SELECTING THE
STATE BOARD TO SPECIFIC DUTIES
OF EACH ENTITY. AYE THINGS THAT
YOU COULD CHANGE THROUGH
MODIFYING STATUTE.
AND FINALLY. CONSIDER YOUR TRADE
OFFS.
I THE PRINCIPLE I THINK BEST
REFLECTED IN THE CURRENT
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE IS A
DIFFUSION OF EXECUTIVE POWER. I
MOST BY DESIGN THE CURRENT
SYSTEM REQUIRES ALL OF THE MAIN
ACTORS TO AGREE ON MOST MAJOR
POLICY CHANGES.
WHAT THE FIVE STUDIES HAVE
ADVISE YOU TO DO BY CONTRAST IS
FOCUSED MORE? ON SOME OTHER
PRINCIPLES LIKE HAVING CLEAR
LINES OF AUTHORITY BY HAVING
TRANSPARENT DECISION MAKING AND
ELIMINATING ARE OVERLAPPING
FUNCTIONS.
SO WITH THAT OVERVIEW I CHAIR
NUMBERS I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
WELL THANK YOU.
.
BUT EVEN WE START WITH ONE.
RELATING TO THESE THESE STUDIES.
HAN.
SO THIS PARTICULAR STUDY THAT
ASKED FOR THE ELIMINATION OF THE
BOARD'S POLICY MAKING POWERS
RECONSTITUTION AS AN ADVISORY
BODY.
AND.
WHO WOULD THEN MAKE POLICY THE
POLICIES UNDER THAT STEADY WHO
WOULD THEN MAKE THE POLICIES?
THAT ARE CURRENTLY MADE BY THE
BOARD. THOSE STUDIES ENVISIONED
THAT THE GOVERNOR WOULD A POINT
TO HEAD OF AN AGENCY SAME WAY
WITH OUR THE GOVERNOR APPOINTS
THE HEADS OF OTHER AGENCIES AND
THAT PERSON WOULD LEAD UP.
NICELY A NEW AGENCY WITH THAT
KIND OF POLICY MAKING AUTHORITY.
CONSIDER THE WHOLE IDEA THAT IT
IS IT'S JUST ASKING THE BROADER
QUESTION OF WHY IT IS THAT WE
HAVE THE SEPARATE BOARD. MAKING
DECISIONS WHEN IN OTHER AREAS OF
POLICY MAKING ITS DONE.
IN A MORE HIGHER HOPE ROACH.
YEAH SO THAT MEAN THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION AND PUBLIC HAS ITS
ROOTS.
NOW ALL THE WAY BACK IN IN
EIGHTEEN FORTY NINE BUT. ON THAT
THE DELEGATES AT THAT TIME SEEM
TO WANT SOME. DISPERSION OF
POWER THEY WERE CONCERNED AYE
NOT JUST EDUCATION BUT IN OTHER
AREAS OF THE BUDGET.
ABOUT POWER BECOMING TOO
CONCENTRATED IN ANY ONE AREA.
I'M.
AND IN SOME. OTHER PARTS OF THE
BUDGET THE LEGISLATURE LATER
CONSOLIDATED THAT BUT IN THE
CASE OF EDUCATION IT'S ONE WHERE
THE VOTERS HAVE REALLY NOT GONE
FOR ANY MAJOR CHANGES. TO THAT
SYSTEM SINCE THAT TIME HONOR.
THIRD OF AND DID YOU HAVE A
QUESTION INCENTIVIZE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SHOT FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
IN A IN A THAT HE. MAINLY WE'RE
LOOKING AT SALACIOUS BETWEEN THE
DIFFERENT.
STATE ENTITY STATE BOARD
GOVERNOR SUPERINTENDENT. SO
WHAT.
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE YOU LOOK
AT THIS AND I KNOW WE'VE HAD.
S. REPORTS.
WHAT'S THE IMPACT THEN DOES THAT
HAVE.
SORT OF DOWNSTREAM WE HAVE. NO
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION WITH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND THEN OF
COURSE YOU. DON'T TO THE
FRONTLINE TEACHERS AND
PRINCIPALS AND TEACHERS AND SO
FORTH.
THIS SORT OF CONFUSION AT THE
TOP.
THEN LEADS TO LET ME CONTINUE AT
NW HAD CHEST EXPLORED THIS
WHAT'S THE CONSEQUENCES OF THAT.
ULTIMATELY OF COURSE WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE EDUCATION OF
OUR CHILDREN SO. IS THIS BASIS
THAT HAPPENS THE TOP LACK OF
CLARITY THESE FIGHTS THEY'VE HAD
WHAT WHAT WHAT THEN.
LEADS TO YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT'S
THE IMPACT THAT HAS ON FOLKS
PROBABLY CAN'T YOU KNOW I DON'T
WHICH TEXTBOOK TO GET THAT. NO
AND WHO KNOWS. THERE'S NO RATING
SYSTEM FOR KIDS CAN CAN YOU
SPEAK TO THAT.
YEAH IT'S A REALLY GOOD QUESTION
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT ALL OF
THE STUDIES ARE LOOKED AT AS
WELL AND I THINK I SHOULD
MENTION THAT MANY OF THE US
GOVERNMENT STUDIES. PATTON
ALTHOUGH THEY'VE FOCUSED ON OUR
STATE GOVERNANCE MANY OF THEM
HAD SIMILAR CONCERNS ABOUT LACK
OF CLARITY AT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FOR EXAMPLE. THAT WE NOTED I'M
RECENTLY THAT THE MISSION OF THE
COUNTY OFFICES IS REALLY UNCLEAR
AND SO THAT'S AN AREA OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT AT MY DESERVE A
CLOSER LOOK.
.
WHAT MANY OF THE AYE SCHOOL
REPRESENTATIVES I INTERVIEWED
FOR SOME OF THE STUDIES SAID BUT
THE PROBLEM WITH THE SYSTEM AS
THEY FELT LIKE THEY SOMETIMES
RECEIVED CONFLICTING MESSAGES?
MESSAGES ABOUT WHAT THEY SHOULD
PRIORITIZE SO YOU WANT ME TO
FOCUS ON.
GRADUATION RATES CLOSING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP TEST SCORES SOME
OF THE MEASURE. I'M SOMETIMES
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE STATE WORD
MAYBE THE MESSAGE IN THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE
WOULDN'T ALL AGREE. AND SO
THEY'D BE SAYING WELL AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL RECEIVING ALL THESE
DIFFERENT MESSAGES AND WE DON'T
KNOW HOW THEIR RANK THOSE
PRIORITIES.
THOSE ARE CLEARLY THAT IT LEADS
TO CONFUSION LOCAL LEVEL ABOUT
THAT.
BUT DIRECTION AND AND THAT SOON
THAT THERE MIGHT EVEN BE SOME
CONSEQUENCES FOR THAT EXAMPLE OF
COURSE YOU KNOW WE DO BUDGETING
WITH THE GOVERNOR AND GOVERNOR
SAYS THIS IS MY PRIORITY AND SO
ON THAT BUT THAT MIGHT. BE
TAPPED TO MIGHT BE FUNDS
ATTACHED TO HER.
IT'S BETTER A IN THAT NAY OTHER
QUESTIONS IN TERMS OF THE STATE
BOARD ITSELF YOU DON'T DID
PEOPLE HAVE DIFFERENT.
HOW INDEPENDENT IS THE STATE
BORDER APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR
I MEAN?
IS IT THEY SERVE IT WELL THE
THE.
TODAY HAVE TERMS THAT THEY
SICKLY WHAT'S THE TO TURN OVER
TRADITION OF THE OF THE STATE
BOARD I MEAN IF THEY'RE
ESSENTIALLY DIRECT TOOLS OF THE
GOVERNOR ARE DO THEY HAVE SOME
ENOUGH SOME INDEPENDENCE IN THE
SENSE THAT TO OTHER APPOINTEES.
YOU HAVE LIKE.
ROB THAT JELLY TO CONSERVE OUT
THEIR TERMS AND.
AND SO YOU DON'T DO NOT
GOVERNMENT COMING IN AND
CLEANING HOUSE ESSENTIALLY IF
BUT THEY DON'T AGREE WITH THE
GOVERNOR HOW. SO EXACTLY HOW
INDEPENDENT
STATE BOARD.
IT'S A GOOD QUESTION TWO THERE I
WOULD SAY MADE MORE INDEPENDENT
AND SAY THE HEAD OF AN AGENCY.
BUT NOT.
FAR LESS INDEPENDENT IN THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF THE
STRUCTURE RIGHT NOW IS THE STATE
PART MEMBERS SERVE FOUR YEAR
STAGGERED TERMS.
I SAW WHEN I GOVERNOR I'M COMING
AND HAS A CHANCE TO SORT OF.
NAME NEW.
MEMBERS THE STATE BOARD OVER THE
YEARS.
I THE STATE BOARD ALSO HAS A
MEASURE OF INDEPENDENCE BECAUSE
THEY CHOOSE A THEY ELECT THEIR
OWN HEAD OF THE STATE BOARD SO
THEY CHOOSE WAS GOING TO
REPRESENT THEM. I'M KEY ISSUES
AND THEY DO HAVE THEIR OWN ON
ITS RELATIVELY SMALL WHAT TO DO
ABOUT IT BUT DOESN'T STAFF
MEMBERS WHO WORK FOR THEM. SO
SOME INDEPENDENCE BUT NAM
IT'S JUST MUCH DIFFERENT IN THE
SUPERINTENDENT IS COMPLETELY
INDEPENDENT OF THAT STRUCTURE.
IS THE CLEAR FIVE WELL THE BOARD
HAS A SMALL STAFF TECHNICALLY
BUT YET IT'S THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE CONTROL OVER TO
SUPERINTENDENT TO ACTUALLY.
OVERSEAS
THE LARGER STAFF THE DEPARTMENT
YES EXECUTABLE WORDS POLICIES
ARE.
YEAH SOME OF THE STAFFING I
THINK IT'S BEEN.
SORT OF FATAH MOVEMENT THE LAWS
A LITTLE BIT NAM.
SOME WAYS UNCLEAR ABOUT HOW THAT
WORKS IN THE SUPERINTENDENT. AYE
IS DIRECTED TO HAVE SORT OF
CONTROL OF.
OF ALL OF THOSE STAFF OF SAY THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION BUT THE
STATE THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO WORK
UNDER THE GENERAL DIRECTION OF
THE STATE BOARD.
SO KIND OF WHERE THE LINE IS
BETWEEN THE STATE POINTS GENERAL
AUTHORITY AND THE SUPERINTENDENT
SPECIFIC MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY.
IT'S ABOUT LESS CLEAR AND
PRACTICE AND THE GOVERNOR IN
RELATION TO ALL OF THIS THE
STAFF AT CD IS ACCOUNTABLE TO
THE SUPERINTENDENT.
TO GOV GOVERNOR HAS A ROLE IN
THAT I MEAN THAT'S THE GOVERNOR
POINT STATE BOARD BUT ASIDE FROM
THE STATE BOARD DIRECTLY BETWEEN
THE GOVERNOR AND THE CD STAFF.
RIGHT LOSS WE HAVE BEEN DOING
THIS PRESENTATIONS SAY TEN YEARS
AGO THE SITUATION MIGHT HAVE
BEEN EVEN MORE CONFUSED BECAUSE
THE STATE USED TO HAVE A
SECRETARY OF EDUCATION.
I WHO WAS REALLY THE GOVERNOR'S
POLICY STAFF THEY DIDN'T HAVE A
LOT OF FORMER ROLAND LA. BUT BY
HAVING THE GOVERNOR'S YEAR THEY
EXERCISE A LOT OF.
I INFLUENCE OVER THE DIRECTION
OF POLICY I TODAY WE DON'T HAVE
A STRUCTURE LIKE THAT MOST OF
THE FORMER. HOT WHEELS OF THAT I
SECRETARY OF EDUCATION WERE
TRANSFERRED TO THE STATE BOARD.
ON BUT IT'S CERTAINLY POSSIBLE
ANOTHER GOVERNOR COULD APPOINT.
AT BRING BACK THAT POSITION AND
WE BACK BE BACK TO AN EVEN MORE
CONFUSING GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE.
AND I JUST BAY NOTE THAT.
IT MAKES A CHALLENGE IN TERMS
COMMUNICATE TO THE PUBLIC WHAT
WE'RE DOING IN EDUCATION AND
WHAT OUR STATE GOALS ARE WITH
THIS CONFUSION AT THE TOP AS
WELL. THANK YOU.
YES I THINK YOU THINK YOU REALLY
HISTORY LESSON HERE TO HIS IS
VERY HELPFUL TO ME.
KINDA WHINY THROUGH TIME AND
SEEING HOW THESE THINGS HAVE
DEVELOPED.
SEEING WATER CONSTITUTIONAL THE
POWERS WHAT AREN'T IS
INTERESTING TO ME TO.
I THINK WE SHOULD REMEMBER IN
THIS ROOM TODAY THAT.
SUCCESS HAPPENS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL THERE'S NOT ONE THING
SACRAMENTO CAN DO.
TO ENSURE STUDENT SUCCESS IN
CALIFORNIA REALLY IT'S THE JOB
OF THIS THOSE OF US REALLY IN MY
OPINION TO SET THE BAR.
AYE PROVIDE RESOURCES AND HOLD
SCHOOLS.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACCOUNTABLE AT
THAT THAT'S KIND OF WHERE I COME
FROM. SO THERE IS ONE PROPOSAL
IN HERE THAT SCARES ME WHICH IS
TURN ARE ALL OF THE DUTIES OVER
BASICALLY TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. AND HAVE THEM.
DIRECTOR STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION BECAUSE THERE ARE.
ONE HUNDRED NINETEEN MICRO
MANAGERS IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE ME BEING THE ONLY
ONE OUT OF THAT HA. HA JUST
KIDDING JUST KIDDING.
BUT I REALLY YEAH I MEAN CAN
YOU IMAGINE IF.
YOU KNOW WHAT ALREADY GOES ON
RIGHT HOW MANY BILLS DO WE DO
WITH YOU HEAR ME ALL THE TIME.
PEOPLE TRYING TO MICROMANAGE
THE SCHOOLS FROM SACRAMENTO IS
NOT A GOOD THING FOR A VARIETY
REASONS BECAUSE WERE DIVERSE
STATE IN MANY WAYS.
BUT I GET YOUR POINT HOOSIER
REALLY SAYING IS THAT.
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
EDUCATION INSTRUCTION IN THE
STATE CALIFORNIA'S WE JUST
ELECTED.
DEPARTMENT HEAD.
OTHER THAN THE BULLY PULPIT AND
SOME FORMAL DUTIES.
THERE ARE MANY.
POWER IS INHERENT IN THAT
POSITION IS THAT CORRECT. THINK
THAT'S RIGHT IT'S REALLY MEASURE
WE WHERE I WAS THINKING BEFORE
IT THE HEARING STARTED IF THERE
WAS ANY OTHER PARALLEL TO OTHER
DEPARTMENTS AND I CAN'T THINK OF
A GOOD ONE IT'S REALLY KIND OF.
STRUCTURE THAT CALIFORNIA SET UP
JUST TO MANAGE ITS EDUCATION
SYSTEM.
AND I DON'T KNOW MAYBE YOU WANT
TO COMMENT ON THIS MAYBE YOU
DON'T BUT.
ARE THERE OTHER STATES I DO
DIFFERENTLY THAT. THAT MAYBE
THEY'D THE CHANGE IN THE
STUDENT SUCCESS YOU HAVE A GREAT
SECOND PANEL I'M GOING TO DEFER
TO THEM ON THAT BECAUSE I THINK
THE UPS AND GREAT INFO FOR YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELL I DO APPRECIATE THIS I I'D
LOVE THE GUY. DO YOU DO YOU HAVE
CITATIONS FOR THE VARIOUS
STUDIES THAT YOU REFERRED TO SO
WE CAN.
YES ABSOLUTELY UNHINGED TOM.
I SEVEN EVER HAND OUT OF THE
LIST OF THE FIVE STUDIES AND I
BELIEVE MOST OF THEM ARE IN YOUR
COMMITTEE PACKETS AND IF THERE
ARE ANY THAT DIDN'T MAKE IT IN
THERE I'M WILL HAPPY TO FOLLOW
UP WITH YOU STEP. BY COUNTY I
GOTCHA OKAY PERFECT.
AND.
BUT NOTHING HAS BEEN DONE ON
THIS FOR TEN YEARS.
THAT'S RIGHT THE LAST MAJOR
STUDY WAS THE LITTLE WHOEVER I
COMMISSION REPORT IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT.
OKAY.
OKAY VERY HELPFUL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE IT IN AND
THEN I THINK THAT.
CHAIR O'DONNELL'S
QUESTION IS A PERFECT SEGUE TO
THE NEXT.
PANEL WILL BE GIVEN A CHANCE TO
HEAR FROM.
DIFFERENT STATES AND LEARN A
LITTLE MORE ABOUT THEIR
STRUCTURE SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU CAN OF THE DEPRECIATION.
SO WE GOT HUNTER REALLY WHO'S A
POLICY RESEARCHER WITH THE
EDUCATION COMMISSION OF THE
STATES ALSO JULIE ROWAN WOODS
WHO SAW SENIOR POLICY ANALYST.
WITH HIS HIS COMMISSION
COMMISSION THE STATE'S WHICH IS
BASICALLY CONSORTIUM.
OF EDUCATION LEADERS FROM THE
FIFTY STATES TO GET TOGETHER AND
TALK ABOUT EDUCATION POLICY
QUESTIONS.
THAT THEY'RE VERY STATES ARE
FACING IN THIS OF COURSE IS ONE
OF THEM HOW TO STRUCTURE
GOVERNANCE.
IN THE EDUCATION SPACE AND WE
LOVE TO HEAR.
FROM.
MISTER RAILEY MISS WOODS WHO
WILL GIVE US PERSPECTIVES FROM.
OTHER.
STATES.
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE I
GUESS YOU'RE ALL IN FROM DENVER.
AND TESTING GUELPH LEAH IT'S A
LITTLE COLD HERE BUT PROBABLY AS
CLOSE AS THEY'RE KNOWN I SHOULD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING US
HERE TODAY A AS THE CHAIRMAN
MENTIONED I'M JULIE WOODS AND
THIS IS MY COLLEAGUE HUNTER
RAILEY WE ARE FROM THE EDUCATION
COMMISSION OF THE STATES.
AND JUST AS A REMINDER WE'RE
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS TODAY
AS WELL AS AS YOU MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS WORK.
SO ALTERNATE OVER HUNTER TO TALK
TO US ABOUT GOVERNANCE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS HUNTER
REALLY AND I'M A POLICY
RESEARCHER FOR THE EDUCATION
COMMISSIONOF THE STATES LIKE TO
THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR PROVIDING US ME
WHAT THE TIME TO DISCUSS STATE
EDUCATION GOVERNANCE THIS
MORNING.
BEFORE WE START.
I JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU A BRIEF
INTRODUCTION TO EDUCATION
COMMISSION OF THE STATES.
WE ARE NONPARTISAN ORGANIZATION
AND DO NOT ADVOCATE FOR AGAINST
ANY POSITION ON WE'RE JUST HERE
TO SERVE YOU AS YOU TO BE THIS
ISSUE TODAY.
.
WE PROVIDE OBJECTIVE INFORMATION
TO OUR CONSTITUENTS WITH WHICH
SOLVE YOU AND I WERE THE ONLY
ORGANIZATION WITH THE NATIONAL
VIEW ON THESE ISSUES ON THEN WE
DO THIS THROUGH RESEARCH
REPORTS.
AYE COUNCIL INCONVENIENCE.
ON DECEMBER REFILL OUR VIEW OF
WHAT ALL DISCUSSED TODAY.
DISTANT OVERVIEW OF GOVERNANCE
WHAT WE MEAN.
ONE LEASE SAY GOVERNMENTS WHAT
ALL THAT ENTAILS AND WHY THAT'S
IMPORTANT.
FOLLOWED BY A QUICK OVERVIEW OF
THE CORE GOVERNANCE STRUCTURES
NATIONWIDE THERE'S FOUR. COURSE
STRUCTURES ON AND SOME
VARIATIONS IN ALL THE.
ADDRESS SOME OF THE TRADE OFFS
VERY BRIEFLY.
.
FOLLOWED BY A DISCUSSION OF THE.
RECENT CHANGES AND SOME CONTENT
POTENTIAL CHANGES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN OTHER STATE HOUSES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
ON AND OFF FINISH WITH SOME
CONSIDERATIONS ON SOME QUESTIONS
FOR ORIENTING YOUR APPROACH AND.
JUST SOME IDEAS TO KEEP IN MIND.
AS YOU MOVE FORWARD.
SO.
WHAT IS GOVERNANCE OUR
GOVERNANCE'S AND?
AS WE DEFINED IT IS THE PROCESS
OF MAKING DECISIONS CREATING AND
ENFORCING RULES. AND DELIVERING
SERVICES.
THAT'S A BROAD DEFINITION IN
RURAL VARY DEPENDING ON THE
ENTITIES SERVICE BEING PROVIDED
OR THE POPULATION UP BEING
ADDRESSED.
ON THAT INCLUDES STEPHAN.
THAT DEFINITION INCLUDES BOTH
INPUTS AND OUTPUTS.
BOTTOM.
DECISIONS ARE MADE ACROSS OUR IN
COORDINATION WITH A VARIETY OF
INSTITUTIONS SO THAT IMPLIES
MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDERS ARE
INVOLVED SO ONE WORK.
SPEAKING ABOUT K. TWELVE
EDUCATION IT'S NOT JUST THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION WHO HAS
OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY OR.
IS INVOLVED IN THAT PROCESS.
PALM INSTITUTIONS MAY ONLY HAVE
PARTIAL JURISDICTION OR HAVE A
DISCRETE FUNCTION AND.
CREATING RULES ARE DELIVERING
SERVICES.
AND THAT FREQUENTLY INVOLVES A
COMBINATION OF FORMAL AND
INFORMAL PROCESS SEASON NORMS.
FORMAL NORMS AND PROCESS EASIER
ESTABLISHING LAW RULES AND
REGULATIONS.
INFORMAL NORMS VARY BY
INTERACTION.
THE PROFESSIONALS IN EACH OF
THOSE ROLES AND.
THE CONTEXTUAL OMENS DRIVE IN
THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS.
ON.
FOR OUR PURPOSES HERE THAT CAN
COMPLICATE AYE RULE CLARITY.
ROLE CLARITY EXCUSE ME AND IT
BECOMES MORE CHALLENGING ONE
INSTITUTIONS AND PEOPLE ARE
REQUIRED TO PERFORM NEW TASKS
DIFFERENT TASKS.
PARDON WITHIN THEIR RULES OR THE
RULES TO REDEFINE.
ON THIS PRESENTATION WILL FOCUS
PRIMARILY ON FORMAL NORM BY
PROCESS SEASON NORMS WITH ADEN
CONSTITUTIONAL STATUTORY RULES
REGULATIONS.
WHY DOES THIS MATTER?
THIS.
DEFINING THIS CREATES A
CONCEPTUAL FOUNDATION FOR HOW
EDUCATION POLICIES ARE CREATED
IN IMPLEMENTED.
THAT HELPS FRAME THE ISSUE AND
ALLOWS YOU TO UNDERSTAND THE
TOOLS AVAILABLE FOR RESOLVING
THOSE ISSUES.
PALM IT DEVELOPS A COMMON
STARTING POINT FOR DISCUSSING
GOVERNANCE ISSUES AND OTHER
EDUCATION POLICIES SO JUST SIT
THE HELP YOU ORIENT YOURSELVES.
AND IT HOPES THAT THIS GROUP WAS
SET GOALS AND MANAGE
EXPECTATIONS ON HAS. HAS KIND OF
ARTY BEEN ALLUDED TO THERE'S.
ONLY SO MUCH YOU CAN DO WHEN YOU
GOT RESTRUCTURED GOVERNANCE AT
LEAST THAT WERE AWARE OF.
I WAS SO THE CORE GOVERNANCE
MODELS ON.
THIRTY EIGHT STATES WILL FALL
INTO ONE OF THESE FOUR
CATEGORIES.
THERE ARE AS I MENTIONED THERE
ARE VARYING ALTERNATIVE METHODS
AND THEY TEND TO BE HYBRID BUT
THOSE PRIMARILY RELATE TO STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION AND. ARE NOT
THE SUPERINTENDENT'S ROLE.
WILL ONLY FOCUS ON STATE
EDUCATION OF GOVERNANCE.
.
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT LOCAL LEVEL.
BUT NOT TOO MUCH ON. LIMITED TO
EDUCATION SPECIFIC ROLE SO
NOTHING IN THESE MODELS LE. HAS
INCLUDES THE STATE LEGISLATURE
OR OTHER AGENCIES OUTSIDE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF THAT.
PALM IT'S A STARTING POINT FOR
ANALYSIS BUT I IT DOES NOT
INCLUDE SOME OF THE MORE HOW
IMPORTANT ASPECTS OF EDUCATIONAL
GOVERNANCE.
AGAIN IT ONLY APPLIES TO K.
TWELVE SYSTEMS NO HIGHER
EDUCATION EARLY LEARNING OR
OTHER STATE AGENCIES WITH
OVERLAPPING IN A.
POLICY AREAS.
AND THAT FUNCTION VARIES BY
DEGREE OF CONTROL AT THE STATE
AND LOCAL LEVELS SO POLICY
MAKING RULES VERY.
FROM STATE TO STATE EVEN IF
THEY ARE IN A SIMILAR STRUCTURE.
.
AND STATES VERY BY DEGREE OF
CONTROL AT THE STATE AND LOCAL
LEVEL.
PITCH.
BUT LIKE TO BE CLEAR THAT
THERE'S NO BEST MODEL THAT WE
ARE AWARE OF IN TERMS OF
PROVIDING A PUBLIC EDUCATION.
IN THE MODELS AS.
YOU'LL SEE ONE ODD.
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT SLIDE.
ASSUME VOTER ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT IS BUTTERS UNDERSTAND.
WHAT?
WHO'S IN CHARGE ON THEN WHO
THEY CAN HOLD.
ACCOUNTABLE ON SPECIFIC ISSUES.
SO.
BRIEFLY I WANT I DISCUSS THESE
ALL WORK FROM THE TOP DOWN
STARTING WITH THE ELECTORATE AND
WORKING DOWN INTO THE INDIVIDUAL
ROLE SO.
AND MODEL ONE VOTERS SELECT THE
GOVERNOR ON THE GOVERNOR
APPOINTS THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION THE CHIEF STATE SCHOOL
OFFICER.
AND THIS CREATES A STRONG
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
IN THE EDUCATION ARENA. IT
ALLOWS EXECUTIVES.
TUBES ARE A LOT OF CONTROL OVER
EDUCATION POLICY AND IT LEAST IN
THEORY IT WOULD CREATE A CLEAR
CHAIN OF COMMAND. HOWEVER THE
SUCCESS AND FAILURE.
EDUCATION POLICIES ARE TIED TO
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY CLARIFY
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR POLICY
PRIORITIES AND IN THE SENSE THAT
THERE'S A. GOVERNOR WHO IS
DISENGAGED OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT IT MAY ACTUALLY MUDDIED UP
THE SYSTEM.
I NEED TO THE STATES THAT.
USE MODEL ONE.
AND I'M SURE YOU SEE IT WOULD
MONEY SYSTEM OTHER JUST IF A
GOVERNOR IS NOT ENGAGED OR.
BASICALLY ALL MOST F THE.
POLICY INFLUENCES WOULD BE IN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ALL OVER
THIS AND IF THERE'S JUST NO
CLEAR LEADERSHIP AT THE TOP
THEN.
ESSENTIALLY YOU HAVE WHAT WAS
DESCRIBED HERE WHERE
EVERYBODY'S.
KIND OF DOING WHATEVER THEY A.
FEELS BEST.
MODERN.
MODEL TO VOTER SELECT THE
GOVERNOR GOVERNOR APPOINTS THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION PALM IN
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
APPOINTED CHIEF STATE SCHOOL
OFFICER. OTHER STILL STRONG
EXECUTIVE ROLE ON THEM THE CHAMP
COME COMMAND AT LEAST APPEARS
CLEAR ON THIS ONE.
THERE IS.
SOME SEPARATION TWEEN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND POLICY
IMPLEMENTATION.
IN THESE CASES THE EXECUTIVE
AND MAY NOT BE ABLE TO PER BY
DIRECT OVERSIGHT OVER
IMPLEMENTATION AND
ADMINISTRATION POLICY AND. AGAIN
IF THE RULES ARE CLARIFIED LINES
WE COUNT ABILITY ARE STILL
UNCLEAR.
IN THESE OF THE SEATS HUSING
MODEL TO.
A.
MODEL THREE VOTERS SELECT THE
GOVERNOR AND THE CHIEF STATE
SCHOOL OFFICER INDEPENDENTLY IN
THE GOVERNOR APPOINTS THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION.
AND.
AS WAS MENTIONED HERE.
CALIFORNIA HAS A NON PARTISAN
CONTEST IT'S THE ONLY STATE WERE
AWARE OF THAT EXPLICITLY HAS A
NONPARTISAN HIGH RES MENTIONED
AND LAW.
WHEN THE GOVERNOR IN THE CC.
CHIEF STATE SCHOOL OFFICERS
PRIORITIES ALIGNED THERE'S.
THERE MAY BE A GREATER ABILITY
TO INFLUENCE POLICY AND.
PERIODICALLY CLEAR LINE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR BOATERS
SPECIFICALLY.
HOWEVER THE MODEL RELIES ON
POLICY PRIORITY ALIGNMENT
BETWEEN THE EXECUTIVE IN THE
CHURCH ACHIEVE STATE SCHOOL
OFFICER ON THE MORE COMPLEX
MODEL THEM IN TERMS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY. THAT MAKES.
ISSUE IDENTIFICATION AND.
RESOLUTION DIFFICULT IF THE
RULES AREN'T ACTING IN
CONJUNCTION WITH EACH OTHER.
THE STATE'S WITHOUT MONO.
AND MODEL FOR MOTOR SELECT THE
GOVERNOR AND THE STATE BOARD OF.
EDUCATION INDEPENDENTLY THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
APPOINTS A CHIEF STATE SCHOOL
OFFICER.
AGAIN MICHIGAN IS THE ONLY
STATE THAT WERE AWARE OF THAT
HAS A NONPARTISAN HOT RACES PALM
HOWEVER.
WHILE OTHER.
ELECTIONS THEMSELVES ARE
NONPARTISAN AND.
STATE PARTY CONVENTION SELECT
THE CANDIDATES SO.
.
THIS ALLOWS THE STATE BOARD
EDUCATION TO STEER POLICY
PRIORITIES ON THEORETICALLY
AGAIN CLEAR LINES OF
ACCOUNTABILITY.
IN DIFFERENT POLITICAL AND
CONTEXTUAL ELEMENTS MAY DRIVE
THE BEATS. DIFFERENT FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN THE STATE
BOARD.
AND IT'S EASIER TO IDENTIFY IN
THEORY WHO'S IN CHARGE.
.
HOWEVER THE EXECUTIVE MAY NOT
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR A POLICY
PRIORITIES LIMITED ABILITY TO
IMPLEMENT LARGER REFORMS I'M
REQUIRING SIGNIFICANT FUNDING OR
SUBSTANTIAL POLICY CHANGES MAY
ALSO.
BUT BE A DOWNSIDE TO THAT.
ON.
IN THOSE TWO STATES TOMORROW
FOR.
.
AND JUST SOME OF OUR RECENT
GOVERNANCE CHANGES.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THESE ARE JUST AN OVERVIEW AND.
TRYING TO PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT
FOR THE DISCUSSION ON.
THIS REPRESENTS A BEST GUESS OF.
ELISE FOR THE POLICIES THAT ARE
BEING CONSIDERED THIS YEAR OF.
OF WHAT'S GOING ON ON WE DON'T
REALLY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ASSESS THE LIKELIHOOD OF PASSAGE
OR. A WHETHER IN THE CASE OF
NORTH CAROLINA WHAT THE OUTCOME
OF THAT SUPREME COURT AYE CASE
WILL BE.
BUT.
LAST YEAR INDIANA WITH EACH BE
ONE ZERO ZERO FIVE CHANGE THE
ROLE OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION.
AND TOOK.
FROM AN ELECTED POSITION TO AN
APPOINTED POSITION AFTER JANUARY
TEN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
THAN THIS YEAR NEBRASKA IS
CONSIDERING A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT TO ELIMINATE THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION.
NEW YORK IS SIMILARLY
CONSIDERING ABOLISHING THE
BORDER FOR BUT I REGION'S AND
TRANSFERRING POWER.
POWERS AND DUTIES TO THE
COMMISSIONER OF EDUCATION.
SOUTH CAROLINA IT HAS CARRY
OVER LEGISLATION FROM LAST YEAR.
CONSIDERING CHANGING
SUPERINTENDENT OF FROM AN
ELECTED POSITION TO.
CABINET APPOINTED POSITION. AND
AS I SAID.
NORTH CAROLINA HAS.
A COURTESAN FROM THE SUPREME
COURT ON WHETHER LAWMAKERS CAN
DIMINISH THE AUTHORITY OF THE
APPOINTED STATE BOARD. ON IN
INSTEAD GIVE UP BUDGETARY
CONTROL TO THE CHIEF STATE
SCHOOL OFFICER.
JUST SOME POLICY CONSIDERATIONS
A THIRD FRAME ORIENT THE DEBATE.
ON BEING AWARE OF THE IMPACT
GOVERNMENT'S CHANGES MAY HAVE ON
THE STATE AND LOCAL DYNAMIC ON
THERE'S AN INHERENT TENSION.
BETWEEN STATE GOVERNMENT LOCAL
DISTRICTS IT'S NOT UNHEALTHY
IT'S JUST CONSTANTLY THERE.
GOVERNANCE CHANGES WILL LIKELY
CHANGE THAT DYNAMIC IN SOME WAY.
BOB PORTER REASSESSING THE ROLE
MAY MEAN RETHINKING AND BROADER
TERMS OF THE ROLE OF STATES AND
DISTRICTS.
.
ESTABLISH CLEAR GOALS OUR VISION
OF FOR APPROACHING GOVERNANCE
CHANGES THAT MANAGING
EXPECTATIONS FOR WHAT YOU CAN
ACCOMPLISH OR WHAT THIS WILL IN
FACT DO.
IS IMPORTANT.
AND FOCUSING THE DEBATE ON
SIMPLY WILL.
THE KEY TOPICS ARE THAT ARE
BEING DISCUSSED.
AND IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO HAVE
A SENSE OF.
PERFORMANCE METRICS HOW WE KNOW
IT THIS IS WORKING AND HOW WILL
YOU KNOW THAT'S IMPROVING
THINGS.
ALSO CONSIDER OTHER HOW CHANGES
ONE WITH YOUR STATE PLAN.
INSURING DOES SO IMPLEMENTATION
IS DONE.
CORRECTLY.
IS VERY IMPORTANT.
AND OF BOYD CONFLICTING MANDATES
AND PRIORITIES DURING THE INPUT
IMPLEMENTATION AND
ADMINISTRATION OF THE LAW.
AND.
CLEARLY ESTABLISHED RULE SO.
THAT SHOULD BE OBVIOUS GIVEN
THE CONTEXT OF THIS DISCUSSION
BUT CHANGING THE STRUCTURE DOES
NOT NECESSARILY MEAN THAT ROLE
CLARITY IS ACHIEVED.
ADEN IN THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
ROLES OR THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES
WON'T CHANGE OVER TIME.
RUN INTO SOME QUESTIONS.
WHAT ARE THE CORE ISSUES YOU'RE
TRYING TO RESOLVE?
WILL PROPONENT PROPOSE
SOLUTIONS ADEQUATELY RESOLVE THE
ISSUE.
HOW WILL PROPOSED SOLUTIONS
IMPACT WORKING RELATIONSHIPS
AMONG POLICY LEADERS?
AND IS IT POSSIBLE TO CONSIDER
THE LONG TERM AFFECTS OF A
CHANGE.
AND I'LL CONCLUDE WITH.
JUST SOME RESOURCES THAT WE
HAVE ON THIS ISSUE IF YOU WILL
PA WANT MORE ON THE NATIONWIDE
VIEW.
THE STATE EDUCATION GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURES UP THE IT EXPANDS ON
SOME OF THE.
JUSTIN
MODEL.
AND THE <c.green> FIFTY STAY</c>
COMPARISON ON K. TWELVE.
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURES WILL.
HIGHLIGHTS THE.
FORMAL CON CONSTITUTIONAL AND
STATUTORY ROLE OF GOVERNORS
LEGISLATORS.
.
STATE BOARDS OF EDUCATION CHIEF
STATE SCHOOL OFFICERS AND
EXECUTIVE SECRETARIES OF THE
STATE HOUSE ONE. THANK YOU.
PQ. CARRIED ON. YES BUT THANK
YOU VERY VERY.
.
FORGET PRESENTATION WITH REGARD
TO THE GOVERNANCE MODEL.
.
IS THERE ANY METRIC.
ASSOCIATED.
WITH THE CHANGE IN THE
GOVERNANCE MODEL OR AN EXISTING
GOVERNANCE MODEL.
THAT POINTS TO WHAT GOVERNANCE
MODEL WE SHOULD HAVE FOR AND
METRIC ASSOCIATED WITH REALLY
FROM TALKING STUDENT SUCCESS YOU
HEARD ME TODAY I'M REALLY FOCUS
ON STUDENT SUCCESS REALLY
CALIFORNIA. CLOSING THAT
ACHIEVEMENT GAP BECAUSE IN MANY
WAYS CALIFORNIA WERE DOING
BETTER THAN WE EVER HAVE YET WE
HAVE MORE CHALLENGES.
BUT WE'VE EVER HAD SO AGAIN IS
THERE ANY METRIC ASSOCIATED WITH
WITH. WITH LIKE WITH ANY
SPECIFIC GOVERNANCE MODEL OR ANY
SPECIFIC CHANGE. ANNA GOVERNANCE
MODEL THAT'S QUANTITATIVE NOT
NECESSARILY QUALITATIVE.
BUT I'M SO THIS IS AN AREA OF
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURES AND
STUDENT OUTCOMES IS UNCLEAR AND
IT'S JUST NOT VERY WELL
RESEARCHED AND THERE'S A NUMBER
OF VARIABLES IN BETWEEN YOUR
STATE LEVEL GOVERNANCE AND.
THE STUDENTS HOWEVER THERE IS
ON. I'M AWARE OF AT LEAST ONE
REPORT.
THAT ACTUALLY STUDY CALIFORNIA
TEXAS AND FLORIDA THAT KIND OF
CAME UP WITH SOME.
VERY GENERAL AREAS.
THAT COULD BE USED TO ASSESS ON
THE SO.
IN THE RICH IN BROAD TERMS ON
STABILITY ACCOUNTABILITY
INNOVATION FLEXIBILITY AND
RESPONSIVENESS TRANSPARENCY AND
SIMPLICITY AND EFFICIENCY ARE OF
THE CORE METRICS AND THEY USED
ON. BUT THESE WEREN'T DONE WITH.
.
CHANGES FROM SAY CHANGING FROM
MODEL ONCE MODEL TO IT WAS JUST
A SIMPLE ASSESSMENT OF WHERE THE
CURRENT GOVERNANCE STRUCTURES
STOOD.
BUT SO TO PUT IT SHORTLY NOBODY
ACTUALLY.
KNOWS WHAT THE OUTCOME IS THAT
THE STUDENT LEVEL ONCE YOU
CHANGE THE GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE.
I'M GOOD PHD DISSERTATION I
ASSUME VERY SOMEONE WHO NEED
SOMETHING ORIGINAL MIGHT GO
THERE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
MEAN.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE
ORGANIZATIONAL BOXES BUT I GUESS
THAT.
YOU COUPLE QUESTIONS AROUND
ELITE HAVE THE ANSWER TO THIS OR
NOT. US SO ONES IN TERMS OF THE.
DIFFERENT MODELS THEY HAVE AT
THE STATE LEVEL THAT CORRESPOND
IN ANY WAY TOO HOW THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE STATE
AND THE LOCALS OPERATE THAT
STATE SO. LUCAS CERTAIN MODELS
MAINLAND MORE TO A CERTAIN TYPE
OF RELATIONSHIP ANOTHER. WITH
SUCH A LOCAL ENTITIES.
THAT OUR GOVERNING EDUCATION
AND STATE SO YOU KNOW WE. IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE WELL MULTI
LAYERS AND WE'VE COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION WITH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IT CETERA RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE STATE ENTITIES AND
THOSE ENTITIES.
WHAT ONE MIGHT ARGUE AGAIN I
DON'T KNOW?
YOU KNOW SO. THAT DOES THAT IF
THERE IS IF THE STATE HAS MORE
INFLUENCE OVER THE LOCALS THIS
THAT BAND SPEAKTO A PARTICULAR
TYPE OF GOVERNANCE AT THE STATE
THAT EITHER MAKES MORE EFFECTIVE
ORDER TENDS TO LEAN. A CERTAIN
WAY NO ONE COMMENTS PEOPLE HAVE
MADE ABOUT CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY
AFTER PROP THIRTEEN IS IS THAT
WE EXERCISE THROUGH.
BUDGETARY AUTHORITY AND WE HAVE
MOVED.
DECIDED TO MOVE TOWARD A MORE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
BUT. WE CAN BE VERY DIRECTIVE
BECAUSE WE ACTUALLY CONTROLADA
PURSE STRINGS VERSES.
OTHER STATES WHERE ACTUALLY
PERHAPS THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
RAISE MORE OF THEIR OWN MONEY
AND ARE LESS DEPENDENT ON THE
STATE GOVERNMENT FOR. RESOURCES
SELF AND IF YOU ANYONE LOOKED AT
THAT ARE YOU CAN COMMENT ON ON
HOUSE THE STRUCTURE MAY
CORRELATE WITH RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE STATES AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OR WHATEVER LOCAL
ENTITY GOVERNS EDUCATION IN THAT
PARTICULAR STATE.
DONE SO AGAIN THIS ISN'T AN AREA
THAT'S BEEN WIDELY STUDIED SO IN
TERMS OF.
THE IMMEDIATE QUESTION OF
WHETHER THERE'S A CORRELATION
BETWEEN A LOCAL STRUCTURE IN THE
STATE'S STRUCTURE.
.
I DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER FOR THAT
AND A LOT OF THE WAY. OF STATE
AND LOCAL STRUCTURES HAVE
DEVELOPED HAVE NOT BEEN.
SO MUCH.
INTENTIONAL DECISIONS BUT JUST
WAIT THE WAY THINGS HAVE EVOLVED
OVER TIME. I WILL POINT TO.
ONE STUDY TO SORT OF ADDRESS
THE CENTRALIZATION VERSUS LOCAL
CONTROL.
WHERE? PERHAPS IN THAT THE
DICHOTOMY NEED ISN'T.
HOLY RELEVANT ANYMORE IN THE
SENSE THAT IT THERE'S NO STATE
THAT'S ENTIRELY LOCAL CONTROL
AND ENTIRELY CENTRALIZE BUT.
ON.
THE STUDY I'M REFERRING TO
ASSESS WHETHER CENTRALIZATION
HELPS DO NOW COMES VERSES A
LOCAL CONTROL. AND WHAT THEY
FOUND WAS ESSENTIALLY DONE YOU
HAVE TO BE MORE NUANCED ABOUT
WHAT YOU WANT THE STATE
CONTROLLING HIM WAT YOU WANT OF
LOCAL DISTRICTS CONTROLLING.
ON AND AT THE END OF THE DAY IT
SORT OF COME SOUND TO.
WHAT ALLOWS A? LOCAL DISTRICTS
TO FOCUS ON STUDENTS AND WHAT
ASPECTS.
CAN THE STATE'S TAKE OFF ON THE
DISTRICTS MY A PLATE.
OKAY.
AND THE. OTHER QUESTION IS IN
RELATION TO. ITEM IT'S YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THESE.
.
BOB SO YOU MADE THE COMMENT THAT
FOR EXAMPLE MODEL ONE WHERE
BASICALLY THE GOVERNOR APPOINTS
EVERYBODY.
THAT OBVIOUSLY THAT IT'S YOU
KNOW DODD VT DIRECTION EDUCATION
POLICY DEPENDS ON WHAT PRIORITY
THE GOVERNOR GIVES OF THE
GOVERNOR.
MAKES A VERY LOW PRIORITY THEN
IF THERE'S.
VERY LITTLE EMPHASIS RIGHT.
IF THE GOVERNMENT'S A HIGH
PRIORITY TO DRIVE A LOT OF
CHANGE BECAUSE EVERYONE HAS GOOD
POINT.
BY THE GOVERNOR.
SO I I GUESS THE THE THE
QUESTION IS IS THAT WE'VE SEEN
THIS ACTUALLY LOCAL AREAS AS
WELL SO WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT.
.
EDUCATION IS SOMETHING THAT IS
pPOPULACE.
BUT.
IF EDUCATION IS SEPARATED FROM
LET'S SAY THE GOVERNOR AND
ALLEGE THE OF THE GOVERNOR.
DE DO YOU SEE.
THE.
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE BEING I WOULD
SAY LESS INTERESTED BUT LESS
ENGAGED AND THEREFORE WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT ALL THE DIFFERENT
EASE AFFECT EDUCATION NOT JUST.
EDUCATION DIRECTLY
YOU SEE LESS COORDINATION BUT
SAY BETWEEN EDUCATION AND OTHER
PARTS OF GOVERNMENT FUNCTIONS.
AB BECAUSE THOSE.
FOLKS ARE SEPARATED AND A LATE
AT NIGHT BLADES GIVE YOU MAY
PRESS LOCALS AND SOMETIMES FOR
EXAMPLE WE'VE SEEN MARES WHO
DON'T OVERSEE THEIR LOCAL
EDUCATION TRIED INSERT
THEMSELVES IN EDUCATION. AT
TIMES.
BECAUSE BATES FEEL THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THE THEIR DIALECT
IT IS VERY CONCERNED ABOUT.
OR YOU COULD HAVE SAVED YOU
HAVE OFFICIALS AND SAY WELL YOU
KNOW EDUCATION ISN'T PART OF
MIND IT SEPARATELY ELECTED
SEPARATELY APPOINTED WHATEVER
AND THEREFORE EVEN THOUGH IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ME.
I'M NOT GONNA DO ANYTHING ABOUT
IT AND THEY JUST GO OFF ON THEIR
OWN SO. I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT
HOW THE STRUCTURES THAN
INFLUENCE
HOPE WHAT PRIORITY A.
GOVERNOR MAKES EDUCATION SO
THERE'S THE PARTNER THE PART
ABOUT WELL IF EVER IF
EVERYTHING'S APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR AND THE GOVERNMENT IS A
CARE ABOUT EDUCATION THAT CARE
BUT DOESN'T A HIGH PRIORITY
TACTIC LANGUISH BUT ALSO A
SERIOUS SITUATION WHERE. THE
GOVERNOR DOESN'T HAVE OVERSIGHT
OVER IS IS ENOUGH OVERSIGHT OF
EDUCATION ARTS ARE PARSED OUT
TODAY AND THERE'S LESS.
OF A DESIRE ARE LESS. INTERESTED
IN ARE AT IT IN IN BAD AND THE
GOVERNOR AND TRYING TO PURSUE
EDUCATIONAL PRIORITIES.
BECAUSE OF THAT BECAUSE THEY
HAVE LESS ABILITY TO INFLUENCE
THAT.
SO AGAIN IT'S LOW DIFFICULT TO
SAY JUST BECAUSE OF THEIR ISN'T
MUCH RESEARCH ON THIS AYE. I
MEAN WHEN I SAY THERE IS A OF
THE GOVERNOR MAY BE LESS
INTERESTED I THINK THEY MAY BE
LESS INTERESTED IN THE SENSE
THAT THEY CAN. MOON MAY OR MAY
NOT HAVE LIKE MORE AMBITIOUS
PLANS FOR WHERE THEY SEE THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM GOING I THINK
IT'S A HILL LEAST AT THE STATE
LEVEL EDUCATE.
K. TWELVE IS
A PRETTY SUBSTANTIAL PART OF THE
BUDGET SO THEY'RE ALWAYS GOING
TO HAVE.
SOME INTEREST IN AND.
BUT I THINK WHERE IF.
TO ANSWER THE BEST I CAN THE
ONLY.
THE DISTINCTION WILL BE WHETHER
THEY CARE ABOUT.
.
YOU KNOW TAKING A.
FOR INSTANCE IN COLORADO LIKE.
P. THREE READING AND THE.
OR DOES SOMETHING A BIG POLICY
INITIATIVE LIKE THAT THAT'S
WHERE YOU'LL SEE THAT
DISTINCTION.
SO IT'S NOT LIKE THEY'RE PERHAPS
MORE WORK TO.
LET INFORMED DECISIONS MIGHT BE
NECESSARY YES
OKAY.
STATE OF.
THANKS FOR A FOR THE
PRESENTATION I SOCIAL TO FOLLOW
UP ON CHAIR.
O'DONNELL'S QUESTIONS EYES SO I
I BELIEVE YOU SAID THERE IS NO
REAL EVIDENCE OUT THERE IS TO.
TO RELIABLE POINT TO WHETHER
ONE OF THESE FOUR PREVAILING
MODELS WORKS BUT AND OTHERS THAT
RIGHT.
SO CALIFORNIA WERE TO MAKE.
SOME SORT OF CHANGE THAT WOULD
NOT BE ON THE BASIS OF REALLY
ANY RELIABLE EXISTING EVIDENCE.
NOT ANY QUANTIFIABLE EVIDENCE
THAT I'M AWARE OF. A CAT. AND SO
I WON THE RECOMMENDATIONS I
THINK WAS TO ESTABLISH AYE
METRICS GOING FORWARD IF WE WERE
TO CREATE OUT WORD BEFORE FOR
THE CHANGE A MANY SIDED ONE
STUDY THAT HAD. SOMEONE I THINK
DESCRIBES METRICS BUT THERE SEEM
TO BE MORE TO ME LIKE IDEALS
LIKE SIMPLICITY AND THINGS LIKE
THAT SO DO YOU HAVE ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS UP FOR WHAT
THOSE METRICS OUGHT TO BE.
UN
SO NOT OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD I
DO THINK.
GOING BACK.
IN TERMS OF THE SALAS SHIRLEY
ESTABLISHING A GOAL OR VISION
FOR WHAT YOU WANT TO ACCOMPLISH
IS.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING SO. I
TO GIVE YOU A SENSE.
IS THERE'S YOUR* CONSTANTLY
BOUNCING PRIORITIES SO DO YOU
WANT THE POLICY MAKING PROCESS
TO BE MORE EFFICIENT YOU WANT TO
BE MORE TRANSPARENT YOU WANT.
.
BETTER CHECKS AND BALANCES THESE
ARE ALL THINGS THAT ARE GOING TO
DICTATE WHETHER YOU WANT TO
MAKE-A CHANGE OR YOU WANT TO
JUST.
UP PERHAPS PROVIDE MORE CLARITY
IN.
EXISTING ROLES OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT SO. ON MY SUGGEST IF I
HAD IS SUGGESTION IT'S SIMPLY
JUST TO.
.
CONSIDER WHAT YOU HOPE TO
ACCOMPLISH BEFORE MAKING ANY
CHANGES AND THEN.
.
DETERMINE WHAT THE KEY METRICS
WILL BE FROM THERE BECAUSE IT'S
REALLY HARD TO ASSESS.
WHAT EVEN?
HOW YOU WOULD?
QUANTIFY A GOOD GOVERNMENT
SYSTEM JUST BECAUSE.
IN A LOT OF CASES THESE ARE
BASED ON.
VALUES JUDGMENTS ABOUT HOW YOU
WANT THE EXISTING LOCAL AND
STATE DYNAMIC TO BE OR.
WHAT YOU WANT STUDENT OUTCOMES
TO HOPEFULLY LOOK LIKE IN THE
FUTURE AND HOW THE STATE WILL
SUPPORT IT?
WELL APPRECIATED I ALSO WANT TO
JUST POINT OUT THAT AND. YOU'VE
GOT OF EXCELLENT FIFTY STATE
REVIEW THAT CAME OUT LAST YEAR
THAT'S AND EVANS PACKETS AND I
THINK SOME OF THE MEMBERS AN
OPPORTUNITY REVIEW IT EARLIER
BUT IT BASICALLY OUTLINES MOST
OF WHICH YOU PRESENTED.
BUT HE'S VERY STRUCTURES AND
DOWN.
YOU KNOW IT'S A.
EXAMPLES OF THERE'S NO PERFECT
WAY TO DO THIS SO WE DO
APPRECIATE YOUR.
COMING TO US WITH THESE REYES
MODELS AND I THINK THAT TERADATA
HAS A DISMAL COMMENT IS A
COMMENT HERE JUST KIND OF. THIS
IS JUST I'M GONNA ME THINKING
BEHIND THE RAIL HERE HAVING BEEN
A TEACHER IN THE POSSIBLE TWENTY
TWO YEARS.
I I JUST WANNA BE CAREFUL IF YOU
LOOK AT THE MINE SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY WE CAN DRIVE ALL THE
SUCCESS FROM SACRAMENTO HE SAID
VERY MUCH CONCERNED TAKE AS WE
TRIED THAT.
OKAY WHAT ABOUT.
BUT EIGHTEEN YEARS AGO FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO WE CAME AND WE SAID
OKAY.
STATE BOARD ADOPTED LIKE THERE
WERE TWO ADOPTIONS AND ONE WAS
COMMON CORE ONE WASN'T MOUSE YOU
LITERALLY HAD. TEACHERS ON PAGE
FOUR.
RIDE IN ON TUESDAY YOU NO NO FOR
THE EVERY TEACHERS ON PAGE FOUR
AND THEY WERE SCRIPT WAS THE
WORST IN OPEN COURT THEIR
SCRIPTED.
YEAH LESSONS THEY READ OUT WHAT
THEY HAD TO READ STUDENTS
LITERALLY SAT.
IN A ON A CARPET AND ALL HAD A
NUMBER IT WAS VERY REGIMENTED.
WE TRIED THAT APPROACH AND IT
DIDN'T WORK.
BUT WE DID WAS WE WE MICROMANAGE
FROM SACRAMENTO SO ON TO BE
CAREFUL THAT WE DON'T THINK
THAT.
THAT WORKS BECAUSE WE TRIED IT.
AND NOW WE'RE UNDER THE ERA OF
LOCAL CONTROL LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA COUNTRY YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH.
AND IT'S UST PER WORD WE'RE
TRYING ANOTHER APPROACH WERE
TRYING TO GET THERE. BUT I JUST
DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO THINK THAT
YOU KNOW THAT THERE'S SOMETHING
WE CAN DO ONE THING WE CAN DO IN
SACRAMENTO.
TO MAKE.
MAKE EVERY CHILD SUCCESSFULLY
CALIFORNIA'S SCHOOLS CANNOT
HAPPEN IN THE CLASSROOM IT'S
GOTTA HAPPEN AT LOCAL LEVEL. AND
IT CAN'T ALL BE DRIVEN FROM
SACRAMENTO.
ED I JUST ONE OF THE THING TO
POINT OUT ON. A DATE DUBS AGREE
WITH THE CHAIR'S COMMENTS.
.
ONE OF THEM TO POINT AS THE YOU
ALSO MEDITATING ONLY THIRTY FOR
THE STATE'S FIT INTO ONE OF THE
FOUR MODELS YOU DESCRIBED.
BUT THERE OF COURSE.
SIXTEEN OTHER STATES AND AND I
THINK YOU LAME OUT PRETTY NICELY
ON PAGE FIVE OF YOUR REPORT
OTHER GOVERNMENTS MODELS AND THE
THE BUT WITH A. RANGE FROM.
GOVERNOR LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR AND
SPEAKER APPOINTING MEMBERS THE
STATE BOARD AS THEY DO IN
MISSISSIPPI RIGHT THE WAY OVER
TO THE COME HYBRID MODELS WHERE
YOU'VE GOT.
PART OF THE BOARD ELECTED PART
OF THE BOARD APPOINTED AS A LOT
OF DIFFERENT IDEAS OUT THERE BUT
TEN BUT ULTIMATELY AFRAID I MEAN
IT'S IT'S.
I GUESS THE QUESTION WE HAVE IS
HOW DO YOU CREATE A STRUCTURE
THAT WILL PASSED.
ALLOW FOR THE THE SORT OF I GOT
YOU A FLOWERING FITTED TO.
THERE'S ALSO JUST GIVE I COULD
JUST IF WE GO BACK TO HISTORY
PROBABLY PRE PROP THIRTEEN THE
DYNAMIC IN SACRAMENTO WAS
PROBABLY VERY DIFFERENT.
BECAUSE THE FUNDING MODEL WAS
DIFFERENT MOST OF THE MONEY CAME
APPROVED CAME FROM THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
SO EVEN LOCALS PROBABLY DIDN'T
SEE GOVERNANCE
OR A MUCH INPUT FROM THE
SACRAMENTO LEVEL NOW THAT
SACRAMENTO'S IN CHARGE OF THE
DOLLARS THEY'RE SEEKING TO HAVE
MUCH GREATER SAID.
YEAH YEAH CENTER PAN THAT THAT'S
PART OF REASON I ASKED MY FIRST
THAT QUESTION IS IS THAT YOU
KNOW. OBVIOUSLY WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE YOUR CLASS FIND STATES
DIFFER MODELS BUT. SOME OF IT
HAS TO DO WITH WILL HOW DO YOU
STRUCTURE THE WHOLE.
THING IN THE STATE MUST RELATION
BETWEEN THE STATE THE LOCALS
FUNDING OTHER TYPES OF THINGS
LEVERS OF FOR. PAUL AND I AND I
THINK THE OTHER.
ISSUE IS YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE
YOU SAID WE DON'T HAVE MUCH DATA
ON WHICH MY LIFE BUT ALSO THAT
BAGS LIKE TO IS THE DATE EVEN
OUT THERE IF WE HAD A
RESEARCHER.
IT WENT IT DO WE HAVE
PERFORMANCE DATA ETCETERA. DO
YOU HAVE INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
DOES THE PUBLIC IN THE EACH
STATE WITH DIFFERENT MODELS
WHICH
WHICH ONE OF THEM ACTUALLY. ADD
HAVE A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING ABOUT
WHAT. THE GOALS ARE FOR THE
STATE EDUCATION AND.
RECOGNIZING THAT ACTUAL
IMPLEMENTATION TAKING PLACE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL BUT THERE'S
SENSE LIKE WHAT WHAT ARE WHAT
OUR MAIN PRIORITIES AND GOALS
WHAT ARE. AND.
AND IT AND NUMBER THEY'RE
MAKING PROGRESS ON THEM OR NOT
RIGHT I MEAN I THINK. IF YOU ASK
THE PERSON ON THE STREET ABOUT
THAT.
NOW DO THEY HAVE ANY IDEA. ARE
NOT AND IS THERE IS THERE ANY
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN BETWEEN THE
DIFFERENT MODELS IN TERMS OF
THAT CLARITY WHO'S WHO'S ABLE TO
TO BE THE SPOKESPERSON HIS ABLE
TO BE.
THE ATTITUDE TO SERVE BILL THE
PUBLIC WILL.
TWO TRY TO.
TO TO MOVE AHEAD.
EDUCATIONAL PRIORITIES.
BUT THE PERSON YOU COME IN AND.
PROCEDURE PRESENTATION ALSO
APPRECIATE THE CONTINUE WORK OF
WORLD ANY DOING TOGETHER.
ON A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT ISSUES
RELATING TO EDUCATION POLICY
MAKING AND AND SIR THANK YOU
GUYS. FEEL THANK YOU BUSINESS A
GOOD SEGUE FOR FOR OF AS.
MR SCHNEIER AT JAMES DIRE WHOSE
SIDE FOUNDER AND CEO OF COMMON
SENSE ACTION FOR KIDS WHO HAS.
A PROPOSED A RELATING TO. SOME
SYSTEM CHANGES IN GOVERNANCE
THAT HE'D. LIKE US TO CONSIDER
WE WELCOME YOU TO.
BUT HEARING HERE TODAY MISTER
STARR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN.
HOW HELLO EVERYBODY HAPPY
VALENTINE'S DAY?
?
ACTUALLY I THINK BIG PICTURE WE
THINK THAT.
DONE WELL BY THIS SUB COMMITTEE
THIS.
JOINT COMMITTEE WHICH WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU ALL COMING
TOGETHER FOR. BY THIS COULD BE
THIS KIND OF.
CHANGE THAT WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING COULD BE A BIG
VALENTINE'S DAY PRESENT AND HERE
I MULTI YEAR PRESENT TO THE KIDS
OF CALIFORNIA SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TAKING THE TIME.
JUST FOR TINY BIT BACK WHEN I AM
ON THAT CD OF COMMON SENSE
MEDIA.
OUR OUR POLITICAL.
ADVOCACY ARMS CALLED COMMON
SENSE KIDS ACTION AS MANY OF YOU
MAY KNOW.
WE HAVE A CONSUMER PLATFORM
WITH NEARLY A HUNDRED MILLION
USERS AND CONSUMERS AND WE HAVE
A SCHOOLS PLATFORM THAT SEND
BACK TO THIRD TO THE SCHOOL THE
UNITED STATES FOCUS PRIMARILY
ON.
DIGITAL CITIZENSHIP AND DIGITAL
LITERACY WORK FOR CATS ON AS
PART OF MY BACKGROUND TO I ALSO
THE FOUNDER OF CHILDREN NOW IRAN
CHILDREN NOW FOR THE FIRST NINE
YEARS OF ITS EXISTENCE. I'M AND
I'M A PROFESSOR IN THE SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION. AT STANFORD WHERE. I
HATE I HATE TO ADMIT I'VE BEEN
THERE FOR THIRTY YEARS AND MY
COLLEAGUES INCLUDE MIKE KIRST
WHOM YOU ALL KNOW FROM THE STATE
BOARD. LINDA DARLING HAMMOND
OTHER FOLKS WHO HAD A BIG IMPACT
ON EDUCATION HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
BOMB THE BOTTOM LINE FOR US ON
MASS BIG PICTURE IS THAT WE
BELIEVE.
THAT A THOUGHTFUL OF LOOK IN
RESTRUCTURING OF THE GOVERNANCE
OF THE OF OF EDUCATION K.
THROUGH TWELVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WILL HAVE A LONG TERM POSITIVE
IMPACT ON THE LIVES OF KIDS AND
THE SCHOOLS IN THIS STATE.
ARM AND.
WE TAKE IT IS A ONE KEY ELEMENT
OF A BIGGER PICTURE BUT AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT ONE. AND
THAT IF THIS COMMITTEE ACT
CONTINUES TO LEAD BETWEEN THE
TWO HOUSES OF THE LEGISLATURE.
AYE THAT THIS WILL HAVE REALLY
SIGNIFICANT LONG TERM POSITIVE
IMPACTS I'M KIDS IN SCHOOLS AND
THAT I KNOW YOU ALL ON THIS
COMMITTEE. BECAUSE YOU CARE
ABOUT THAT
SO.
AYE WE'RE DELIGHTED THAT YOU'RE
TAKING THE TIME TO DO THIS
JOINTLY BOTH THROUGH THE
CHAIRMAN PULLING THIS TOGETHER
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU
ON IT IN LEADING UP TO THE
PROPOSAL AND ON THE NET DESCRIBE
BRIEFLY. WE MET WITH PEOPLE ALL
ACROSS THE STATE ARM AT THE
COMMUNITY LEVEL I'M AT THAT
SCHOOLS A LEVEL BUT ALSO.
TALKING TO A LOT OF THE BIG
PLAYERS HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN THE
SUPERINTENDENT'S OFFICE.
.
FORMER UP THAT I STATE OFFICIALS
ETCETERA. AND THERE WAS PRETTY
MUCH UNANIMOUS AGREEMENT IN IN
OUR IN OUR YEAR LONG EFFORT TO
TAKE A LOOK AT PASS. THAT IT'S
AWFUL RESTRUCTURING OF THE
GOVERNANCE MODEL HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A VERY
POSITIVE IMPACT ON. THE SYSTEM
OF EDUCATION AND QUITE HONESTLY
THE OUTCOMES FOR CATS. AND I
HEARD THE QUESTION AND A VERY
GOOD QUESTION ACTUALLY CHAIRMAN
O'DONNELL ABOUT PROOF AND
EVIDENCE ABOUT ABOUT IMPACT AND
I THINK OUR PRIOR SPEAKERS WERE
WE'RE CLEAR THAT. IT YOU HAVE TO
EXTRAPOLATE IF YOU WILL FROM
GOVERNMENTS TO ACTUAL STUDENT
OUTCOMES AND I KNOW WE ALL CARE
ABOUT STUDENT OUTCOMES AND A
BETTER EDUCATION SYSTEM. AND I
KNOW WE ALL KNOW THE STATS ON
CALIFORNIA TO THAT YOU KNOW WERE
IN THE FORTIES WHEN IT COMES TO
A PER PUPIL SPENDING.
AND ACTUALLY HOW WERE RANKED AS
A STATE COMPARED TO OTHER STATES
IN THE COUNTRY.
I THINK IT'S A VERY GOOD
QUESTION THAT YOU ASKED. AS
ELEMENT O'DONNELL BUT BUT I DO
THINK THAT ON A FUNDAMENTAL
LEVEL.
ACCOUNTABILITY TRANSPARENCY
SIMPLICITY MAKE A LOT OF SENSE
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
DELIVERING SERVICES TICKETS
THROUGH SCHOOLS AND IT IN THIS
STATE. AND SO THAT'S WHY WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS IMPORTANT
ABOUT FIVE POINTS YOU JUST MAKE
FOR YOU OVERALL AND I AM NOT BUT
I DO NOT AT THE LEVEL OF
EXPERTISE SAYS. AS I CAN COMBINE
DOES FROM THE LA O. OR THE
CHANCE FROM.
.
FROM THE EDUCATION WHICH THE
STATES BUT I THINK.
THIRTY YEARS WORKING ON THIS
LEADS ME DEBTS. I'M AND COMMENTS
I THOUGHT FIVE BIG POINTS FIRST.
THERE'S BEEN A LONG TERM
STRUCTURAL CHALLENGE THAT I
MISTER COUPON LAID OUT FOR YOU
THAT'S BEEN IDENTIFIED
CALIFORNIA FOR A HUNDRED YEARS
IN THE STRUCTURE OF EDUCATION
GOVERNMENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND ALL OF DEAD WHENEVER THEY
HAVE A HOOVER COMMISSION OR A
BIG STUDY AS YOU MENTIONED TN
YEARS AGO. THERE'S A
RECOMMENDATION TO CHANGE THE
GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE AND
SIMPLIFY AT AND MAKE IT MORE
TRANSPARENT AT TRANSPARENT
ACCOUNTABLE.
SO AND THIS IS BEEN.
BROUGHT UP BY GOVERNOR'S
ATTORNEYS GENERAL THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE COURTS AND
ALL WHO SEEMS SORT OF A
BALKANIZED STRUCTURE.
AND WE'RE NOT COMING YEAR JASON
WE HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS BECAUSE
WE BELIEVE YOU ARE THE FOLKS WHO
CAN COME UP WITH THE OVERALL
LONG TERM SOLUTION FOR THAT. BUT
WE DO BELIEVE THAT THE CURRENT
SYSTEM HAS BLURRED LINES OF
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND PLENTY OF OF
ROOM FOR MUCH GREATER
TRANSPARENCY EFFICIENCY AND
HONESTLY WHERE CONSTITUENTS AND
YOUR VOTERS AND THE PEOPLE THAT
STATE KNOW WHO'S IN CHARGE.
AND SO. WE WE BELIEVE NUMBER ONE
THAT THIS IS BEEN SEEN FOR YEARS
AND AND NUMBER TWO THIS IS THE
TIME. WE THINK THIS IS THE
MOMENT THE EVEN TAKE TIME TO TRY
TO FIX THIS. ARMED.
AND WE THINK THAT YOU ALL AS THE
LEGISLATURE IN IN A BY CAMEL WAY
CAN DO JUST THAT COUPLE OF FOR
OF THOUGHTS ON THAT.
.
A LOT OF IT HAS TO DO WITH THE
TIME AND THE FACT THAT BOTH THE
GOVERNOR. AND.
THIS HAS P. IRE ARE LEAVING
OFFICE HAVE CAN HAVE AB IT
PLEASE THROUGH THEIR STAFFS
GIVEN US THEIR DIRECT TALKS
ABOUT. HOW THE ALBUM GOING
FORWARD THIS COULD BE DONE BUT
ALSO THE IT'S?
IF YOU I WOULD ARGUE AND AFTER
THE CONVERSATION WITHOUT EVER
LAST YEAR WITH SO MANY DIFFERENT
PEOPLE WHO CARE ABOUT THE
SYSTEM.
DAVID EIGHT IF IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
THIS YEAR IT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN
FOR ANOTHER TEN OR TWENTY YEARS
AND IT MAY NEVER HAPPEN. AND
THIS IS A UNIQUE MOMENT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE THE LEAD.
ON.
AND BOTTOM LINE I THINK OUR
POINT IS THAT IF YOU FOR
SIMPLIFY AND STREAMLINE THAT THE
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE.
THEN SOME OF THE TOP DOWN
ACCOUNTABILITY MANDATES LIKE NO
CHILD LEFT BEHIND ME I I HEARD
THE QUESTION THAT YOU RAISE. I'M
MISTER KILEY ABOUT ABOUT TOP
DOWN MICRO MANAGING THAT OR. WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT EITHER
AND ACTUALLY WE BELIEVE THAT. A
A SMART GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE
WILL PROVIDE MUCH MORE BOTTOMS
UP ACCOUNTABILITY AS OPPOSED
POST WHEN COMBINED WITH LCF
OFTEN SOME OF THE OTHER
STRUCTURAL CHANGES THAT HAVE
OCCURRED OVER THE PAST SEVEN OR
EIGHT YEARS.
PALM.
AND AND LITTLE ELIMINATES
CERTAIN BYZANTINE GOVERNMENT
STRUCTURES THAT CAN GET ON THE
WAY WORK REQUIRED THE STATE. AND
AND AND LOCAL I. DISTRICT
SUSPEND WAY TOO MUCH TIME AND
RESOURCES ON. INEFFICIENT DIED
BY COMPLICATED.
STRUCTURES AND LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY UP BY THE WASTE
CAN GENTLY I THINK AND WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM SOME OF THE
OTHER WITNESSES. THAT THIS ON
ULTIMATELY ALSO BENEFIT EARLY
CHILDHOOD AND. ALL OF YOU ALL
ARE HERE BECAUSE YOU CARE ABOUT
KIDS AN EDUCATION AND OBVIOUSLY.
A GOOD EARLY CHILDHOOD SITUATION
THE CONCERN OF FIVE IS GONNA
LATE LEAD INTO THEIR ABILITY TO
PERFORM WELL IN SCHOOL TILL AND
WE THINK THAT THE GOVERNMENT'S
CHANGE THAT WE'RE PROPOSING.
WILL IN FACT ALSO IN YOUR TO
THE BENEFIT OF BY STREAMLINED
MORE EFFICIENT EARLY CHILDHOOD
SYSTEM IN THE STATE.
I'M ALTHOUGH THAT'S NOT PART OF
THE FUNDAMENTAL PROPOSAL WAS
PRETTY FUNNY TODAY. AND LASTLY
EVEN THOUGH WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CHANGING THE ROLE OF THE S. P.
AYE WE ACTUALLY THINK THAT THE
PROPOSAL'S STRIKES ME AS P. AYE.
AND THAT'S OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING
OUT OF THAT YOU'LL HEAR FROM
OTHERS ON. BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY A MORE ACCOUNTABLE EFFICIENT
SIMPLE SYSTEM OF GOVERNANCE
WHERE IT'S CLEAR WHO'S IN CHARGE
IN IT'S CLEAR WHO THE PEOPLE CAN
HOLD ACCOUNTABLE. IS GONNA BE A
BETTER SYSTEM OF EDUCATION FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
BIG WINNERS ARE GOING TO BE
KEPT.
WHEN YOU HEARD FROM THE
EDUCATION COMMISSION OF THE
STATES YOU CAN SEE THE FOUR
MODELS AND OBVIOUSLY WE'RE NOT
AS MUCH EXPERTS AS THEY ARE ON
THIS. BUT IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
THE STATES THAT ARE DOING THE
BEST IN TERMS OF STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT OUTCOMES.
THEY INCLUDE NASA WE I WAS WE
HAD WE'VE DISCUSSED WITH THE
CHAIRMAN ABOUT BRINGING THE
FORMER GOVERNOR OF MASSACHUSETTS
HERE WHO OVERSAW THE
RESTRUCTURING THERE. I MEAN BE
HAPPY TO MAKE FOLKS LIKE HIM AND
OTHERS AVAILABLE TO YOU. A TERMS
OF LOOKING OUR THEIR STATE OF
DONE IN ADDITION TO WHAT THE
EDUCATION COMMISSION THE STATE
FOLKS UPSET. BUT OUR OVERALL
SENSE IS IF YOU LOOK AT THE TOP
PERFORMING STATES IN TERMS OF
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT AND
DELIVERING RESOURCES EFFECTIVELY
TO STUDENTS AND SCHOOLS
DIRECTLY.
THEY ALMOST ALL FALL INTEREST
MORE SIMPLIFIED ACCOUNTABLE
STRUCTURE STATES LIKE KENTUCKY.
MASSACHUSETTS CONNECTICUT MADE
MAJOR STRIDES IN THIS AREA. ON.
AND SO WITH ALL OF THAT IN MIND
WITH THE INPUT WE GOT FROM
PEOPLE AROUND THE STATE. ARE WE
BASICALLY HAVE A PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD COMMONSENSE
PROPOSAL. WHICH IS I. DOT YOU
WHAT WOULD THAT WE WOULD
FUNDAMENTALLY UP PUT THE ARMED.
LEAVE THE CONTROL OF THAT.
LET ME BLOOM FERRETS WE WOULD
OF MADE MORE SPECIFICALLY.
WE WOULD AMEND THAT CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION CODE TO GENERALLY
IMPLEMENT THE RECOMMENDATION OF
THE BIPARTISAN TWO THOUSAND TO
MASTER PLAN EDUCATION.
TO MOVE THE AUTHORITY FOR THE
OPERATIONS OF THE ACT CALIFORNIA
CURRENT PRE K. THROUGH TWELVE
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM AT LARGE
AND THE ULTIMATE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE DELIVERY OF EDUCATION. I
TO STUDENTS WITHIN THE ON OFFICE
OF THE GOVERNOR UNDER THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION.
IT WOULD EMPOWER THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT TO PLAY AN
ESSENTIAL LINCHPIN ROLE. AS THE
OBJECT COORDINATOR BETWEEN ALL
COR P. THROUGH SIXTEEN GOVERNING
BODIES TO BRING GREATER
COHERENCE IN POLICY DEVELOPMENT
AND IMPLEMENTATION.
BUT FUNDAMENTALLY YOU'RE
PUTTING THIS THE POWER UNDER THE
OFFICE OF THE GOVERNOR ARM AND
AS I SAID WE THINK THIS IS THE
RIGHT TIME TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN.
ON AND IT WILL ACTUALLY
STRENGTHEN OUR ATTACK THE ROLE
OF THE FBI JOBS FOR A PERFECT
SOME EXAMPLES ON.
THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT WOULD
REMAIN INDEPENDENT AND ELECT
THAT LECTURED STATEWIDE
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICER. SERVING
AS A AN INDEPENDENT STRONG VOICE
FOR PEOPLE ON EDUCATION MATTERS
WOULD GAIN A VOTING ROLE ON THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION.
FREED FROM THINK THEY'VE
CUMBERSOME ADMINISTRATIVE DUTIES
I'M IN THAT ROLE THE SUPER SPI.
WOULD FILL WE WHAT WE BELIEVE IS
A CRITICALLY. IMPORTANT AND
INFLUENTIAL ROLE BY WORKING.
I'M ALIGNING EFFORTS ACROSS
EARLY CHILDHOOD K. THROUGH
TWELVE AND HIGHER ED BY SERVING
THE THE BOARD OF VOTE ON THE
BOARDS OF. POP OF THE KEY.
OUT OF THE QUEUE. INSTITUTIONS
THAT MATTER IN THE STATE
EDUCATION INCLUDING THE UC
REGENTS THE CSU BOARD OF
TRUSTEES THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES GOVERNING
BOARD MCALISTER'S BOARD AND CTC.
AND THAT'S S. B. I WOULD HAVE A
MUCH IN OUR VIEW HAVE A MUCH
STRONGER ROLE IN SERVING
ACTIVELY IN THOSE CAPACITIES.
THE PROPOSAL WOULD THAT WERE
WERE SUGGESTING AND AGAIN WE
KNOW YOU WILL LOOK AT IT AND
COME UP WITH WHAT YOU THINK OF
THEM THE BEST THE BEST SOLUTION.
ON OUR PROPOSAL WOULD PROVIDE
THAT THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE STATE BOARD.
WHO'S CURRENTLY APPOINTED BY
THE GOD APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR.
.
WOULD WOULD.
WOULD.
I WOULD HAVE. DIED DIRECT
RESPONSIBILITY AUTHORITY OVER
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND THE
ACTUAL ADMINISTRATIVE
RESPONSIBILITIES. THAT POSITION
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO SENATE
CONFIRMATION. IN BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE WOULD
GAIN THE ABILITY TO APPOINT AT
LEAST ONE MEMBER OF THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION SO IT'S A
DIFFERENT STRUCTURE.
STATE BOARD THAN CURRENTLY
EXISTS IN GIVES THE LEGISLATURE
INPUT INTO THAT THAT THE STATE
BOARD WHO THEN OBVIOUSLY SELECTS
DOT DOT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. TOM
WE BIG DEBTS WILL SIMPLIFY AND
STREAMLINE THE SYSTEM BUT ALSO
CREATE. ACCOUNTABILITY ON.
AND IT WILL CUT DOWN ON THE
LEVEL OF STATE BUREAUCRACY AND
WHICH WE FEEL IT'S CONSISTENT
WITH GOVERNOR'S BROWN'S.
RELEASED EARLY IN HIS FOR IN ITS
FIRST TERM AT.
ELIMINATION OF THE SECRETARY'S
EDUCATION OFFICE AT THE
BEGINNING OF HIS TERM AND JUST
TO SHOW YOU HOW OLD I AM I WAS
HERE WHEN MAUREEN DIMARCO WAS
APPOINTED. AS THE FIRST
SECRETARY VEGETATION AND I
BELIEVE TESTIFIED ON THAT SO WE
HAVE SEEN THAT PLATE MANY OF YOU
WERE HEARING GRADE SCHOOL IN
THOSE DAYS BUT. WE THIS HAS BEEN
A SYSTEM OF TEASING BUT WE WITH
THIS IS A LONG TIME COMING IN IN
A WAY AND I THINK GOVERNOR
BROWN'S DECISION TO ELIMINATE
THAT POSITION WAS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. AND THIS
RESTRUCTURING WOULD HELP I
MENTIONED BRIEFLY I THINK ALSO
THAT IF THIS I DONE EARLY
CHILDHOOD WILL BE A MORE
STREAMLINED INEFFECTIVE SYSTEM
THAN IT CURRENTLY IS. SENATOR
PAN AND OTHERS OF YOU KNOW
WEALTHY EARLY CHILDHOOD SYSTEM
HERE IN ALL THE KEEP USING
COMPLEXITIES THAT ACCEPTS THEIR.
URINE GABLE AND OTHERS ARE GONNA
TESTIFY LATER BUT WE DO BELIEVE
THAT IN THE LONG RUN IT'S
GOVERNMENT'S RESTRUCTURING WILL
ALSO REALLY HELP ON THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD FRONT. ON AND THE
BOTTOM LINE FOR AYE SAYS.
IF WE DO THAT S..
CLARITY SIMPLICITY EFFICIENCY
TRANSPARENCY.
ALL OF THOSE ARE GOING TO BE
GOOD FOR EDUCATION ALL OF THOSE
ARE GOING TO ENGAGE THE PUBLIC
EVEN MORE. IN A SYSTEM WHERE
THEY KNOW THE ULTIMATE
ACCOUNTABILITY TO YOUR POINT OF
ONE I CAN IMPOSE SENATOR PANTS
BUT WHAT IF YOU HAVE A GOVERNOR
DOESN'T CARE THAT MUCH ABOUT
EDUCATION.
WELL FIRST OF ALL AYE IT'S GONNA
BE IT'S A SUCH A HUGE PORTION OF
OUR BUDGET THAT A GOVERNOR HERE
SHE CANNOT CARE ABOUT THAT. AND
NUMBER TWO AT THE END OF THE DAY
IT IS WHAT I THINK MOST OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS CARE ABOUT IN TERMS
OF THE OPERATION OF THE OF THE
OF THE STATE GOVERNMENT. THEY
CARE A LOT ABOUT HOW THE STATE
AND THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITIES
DELIVER EDUCATION AND EDUCATE
THEIR KIDS IN THEIR SCHOOLS.
PHILIP THE END OF THE DAY WE
THANK IS STREAMLINED OFFICIAL
PROPOSAL WILL MAKE A BIG WIN FOR
FOR KIDS. THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR.
LETTING ME GET UP FOR ANYONE
PRESENTED.
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND QUESTIONS FROM THE PANEL.
IT'S A MEMBER OF KILEY.
BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FEAR AT
TESTIMONY MR STIERHEIM SO I I
WOULDN'T DISCUSS START BY ASKING
ABOUT PAN.
YOU'RE. I THEORY THAT THIS WILL
MAKE THINGS MORE EFFICIENT AND
SO IS THIS AYE ARE YOU GENERALLY
AN ADVOCATE FOR AYE AYE A
UNITARY EXECUTIVE.
I YOU KNOW SHOULD WE BRING
FUNCTIONS OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL SECRETARY OF STATE.
UNDER THE PURVIEW OF THE
GOVERNOR IS THERE SOMETHING
SPECIFIC ABOUT.
EDUCATIONAL YOU DON'T WANT THAT
TO BE AS INDEPENDENT AIRCRAFT
ARE CAUSING AYE TATE'S REALLY
JUST ABOUT EDUCATION OKAY.
UP BY ACCU AT STANFORD WHEN I
TEACHES CUTS CON LAW SO I
WOULDN'T RECOMMEND TO YOU TERRY
EXECUTIVE. AND I'M A BIG
BELIEVER IN HAVING. A
INDEPENDENT JUDICIARY TO AJ IT'S
REALLY AN EDUCATION IT'S REALLY
THE CONFUSING SITUATION WE
RIGHT NOW.
WHERE IT'S NOT THAT CLEAR TO
PEOPLE OF WHO'S IN CHARGE ON A
SPECIFIC BOTH IN TERMS OF THE
THE ULTIMATE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION SO KNOW WHAT
SPECIFICALLY STRUCTURED AROUND?
THE DELIVERY OF K. THROUGH
TWELVE SERVICES BUT ALSO EARLY
CHILDHOOD I THINK IN THE LONG
RUN BUT IT'S NOT. THE IDEA OF A
UNITARY A GOVERNMENT WITH
EVERYTHING UNDER THE POWER
PERSON GOT IT SO YOU SEEM TO
WANT TO BRING MOST THE POWERS
THE SPI UNDER THE GOVERNOR BUT I
GUESS YOU COULD JUST AS EASILY
TO CLEAR UP THAT. CONFUSION WITH
THE OTHER WAY AROUND AND BRING
SOME OF THE AUTHORITIES OF THE
BOARD UNDER THE S. B. IRAN I
THINK I I GET YOUR POINT I'M NOT
I DON'T THINK I DON'T THINK.
THEY'D BE I DON'T THINK WE WE
THINK THAT THE FBI IS LOSING IN
THIS EQUATION WE BELIEVE THAT
THE FBI IS ACTUALLY GONNA BE
EMPOWERED IN THIS PROPOSAL. AND
THAT THE FBI IS GONNA LOOK IS
GONNA LOSE THE ADMINISTRATIVE
ESPONSIBILITY FOR THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THAT'S
GOING TO GO UNDER. THE.
STATE BOARD BUT WE ARE TO
BELIEVE THIS WILL STRENGTHEN THE
ROLE OF THE VOICE OF AND
ACTUALLY THE IMPACT OF THE S. P.
AYE. REMOVING THEM FROM SORT OF
A BUREAUCRATIC ROLE THAT THEY
PLAY IN PUTTING THAT IN ONE
PLACE WITH ONE WITH ONE.
ACCOUNTABILITY WHICH IS UNDER
THE STATE BOARD.
WHICH AGAIN ULTIMATELY REPORTS
INTO THE GOVERNOR BUT I DON'T
THINK WE SEE THIS IS AS.
I.
ANYWAY UNDER I THINK WE SEE THIS
IS IT IS GROWING THAT AUTHORITY
IF YOU WILL OF THE FBI AND A LOT
OF THE CONVERSATIONS WE HAD LAST
YEAR WHEN WE WERE. CIRCULATING
THIS ROUND AND TALKING TO
DIFFERENT EXPERTS. INCLUDING
WITH AYE AYE AYE AYE AYE FBI
TOUR LOOKS AND AND HIS STAFF.
WITH A SENSE FROM DAM ACTUALLY
THAT THAT WOULD BE POSITIVE. SO
IT WITH WHICH IT'S NOT DESIGNED
TO GOT THAT ROLE IT'S THAT
DELIVER EFFICIENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY.
OKAY THAT'S INTERESTING GIVEN
HAVING THE FBI ALL THESE BOARDS
IS GONNA GIVE HERE SHIA. BIGGER
VOICE LET'S PUT THAT CLEARLY WE
DO YET FOR THAT KLIM ASIDE FOR
A%
MORE ENGAGE LET'S PUT THAT KIND
TO THE SIDE FOR A SECOND AND
THAT. YOU YOU DO SAY THAT YOU
WANT BUT THE ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNCTIONS OF THE S. P. AYE
UNDER.
THE PURVIEW OF THE GOVERNOR BUT
WITH THE ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNCTIONS WERE TALKING ABOUT
THOSE ARE EXECUTIVE FUNCTIONS
YOU'RE NOT AN ADVOCATE FOR THE
UNITARIANS THAT COULD HAVE SOME
BY DO YOU. FAVOR.
A UNITARY EXECUTIVE WHEN IT
COMES TO ADMINISTRATIVE
EDUCATION FUNCTIONS WHEN ANOTHER
AREAS BECAUSE WE BECAUSE THE
CURRENT SYSTEM IS THE ONE THAT
SO ITSELF HAVE BEEN SUCH I HAVE
BEEN URGED FOR A HUNDRED YEARS
TO BE RESTRUCTURED RIGHT WHAT
ABOUT THE SUGGESTION I JUST MADE
THAT YOU COULD FLIP. IT THE
OTHER WAY AROUND SO THE
ADMINISTRATIVE.
EXIST IN THE STATE PARK I GOT A.
COULD ARE YOU COULD OUR SENSE IS
IT MAKES MORE SENSE TO DO IT
UNDER THE SLIDE.
MY GOVERNOR
BUT BECAUSE WE TAKE THAT
ULTIMATELY THE GOVERNOR IS THE
PERSON WHEN YOU THINK OF YOUR
AVERAGE CONSTITUENT WHO THE
PERSON WHO THE PUBLIC'S GOING TO
HOLD ACCOUNTABLE. AND WE THINK
THAT THAT THAT'S A THAT'S A MUCH
STRONGER POSITION ELECTORALLY
QUITE FRANKLY GOVERNOR'S A
BIGGER DEAL THAN S. B. I. AND WE
THINK IT MAKES A LOGICAL SENSE
TO HAVE THE OVERALL
ACCOUNTABILITY IN ONE PLACE
RATHER THAN ACROSS MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT LOCUSTS AS. YOUR
POINT'S WELL TAKEN THAT YOU
COULD SAY LET'S PUT IT ALL OVER
HERE. BUT I THINK THAT WOULD BE
I THINK IT WOULD CONTINUE THE
CONFUSION ACT THAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE THAT SORT OF. IT WITH WITH
DUAL AND UNCLEAR LINES OF
AUTHORITY BETWEEN SP AYE AND THE
STATE BOARD WITH THE STATE BOARD
OF THE FEEDING ON OF THE
GOVERNOR. AN ARTS CENTER IS THIS
IS THE SIMPLEST MOST LOGICAL WAY
TO DO IT BUT THE TRUTH IS COMING
CALLING. THAT'S THE COMP THAT'S
A CONVERSATION WE WANT YOU TO
HAVE AND YOU HAVE RECKONED
LANDED ON THE REALLY SMART
PEOPLE HERE WORK ON EDUCATION
WAY LONGER THAN I HAVE. AND SO
WE'RE RISK AT THE END OF THE DAY
A CLEARER MORE SIMPLE EFFICIENT
SYSTEMS GOING TO BENEFIT GETS
PERIOD. BUT IT TO YOUR POINT'S
WELL TAKEN YOU COULD DO IT DEATH
THANK YOU AND I I I WILL JUST
KNOW THAT SORT OF THE ARGUMENT
THAT WHILE THE GOVERNOR'S MORE
VISIBLE FIGURE THAT. IS EQUALLY
AN ARGUMENT FOR PUTTING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL THIS AREA STATE
AND SO FORTH THOSE FUNCTIONS
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S WHILE I I
WOULDN'T I I DOUBT I WOULD SAY
THAT I DOUBT I WOULD AGREE WITH
YOU BUT I GET YOUR POINT BUT I
YEAH SO I HAVE BEEN. LOOKING AT
THE LOCAL.
OF THINGS I WE HAVE ELECTED AND
I THINK MOST COUNTY USER AT
LEAST SEVERAL COUNTIES IN
ELECTED COUNTY. AS
SUPERINTENDENT OF EDUCATION AND
WE ALSO HAVE ELECTED I COUNTY
BOARDS OF EDUCATION DOES THAT
LEAD TO THE SAME SORT OF
PROBLEMS AT THE LOCAL EVEL YOU
KNOW IT'S. A GOOD QUESTION AND
I'M NOT HERE DAY TO COME.
IT'S A VERY GOOD.
TO ASK
I'M AND I THINK THAT MIGHT MY
GENERAL SENSE ON THIS IS THAT
THE L. CFF DECISION TAKEN EARLY
IN THE GOVERNOR'S FIRST TERM.
REALLY DEVOLVED A LOT OF
RESPONSIBILITYTO THE LOCAL
LEVEL FOR FUNDING IN AND OTHER.
OTHER LOCAL SCHOOLS DECISIONS
WHICH WE THOUGHT WAS A MEAN
ULTIMATELY I THINK OUR SENSE IS
THAT I'LL SEE IF OPPOSITE GOOD
DECISION THAT REALLY THAT THERE
WAS A POSITIVE SUPPORT FOR THE
STATE PARTICULARLY FOR. AND IT
FOR LOWER INCOME KIDS QUITE
HONESTLY AND FOR DISTRICTS THAT
NEED THE MOST HELP UPON BUT
YOU'RE RIGHT IT'S THIS IS A
COMPLEX SYSTEM THAT'S RIGHT IT
IS A LONGER DISCUSSION IT'S NOT
RIGHT. THERE AND BY THE WAY I
WOULD SAY THIS TO.
WE'RE NOT SUGGESTING THIS IS THE
MAGIC BULLET WE'RE NOT SAYING
THERE IS ONE THING IN OF ALL ALL
YOU HAVE TO DO HERE IS
RESTRUCTURE THE SYSTEM AND.
EVERYTHING'S GONNA BE PERFECT IN
CALIFORNIA'S GOING GO FROM FORTY
TWO TO ONE IN TWO YEARS.
THERE'S NO MAGIC BULLET THE WE
THINK THIS IS A LOGICAL
INTELLIGENT WAY TO MORE
EFFICIENTLY DELIVER SERVICES TO
KIDS IN SCHOOLS IN THE STATE.
AND TO HAVE A CLEAR LINE A CLEAR
LINE OF A THOUGHT OF
ACCOUNTABILITY TO YOUR
CONSTITUENTS AND THE GENERAL
PUBLIC AND ACTUALLY STRENGTHEN
THE SYSTEM OVERALL WHICH IS WHY.
YOU GUYS ARE ALL ON THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND PLOTS
ABOUT MY LIFE WORKING ON KIDS AN
EDUCATION. RIGHT BUT I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS WHY ARE YOU FOCUSING
ON THIS REFORM AT THE STATE
LEVEL WHERE THE SAME BIFURCATION
OF AUTHORITY SEEMS TO EXIST AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL BECAUSE WE
BECAUSE AFTER TALKING AFTER
HAVING WORKED ON THESE ISSUES
FOR TWENTY PLUS YEARS. AND
TALKING TO PEOPLE ALL ACROSS THE
STATE AT ALL DIFFERENT LEVELS
THEY KEPT COMING BACK TO THE
THEME THAT PICTURE THAT WE
SHOULD RESTRUCTURE THAT AND THAT
EVERY COMMISSION THAT EVER
LOOKED AT THAT SAYS RESTRUCTURE
THAT. BUT THAT'S WHY IT'S IT'S
AND SO AGAIN IT IS NOT A PURELY
SIGNED I THAT'S WHY I THOUGHT OF
SOME WOMEN O'DONNELL QUESTIONS
ABOUT YOU KNOW SHOW THEIR. PURE
EVIDENCE AGREED THE GOOD PHD
THESIS PER SOME KID IT AT HIM
AND IN A PHD UPS AT SCHOOL RIGHT
NOW. BUT IT'S JUST IT IT JUST ON
ITS FACE AND AND ALSO WITH WITH
THE INPUT OF SO MANY DIFFERENT
PEOPLE ON THE STATE.
IT IS A LOGIC A MORE LOGICAL
STREAMLINED EFFICIENT
TRANSPARENT SYSTEM. BUT IT'S NOT
A MAGIC BULLET LEFT I WILL BE
CLEAR ON THAT THEY'RE STILL LOT
OF OTHER STUFF THAT YOU ALL. ON
THIS IMPORTANT COMMITTEE AFTER
WORK ON TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE A GOOD EDUCATION SO SO
WHERE IS THE EVIDENCE THIS TO BE
A MORE LOGICAL AND TRANSPARENT
AND EFFICIENT SYSTEM EVERY NIGHT
YOU THROW OUT A FEW EXAMPLES OF
STATES THAT HAPPENED OF GOOD
RESULTS THAT ALSO. HAPPEN OF THE
SYSTEM THAT YOU LIKE BUT THAT
AYE GENTLEMAN TO TESTIFY BEFORE
YOU GO I THINK YOU'LL KNOWLEDGE
IS MORE KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT THE
TOPIC
AND YOU. I STATED THAT THERE IS
NO QUANTIFIABLE EVIDENCE
ACTUALLY THE ONE SYSTEM WORKS
BETTER HAN THE OTHER GOES BELOW
ME FINISH MY QUESTION. AS TO WHY
ARE WE SORT OF.
THROWING AROUND IDEAS ABOUT
WHAT WE CAN TWEAK THIS BETWEEN
BAT WITHOUT HAVING FIRST
RIGOROUSLY STUDIED I YOU KNOW
HUNDRED PLUS YEARS OF HISTORY
WITH.
THESE DIFFER MODELS I THINK WE
ARE I MEAN I MY MY ANSWER TO IS
I THINK YOU HAVE I THINK THAT
THEY ARE NOT GEARED TO TO THAT
QUESTION AND. AND AND THE TRUTH
IS THAT THEY'RE PROBABLY NOT
BEEN A MOUNTAIN OF RESEARCH
MONEY PUT INTO STUFF LIKE THAT
TOO AND A DETAILED. QUANTIFIABLE
DISCUSSION ABOUT BUT I THINK IN
THE BIG PICTURE SENSE
I BET THAT IF YOU GO TAKE THAT
GO GHOST SPEND AND AND I KNOW
YOU AND YOUR ALL YOUR CABLE DO
THAT FROM TIME TO. GO ASK ALL
THE PEOPLE IN EDUCATION THE
STATE TO WORK AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THE STATE LEVEL ABOUT THIS AND
YOU'RE GOING TO GET DIFFERENCE
OPINION FROM THE PEOPLE ARE
GONNA TESTIFY AFTER MIDNIGHT A
LIGHT RIGHT. SO WE'RE NOT SICK
AND PART OF WHAT WE'VE WHAT I
THINK IS REALLY GOOD ABOUT THIS
DISCUSSION IS YOU ARE BOTH.
BOTH HOUSES THE LEGISLATURE HERE
LOOKING AT THIS ISSUE TRYING TO
GET IT RIGHT. AND.
ALL OF THE INPUT WE HAVE GOTTEN
HAVE SUGGESTED THAT WHILE THIS
IS A WONKY SOLUTION IT ACTUALLY
WILL ULTIMATELY. IN YOUR TO
SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS FOR SCHOOLS
HERE AND KICK DELIVERY OF
SERVICES TO GET AND ALSO SENT TO
THE PUBLIC THERE'S
ACCOUNTABILITY YEAH BUT IS VERY
ONE STUDY THAT. THAT COULD
CANONIZE THAT NO AND THAT'S A
FAIR QUESTION BUT THE BALANCE OF
EVIDENCE SUGGESTS SO AND THAT'S
WHY I THINK IT WAS IMPORTANT
WHAT CAN. COUPON SAID WHICH IS
EVERY STUDY THAT'S LOOKED TO
PASS FOR THE LAST HUNDRED YEARS
HAS RECOMMENDED A CHANGE OF THIS
NATURE WITHOUT ALL THE SPECIFIC
ELEMENTS SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
RELYING ON AND IT'S NOT PURE
SCIENCE I WOULD AGREE.
RIGHT WE I MEAN YOU I KNOW
SOMEONE WHO CARES VERY MUCH
ABOUT STUDENT TIME HOW COMES AND
THAT. AND IMPROVING THAT AND I
YOU SEEM TO BE ACKNOWLEDGING I
GUESS THAT WE HAVEN'T REALLY
LOOKED AT WHAT'S WRITTEN OTHER
STATES IN AS QUANTIFIABLE WAYS
WE COULD AND. AGAIN THAT THE
JOHN JUST TESTIFIED.
AGREED WITH THAT SO WOULD YOU.
AGREE THAT WE SHOULD PROBABLY
NOT MAKE ANY SORT OF STRUCTURAL
CHANGE UNTIL WE HAVE A HIGHER
LEVEL OF EVIDENCE WHERE THAT THE
FOLKS WHO JUST TESTIFIED COULD
TELL US THAT WE ACTUALLY DO NOW
HAVE SOME GOOD EVIDENCE.
THIS MOTTO TO NOW IT WOULDN'T I
WOULDN'T OF I THINK THAT'S A
FAIR QUESTION NO I THINK THAT.
I THINK THAT THE BODY OF
EVIDENCE THAT EXISTS. IS IS GOOD
ENOUGH TO SUGGEST THAT A CHANGE
NOW WILL WILL MAKE THAT HAVE
YOUR MONEY WHAT THAT EVIDENCE
WAS DONE I I THINK IT'S THAT
IT'S IT'S REALLY THE EVIDENCE
AS.
OF OF OF TO GAWKING TO ALL THE
OTHER KEY EDUCATION PLAYERS
AROUND THE CITY TALKING TO
PEOPLE ISN'T REALLY EVIDENCE YOU
HAVE KEY POINT WHAT THE
EVIDENCES.
YOU KNOW I WOULD AGAIN BE IT
ONLY EVIDENCE I WOULD POINT TO
WOULD BE THE STATES THAT ARE
EXCEEDING US IN TERMS OF THEIR
RANKINGS INTERFERE IN DELIVERING
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES TO PUPILS.
ARE WHO HAVE A MORE STREAMLINED
EFFICIENT SYSTEMS COSTS OF THEIR
STATES THAT ARE EXCEEDING US THE
HOMEGROWN KNOWN LET MISTER STARR
FINISH FOR THAT'S MY ALMA
THINKING THAT RESCUED ME WAIT NO
LET HIM FINISH HIS COMMENT
BEFORE YOU COME BACK IT UP
PLEASE. ABOUT MY LETTUCE BE
POLITE IN THIS ROOM
THANKS A LOT.
BUT TAKES A FROM IMMINENT ON
THAT FOR IT TO BE THERE FOR
QUITE
I GET I GET YOUR POINT I MEAN I
I DON'T AGREE WITH YOU BUT
SUBMITS THAT SOME OF THE
PROMISES YOUR QUESTION BUT. THE
BUT THE FAIR POINT AND I WOULD
TELL YOU THAT THERE IS NOIT
THERE'S NO PERFECT ROADMAP
THAT'S BEEN LAID OUT AND I
WOULDN'T TAKE FIVE YEARS ON THIS
COMMITTEE AND DO THAT.
THIS IS A PRETTY LOGICAL CLEAR
THING TO DO YOU SHOULD DISCUSS
IT IS A COMMITTEE COME FROM
ABOUT IT COME OUT IT WITH YOUR
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES. AND.
WE STRONGLY THINK THAT THIS A
PROPOSAL WILL DELIVER MUCH
BETTER RESULTS FOR KIDS IN
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA NOT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
PLEASE MAKE COME.
CURRENTLY IT DIDN'T HURT I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU MISTER TECH IS I
THINK YOU'RE OPEN GOAL HERE IS
REALLY STUDENT OUTCOMES.
IT NOW COMES OUT AND IT'S BETTER
SCHOOLS ABSOLUTELY IT ISN'T JUST
CHANGING GOVERNANCE TO CHANGE
GOVERNANCE.
BUT I AND THAT BY THE WAY I
THINK THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
POINT BECAUSE THAT'S AND THAT'S
WHY I'VE USED THE TERM WONKY
ACTUALLY MISTER CHAIRMAN
BECAUSE.
IT IS LONG ITS GOVERNANCE YOU
COULDN'T GO IT'S IT'S
COMPLICATED TO EXPLAIN TO YOU
ALL WHO ARE EXPERTS IN THE
FIELD.
BUT THE TRUTH IS AT THE END OF
THE DAY IT'S TO DELIVER ME MORE
AND BETTER SERVICES TO KIDS AND
TEACHERS IN YOUR TEACHER OF
TWENTY TWO YEARS I'M A TEACHER.
THAT'S HOW I GOT INTO THIS FIELD
WE ALL KNOW THAT THERE ISN'T
VERY FEW THINGS ARE MORE
IMPORTANT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN DOING A GOOD JOB
OF RAISING AND EDUCATING OUR
KIDS. AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS.
GOVERNANCE CHANGE WILL BE AN
IMPORTANT ELEMENT BUT NOT AND
SIMPLE BUT I IN OF ITSELF THE
ONLY ELEMENT. PHILIP GIVE US A
BETTER EDUCATION SYSTEM BETTER
RESOURCES FOR TEACHERS BETTER
OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS ALL THE
THINGS WE ALL CARE ABOUT YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANKS.
WE'RE I PAID AMERICA SAY I DON I
FIND A LOT OF THE PROPOSAL VERY
INTRIGUING AND THERE'S CERTAINLY
SOME THINGS ABOUT THE STRUCTURE
THAT ARE.
.
THAT ARE PART PROBLEMATIC IN AND
PERHAPS.
DYSFUNCTIONAL.
I'M PART OF WHAT MAKES ALL THIS
SO DIFFICULT IS THAT. SO MUCH OF
THE WAY THE SYSTEM WORKS OR
DOESN'T WORK AND ULTIMATELY
COMES DOWN TO WHO'S IN THE
POSITIONS YEAH. AND I'M.
I'M I'M NOT SURE WHETHER MAKING
THIS CHANGE WILL YOU KNOW WILL
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM.
I'M.
IF THINGS I AM.
I MEAN I'M I'M SYMPATHETIC TO
THE SOME OF THE LINE OF
QUESTIONING COMING FROM THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ABOUT. DATA.
IT'S NOT THAT I DON'T.
THIS OTHERS NOT A PART OF MY GOD
THAT CERTAIN THINGS THAT YOU
THAT THE YOU REALLY ON THE
SOMETHING ASSISTED IF WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND MAKE A
ENORMOUS CHANGE TOWARD A STINT
WITH ALL OF THE. CHALLENGE IN
MONEY IN BUREAUCRATIC NIGHTMARE
AND.
REGULATORY ALTERATIONS NECESSARY
ASSOCIATED WITH MAKING TEAMS
LIKE THIS YOU KNOW HOW DO WE
REALLY MAKE SURE THAT. IT'S NOT
JUST.
BASED ON CONVERSATIONS WITH
PRICE MORE PEOPLE I MEAN I I
DON'T I DON'T I DON'T DISCOUNT
THE FACT THAT YOU HAVEN'T HAD.
CONVERSATIONS WITH REALLY WISE
PEOPLE WHO FOLLOW OUT ABOUT THIS
AND HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
FOR A LONG TIME.
I THINK THAT'S PARTLY I THINK I
THINK THAT'S GONNA WITH DECENT
NUMBERS GETTING AND I AGREE. I
AYE THAT THOSE RIVER CRESCENT BY
THE AD THAT THEY WERE TOTALLY
VERY QUESTIONS. AND AND AND IN
SOME CASES YOU SAW I COULDN'T
GIVE YOU A A YOU AND EVIDENTIAL
PURE EVIDENTIARY BASIS BUT I D
THINK THAT THOUGHT THAT. I DO
THINK THAT EVERYTIME THIS IS
BEEN LOOKED AT BY REALLY SERIOUS
COMMISSIONS AND AND I'M REALLY
RESPECTED BY THE. STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO CARE ABOUT THAT
PAVE ALL COME BACK WITH THE SAME
CONCLUSION AND THEY ALL REFERRED
MISTER CHAIRMAN TO THE
DYSFUNCTION YOU MENTIONED. THAT
THAT DEPICT A BLURRED LINES OF
AUTHORITY THE BLURRED LINES OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND HONESTLY YOU
HAVE TO EXTREMELY KNOWLEDGEABLE
COOKS CAN SPRINTS FOR
CONSULTANTS FOR THIS COMMITTEE
ON PO IN BOTH. IN BOTH HOUSES
I'M WE'RE VERY FAMILIAR WITH
BASS TO AND SO I I WISH I COULD
PRESENT YOU WITH SORT OF THE
MASTER PLAN STUDY THAT HAVE BEEN
DONE I DON'T THINK IT WILL BE
DONE. ON AND I AGREE I THINK
IT'S A VERY FAIR QUESTION TO ASK
MISTER CHAIRMAN AS YOU KNOW DO
WE HAVE ENOUGH TO GO ON. TO MAKE
AN IMPORTANT STRUCTURAL CHANGE
LIKE AS. OUR STRONG FEELING IS
YES BUT THAT'S.
THAT THAT'S WHY WE ELECTED SUCH
FINE REPRESENTATIVES FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO MAKE
DECISIONS LIKE THAT.
OKAY SO LET ME JUST COUPLE
APPRECIATE THAT I'VE BEEN
APPRECIATE THEM YOU KNOW.
THE THE OPEN WAY THAT YOU'RE
DOWN HERE JUST ASKING US TO
CONSIDER THIS AYE MEN THINK THAT
SOME.
YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S REALLY
WHERE THE DISCUSSIONS Y. WE'RE
HAVING THIS DISCUSSION TODAY I
GUESS ONE OF MY QUESTIONS IS
ARMED.
ALONG THE LINES OF OF WHAT
CENTER KILEY WAS ASKING ABOUT
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
INTERACTION BETWEEN THE STATE.
AND THE AND THE LOCALS WONDER
THIS STRUCTURE OUT HOW DO WE
ENSURE.
THAT WE DON'T INCREASE
CONFUSION.
I.
WHEN YOU'VE GOT.
YOU KNOW DISTRICT IN COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS HAVING TO ANSWER
POTENTIALLY BOTH THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT AND SECTOR OF
EDUCATION IN CERTAIN THINGS.
NOW THEY'RE GONNA BE SEPARATE
ENTITIES UNDER YOUR PROPOSAL BUT
THEY WERE PUT IN THIS WAY CITIES
ARE OUT THERE IN THIS ONE THEY
WOULD JUST BE THAT DAY WOULD NO
LONGER. HAVE THE SAME LINES OF
AUTHORITY TOWARD THAT TO THE S.
P. AYE IT WOULD REALLY BE GOING
THROUGH THE STATE THAT YOU HAVE
ONE.
WE HAVE ONE CENTRALIZED
AUTHORITY FOR OVERALL COMPETENCE
OKAY IN GENERAL.
OKAY I'M.
ONE OTHER QUESTION HAS TO DO
WITH WITH AT WITH YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF HIGHER
EDUCATION AND ALL OF THIS AND
MAKING SURE THAT WERE BEING
SMART ABOUT ARTICULATION
BETWEEN.
KITTY TWELVE AND HIGHER ED AND
AND TEN.
YOU KNOW HOW HOW DO HOW TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S SMART
ARTICULATION HAVE YOU SPENT TIME
LOOKING AT THAT AS WELL HONESTLY
NOT NOT THAT MUCH AND BY THE WAY
IN IN IN ALL SORT OF INTO
TELLING ABOUT YOU ALL BECAUSE
AGAIN WE WE DO THIS WITH RESPECT
FOR. THE COMMITTEE AND WHO'S ON
IT YOU KNOW.
MY COLLEAGUE AT STANFORD
PROFESSOR CURSE IS ALSO THE
PRESIDENT STATE BOARD SOME IF MY
CAR YOU COULD YOU CALL KNOW HIM
WELL ARE YOU ARE YOU SURE YOU
SHOULD. THIS IS THE I WOULD TELL
YOU IF YOU LOOK AT THIS AND
CONSIDER THIS KIND OF CHANGE IT
WOULD BE SO IT WOULD BE FOLKS
LIKE MY CURSE TO SPEND YEAR
THROUGH MANAGING THIS.
IN DIFFERENT ROLES I'M AND AND
AND SOME OF HIS COLLEAGUES AT
THE STATE BOARD AND AS I'VE AYE
AYE I. MENTIONED BOTH.
LYNN AND WRECKED BECAUSE OF
THEIR EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE AS
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO REALLY
REALLY KNOW THE SYSTEM INCLUDING
THE INTERPLAY BETWEEN THE STATE
LEVEL A GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE.
AND LOCAL SUPERINTENDENTS
ETCETERA AND. OUR OUR OUR
REQUEST YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR HONOR TO HAVE A HEARING ON
THIS IN A REALLY SERIOUS
DISCUSSION IS. WHAT'S COME UP
WITH A BETTER SYSTEM BUT LET'S
DRAW ON THE EXPERTISE OF PEOPLE
WHO MANAGE THE SYSTEM OVER THE
PAST. I'D DECADE OR TWO AND AND
AND AND COME UP WITH A MORE
EFFICIENT STREAMLINED
TRANSPARENT.
PROPOSAL YEAH WE DID SAY WE HAD
ALL BUT AT ALL THE ANSWERS
OURSELVES.
WHAT WHAT DO YOU WHAT DO YOU SEE
AS WHERE YOU SEE THIS IS A BIG
PICTURE QUESTION AS THE GREATEST
DYSFUNCTION ASSOCIATE WITH OUR
CURRENT STRUCTURE?
WHAT WHAT'S WITH THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM TRYING TO SOLVE HERE?
I WOULD SAY THAT THREE WERE AYE
JAY ACCOUNTABLE I THINK I KEEP
USING THE WORD ACCOUNTABILITY
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S NOT CLEAR
TO THE AVERAGE PERSON MAYBE TO
EXPERTS ON IT WHERE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY LIES WHICH WE
THINK IT'S REALLY HELPFUL.
I THINK.
AND AND BY THE WAY THAT MATTERS
IN TERMS OF CONSTITUENTS
BELIEVING THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO. HELP THEIR KIDS
GET A BETTER EDUCATION IN THEIR
LOCAL SCHOOL BE BETTER AND WHICH
OF THE WAY THAT THE NINETY
PERCENT OF THE FOLKS WHO ELECT
YOU THINK. THEY JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW REMOTE
TO ELEMENTARY SCHOOL WORKS
BETTER IMAGES MORE EFFICIENT
DELIVERY OF RESOURCE. SO I WOULD
TAKE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THAT.
AND IT'S AND IT'S STILL ITS THE
EXPECT THE ALSO THAT TO EDIT
SYSTEM WHERE THEY ALL POINT
FINGERS AT THE. RIGHT NOW WHERE
I KNOW THAT'S NT OUR FAULT
THAT'S THEIR FAULT THAT THEIR
RESPONSE GOING. AND I THINK THAT
THERE'S A CHANGE IN GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE WE BELIEVE THAT A
CHANGE IN GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE.
WOULD REMOVE THAT AND CLARIFIES
ABOUT THE INCLUDING BY THE WAY.
IF IT'S NOT THAT GOOD AND THE
OUTCOMES AREN'T THAT GOOD
HOLDING THE PEOPLE RESPONSIBLE
MORE WHO ARE IN CHARGE. IT IN A
MORE CLEAR HEADED WAY AND AND
INCLUDE INCLUDING WHY ARE WE
GETTING BETTER RESULTS IN BEING
ABLE TO TARGET BACK. TO PICK TO
QUITE FRANKLY TO THE GOVERNOR
AND THE STATE BOARD IN A MORE
STRATEGIC WAY.
THAT MEANS IT'S INTERESTING. AND
I PAY.
I THINK I STRUGGLED WITH SOME OF
THE VERY THE SPACE IN QUESTIONS
WHEN I SERVED AS A SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER IN MY HOMETOWN.
I OUT YOU KNOW.
AND IT REALLY DOES.
HELP TO ILLUSTRATE SOME OF THE
TENSIONS THAT UNDER GIRD.
SOME OF THE CENTER COUNTIES
QUESTIONS.
WE DECIDED.
NOT ONLY A THIN AT THE STATE
LEVEL TO SEPARATE OUT EDUCATION
GOVERNMENTS FROM THE.
YEAH FROM THE GOVERNORS PAROLE
BUT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO WE
DECIDED TO.
GIVE ALL THE LOCAL POWER CITY
COUNCILS BUT CREATE SEPARATE
SCHOOL WORDS BECAUSE EDUCATION
SO SPECIAL SO DIFFERENT SO.
SO IMPORTANT SO UNIQUE.
THAT WE WANTED OUT ENTIRELY
SEPARATE BOARD TO BE A GRAPPLING
WITH THOSE EDUCATION POSSIBILITY
QUESTIONS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THAT'S BEEN A. AYE TWO HEADED
DRAGON I'M ON THE ONE HAND IT
HAS PROVIDED MORE ATTENTION AND
MORE FOCUS ON EDUCATION A GROUP
OF ELECTED OFFICIALS AND A WHOLE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO. JUST FOCUS ON
EDUCATION THE FLIPSIDE IS
SOMETIMES SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN LEFT
BEHIND THE POWER STRUCTURE
BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T BEEN. AYE
AS IN THE MIX WITH THE WAY THE
LOCAL GOVERNANCE IS TAKING PLACE
PLAYING THERE'S A FEAR PERHAPS
WITH THIS.
YOU'RE RIGHT THERE IS A THERE'S
A PROMINENT SO THE GOVERNOR'S
POSITION THERE'S A THERE'S A
POLITICAL POWER TO THE
GOVERNOR'S POSITION THE SAME
TIME THE GOVERNOR'S WORKING ON
TWENTY NINE DIFFERENT ISSUES.
AND IF THE GOVERNOR DOESN'T YOU
KNOW AND WE HEARD THIS EARLIER
IF THE GOVERNMENT DOESN'T TAKE
LEADERSHIP IT DOESN'T SEEM TO
PRIORITIZE EDUCATION DOESN'T
CARE AS MUCH ABOUT EDUCATION. I
THINK THERE'D BE A FEAR UNDER
YOUR PROPOSAL EDUCATION COULD
ACTUALLY BE.
EVEN LOWER AYE DOWN THE TOTEM
POLE DAN I'M THAT IT IS NOW I AT
LEAST WITH S. P. AYE YOU'VE GOT
SOMEONE WHO IS. WHOSE WHOSE JOB
IT IS TO FOCUS ON EDUCATION THE
FOOT SAID OF COURSE ISN'T IT'S A
LESS PRONE POSITION MAYBE IT'S
TOO EASY FOR GOVERNOR TO SELL
THAT THE S. B. I.'S
RESPOSIBILITY AT STATE BOARDS
MONTHS BILL I'M GONNA FOCUS ON.
YEAH CLIMATE CHANGE HIGH SPEED
RAIL OTHER THINGS AND AND NOT
FOCUS ON ON ON EDUCATION SO ON
THIS IS THIS IS ATTENTION HERE
AND I'M NOT SURE THERE'S. A
CLEAR ANSWER I I'M SO MY
RESPONSE WAS WHAT A REALLY GOOD
POINT
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I WOULD TAKE
TO.
ONE.
I'M.
THIS STATE BOARD IS THE CASE I
MEAN OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE GROW YOUR
EAR HERE INCREASING THE POWER
THE STATE PORTING YOU'RE ALSO
TALKING HOW THE STATE CHANGING
THE WAY IT'S CONSTITUTED MEANING
GIVING THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE. AYE AYE AYE OPPORTUNITY
HELP CHOOSE WHO'S ON THE STATE
BOARD SO IT'S THE STATE BOARD
AND THEN THE GOVERNOR AND YOU
LOOK AT HOW THINGS REALLY WORK
RIGHT NOW IN CALIFORNIA. THE
STATE BOARD IS WHERE THE POWERS
AND IT'S WORKED QUITE WELL THAT
HIS WORD IS NOW UNDER THIS
GOVERNOR THE WAY IT'S BEEN DONE
ELIMINATED POSITION. W. I'LL
WITHOUT THE MAUREEN DIMARCO
POSITION ELIMINATE THE MAUREEN
DIMARCO POSITION HE HE.
CONSOLIDATED QUITE HONESTLY THE
AUTHORITY UNDER.
YOU KNOW MY CURSED AND IF THE
AND AND AND THAT THOSE PEOPLE
WHO RUN THE STATE BOARD. IT'S
BEEN A IT'S BEEN A PRETTY GOOD
RELATIONSHIP OVERALL BETWEEN THE
STATE BOARD GOVERNOR AND AND AND
AND I S. B. I TO RELIGION IN
GENERAL. ON BUT IT'S BABE DONE
IT'S A LOT OF THIS IN PRACTICE
HAS COME UNDER AND WE'RE SAYING
INSTITUTIONALIZE THAT STRUCTURE.
I'M I WOULD ARGUE THAT IN THE
STRUCTURE WERE PROPOSING. THAT
THE FBI IS MUCH MORE EFFECTIVE
ADVOCATE THEY'RE NOT
ADMINISTRATOR THEIR EFFECTIVE
ADVOCATE FOR KIDS IN EDUCATION
AND YOUNG PEOPLE ON THIS THING
AND THEY ARE THEY'RE ACTUALLY
HAVE THE TIME INSTEAD OF
MANAGING. THE STATE THAT THE
STATE INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE STRUCTURE THEY'RE
THERE TO BE EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IF WE DID ELECTED
GOVERNOR WHO WAS A LOUSY ON
EDUCATION OR DIDN'T CARE ABOUT
EDUCATION WAS. WORRIED ABOUT
WHATEVER THAT PARTICULAR
GOVERNOR MIGHT BE DIVERTED
THEY'RE DIVERTING THEIR
ATTENTION DO YOU HAVE A STRONG
ELECTED OFFICIAL TO POKE TO
RETURN THE FOCUS TO THOSE
ISSUES.
INCLUDING AT THE HIGHER ED LEVEL
WHICH WAS YOUR EARLIER QUESTION
BECAUSE THEY'RE GONNA BE
INVOLVED AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEVEL AT THE CAL THE
REGION'S LEVEL. AND AND CAL
STATE LEVEL SO I ACTUALLY THINK
THAT THIS THEIR DESTRUCTION
WOULD ROUGH THAT WEEK THAT THE
PEOPLE
ELECTED TO DO BUT THEN DON'T
KNOW THE DETAILS ANY. IN THE
THIRD SEPTEMBER WAS ASKING ABOUT
SECTOR STAY THE AGM THAT'S TRUE
THEY RUN COMPLEX AGENCY DO. I
AND.
YOU KNOW EDUCATION COURSE HAS A
WHOLE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
GOVERNANCE COMPONENT TO THIS
THAT DOESN'T.
EXISTING QUITE THE SAME WAY
OTHER D. A.'S LIKE IT OR NOT
ALSO REGISTER RECORDERS.
AT THE COUNTY LEVELS IN THE AND
EDUCATE ON THE ELECTIONS
ADMINISTRATION AS IT RELATES TO
THE SECRETARY STATE.
I'M CERTAINLY THEIR LOCAL LOCAL
PROSECUTORS AND LOCAL COURTS.
I'M.
YOU KNOW OF COURSE THE EDUCATION
SUCH A BIGGER PART OF THE BUDGET
CRACK.
AND SO MAYBE IT'S BETTER TO HAVE
IT ALIGNED IS FOR THAT REASON
ALONE TO TO GET THE GOVERNOR
AND.
A GREATER SENSE OF BRIAN. BUT IT
IS A BIG QUESTIONS I IDEA AND I
I MIGHT THE PART WHY ONE HAVE
HEARINGS FOR US THAT CAN SIT
BACK AND AND NOW SOME OF THESE
QUESTIONS AND.
BUT BUT I THINK YOU TO SOME
EXTENT THE BURDEN OF PROOF.
IT IS ON.
YOU TO TO YOU THE PROPONENTS OF
OF MAKING SUCH A BIG CHANGE IT
BECAUSE.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
YOU KNOW.
SURE WE MAY IF THE CHOICE WERE
THAT WE WERE STARTING A NEW
BRAND NEW STATE.
YOU KNOW WOULD WE STRUCTURE
THINGS THE WAY WE WE DO NOW YOU
KNOW PERHAPS NOT MAYBE MORE LAWS
WHICH IS OBSESSING BUT THE
QUESTION IS.
IF WE'RE GOING TO.
TAKE ALL THE STEPS NECESSARY ALL
THE A A UPHEAVAL ASSOCIATED AYE
IS GOING TO BE WORTH IT.
I'M NOT AND I THINK THAT'S A
GREAT I ACTUALLY THINK.
THAT'S CANDIDLY A REALLY WELL OF
GROW A GOOD WAY TO LOOK AT IT I
WOULD ASSUME THAT HOW WE WOULD
WANT YOU ALL TO LOOK AT IT. WE
FEEL STRONGLY THAT IT IS WORTH
IT YEAH BUT HAVING SAID IF
YOU'RE RIGHT AND I ALSO THINK
IT'S FAIR FOR YOU TO SAY. THAT
WE SHOULD SUBMIT MORE EVIDENCE
TO YOU AND I'M A AND WE WILL OF
OF WHY WE BELIEVE THIS WILL
DELIVER AND AS MUCH EVIDENCE AS
WE CAN FIND THAT EXISTS WHICH.
BASED ON WHAT WE HEARD FROM THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE IS NOT GOING
TO BE PERFECT IF NOT GOING TO BE
THE UNIQUE WE TAILORED
SCIENTIFIC STUDY THAT YOU MIGHT
IDEALLY LIKE OUT. BUT I AGREE
THAT THERE IS A BURDEN ON US TO
AFFIRM BILLY SHOW THAT WHY THAT
WILL HAPPEN WE WILL BE HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THAT. I'M IN THE US AND
BUT I ALSO THINK THIS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT STRUCTURE AND THAT
THAT'S WHY GO BACK TO THE TIMING
THIS IS EITHER GOING TO HAPPEN
THIS YEAR OR IT'S NOT. THIS IS
THE RIGHT YEAR THAT THE OTHER
THING I WOULD SAY IS IT'S NOT
GONNA HAPPEN IT IN IN TWENTY
NINETEEN OR TWENTY TWENTY IT'S
GONNA HAPPEN IN A YEAR WHERE.
THE GOVERNOR IS TURNING OUT THE
SPI IS TURNING OUT AND AND AND
AND THEY DON'T HAVE SKIN IN THE
GAME IN THAT PARTICULAR WAY OR
BROWN THEIR OWN PARTICULAR STUFF
SO YOU LOOKING ABROAD STRUCTURAL
ISSUE. IT'S THING DISCUSS WITH
WISE PEOPLE
AND WE'RE. VERY PLEASED I HAVE
TWO VERY VERY WISE PEOPLE ARE
GONNA COME UP TO THE NEXT PANEL.
AND GIVE US SOME PERSPECTIVES
ABOUT GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE TO
PEOPLE WHO'VE HAD A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE IN THIS SPACE.
NOT GARY HART ARE FROM SECTOR
EDUCATION ALSO FORMER STATE
SENATOR AND I BELIEVE CHAIR
THIS.
AUGUST COMMITTEE.
AND THEN ALSO GAVIN PAIN FORMED
ITS CHIEF DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF INSTRUCTION WHO BRINGS A
PERSPECTIVE HAVING SERVED AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF OF THE AND THE
DEPARTMENT DUCATION. AND WE'RE
VERY MUCH LOOKING FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH DRIVING THANK YOU MISTER
STARR THANK YOU.
SO WE WELCOME YOU BACK TO THE
SENATE. S. SENATOR HART.
AND.
AND LOOK FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU OF MISTER CHAIRMAN HEN
DEAD CHAIRMAN DONALD UP IN SUCH
BE BACK IN FORTY TWO OR THREE
AND LOOK AT THIS MILLION
HIDEOUSLY INSTEAD OF LOOKING AT
YOU.
I'M. REALLY ENJOYED LISTENING TO
THE TESTIMONY CUT TODAY IN THE
DISCUSSION BECAUSE I THINK YOU
RAISED ALL OF THE.
PORTANTO ISSUES AND CONCERNS I'M
I JUST TO TRY TO BUILD UPON
YOUR.
WHEN YOUR LAST QUESTIONS.
THOSE SENATOR ALAN TO OF THE
WITNESS WAS WHAT IS WHAT IS THE
BIG ISSUE HERE WHAT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT WE NEED TO
BE THINKING ABOUT.
AND FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IS
SOMEONE WHO SERVED.
IN THE LEGISLATURE FOR TWENTY
YEARS BUT ALSO AS A CLASSROOM
TEACHER NOT FOR QUITE AS LONG AS
HER. SUBLIMINAL DONALD BUT FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AS A HIGHSCHOOL
TEACHER AND ALSO AS A
RETURN OF EDUCATE.
THE ISSUE OF EDUCATION IS IN A
WHAT BROUGHT ME TO A LEGISLATURE
MORE THAN THING ELSE IT'S WHAT
I'M I DEEPLY CARE ABOUT.
AND THE ISSUE I THINK THAT'S
MOST IMPORTANT HERE IS THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
GOVERNOR AND THE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION YOU HAVE
TO ELECTED OFFICIALS. MAY
EXECUTIVE BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT
TO CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS.
AND THE CHALLENGE THAT YOU HAVE
IS THAT WHEN THOSE.
INDIVIDUALS.
ARE NOT IN ALIGNMENT THERE'S
DISAGREEMENT WHETHER IT'S A
PARTISAN DISAGREEMENT AND
IDEOLOGICAL DISAGREEMENT A
PERSONALITY DISAGREEMENT.
.
IT'S AN ISSUE.
AND THE CONCERN THAT I HAVE IS
THAT.
THE GOVERNOR HAS ALMOST ALL OF
THE POWER THE GOVERNOR HAS THE
POWER OF THE PURSE.
THE GOVERNOR HAS THE POWER OF
VETO. OF THE GOVERNOR HAS THE
POLICY OF APPOINTMENT.
OF HIM THROUGH HIS STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION AND THE WAY THE
STATUTE HAS BEEN WRITTEN AND
INTERPRETED BY THE COURTS.
THE POLICY FOR EDUCATION REST
NOT WITH THE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION BUT WITH THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION.
BOB IT SO WHEN YOU HAVE THESE
BATTLES BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR AND
THE SUPERINTENDENT AND THERE
HAPPENED BATTLES IN THE PAST.
OF CURRENTLY WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW. A QUITE FUNCTIONAL
PEACEFUL RELATIONSHIP I THINK
THAT EXISTS BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR
THE STATE POURED.
AND OF THE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION BUT THAT
HASN'T ALWAYS BEEN THE CASE AND
I THOUGHT IT MIGHT JUST BE
INSTRUCTED.
OF FROM
PERRANCE.
MISTER TO SHARE WITH YOU YOU
KNOW WHAT. SOME OF THOSE
CONFLICTS HAVE BEEN IN THE PAST.
BECAUSE WE'D.
THEY'RE LIKELY TO REEMERGE IN
THE FUTURE YOU KNOW AT SOME
POINT IN HIGH I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE ANSWER IS BUT THE LET JUST
MADE NO MENTION TWO OR THREE OF
THESE ONE IS. FIX UP THE
CONFLICT IN SOME RESPECTS HAVE
SPARKED SO MANY OF THE PREVIOUS
STUDIES THAT HAVE CALLED FOR
CHANGES.
DEREK YOU KNOW THEM BUT I THINK
IT'S REALLY NOTEWORTHY EVEN
THOUGH THESE ARE NUTS
QUANTITATIVE RESEARCH STUDIES IT
REALLY IS REMARKABLE THAT OVER
THE YEARS THE LEGISLATURE.
AS WELL AS.
ALL OF THESE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSIONS HAVE COME TO THE
SAME.
THERE OUGHT TO BE MORE POWER
THAT'S GIVEN TO THE GOVERNOR AND
LIST TO THE SUPERINTENDENT IN
PART BECAUSE.
THAT'S THE DE FACTO OF
RELATIONSHIP THAT THAT EXISTS
AND WE OUGHT TO BE MORE. BUT I
THINK FORTHCOMING AND.
IN ESTABLISH AND AND I THINK IT
ALSO ONE OTHER POINT SENATOR PAN
MADE REFERENCE TO THIS.
ITEM THE ISSUE OF I THINK
CONFUSION IS AN IMPORTANT ONE I
THINK THE ELECTORATE OFTENTIMES
AND EDUCATORS AS WELL WHO HAVE
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF AT THE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
BELIEVE IT THE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION IT IS A YOU
KNOW A VERY POWERFUL PERSON.
THAT THEY HAVE FISCAL.
AUTHORITY THAT THEY HAVE POLICY
MAKING AUTHORITY WHEN. IN FACT
THEY MAY NOT HAVE THAT MUCH IN
THAT CAN BE MISLEADING I THINK
TO A TO EDUCATORS. BLOW ME GET
BACK TO JUST UP.
OF THIS ISSUE ABOUT SOME OF THE
CONFLICTS THAT EXISTED IN THE
PAST AND I ALSO WANTED TO MAKE
IT PLEASE JUST PASSING REFERENCE
TO THE ISSUE OF HIGHER
EDUCATION.
AND GOVERNANCE AS RELEASED THE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION.
SO AS IT RELATES TO.
THE PARTISAN NATURE I JUST PUT
POINT OUT THAT OBVIOUSLY THE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION IS A NONPARTISAN
OFFICE.
BUT IN FACT FOR THE TIME THAT I
SEARCH THE LEGISLATURE YOU HAVE
A SITUATION WHERE.
OF THE GOVERNOR'S TENDED TO BE
REPUBLICAN.
A REAGAN RIGHT BEFORE I GOT
ELECTED THE LEGISLATURE AND
THEN.
WILSON DEUKMEJIAN AND.
SCHWARZENEGGER ARM AND THE
SUPERINTENDENT WAS.
A DEMOCRAT TED FOR THE LAST
TWENTY FIVE YEARS IT'S BEEN
SOMEONE WHO COMES OUT OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
PARTISAN.
YOU KNOW PROMINENCES A MEMBER
OF THE LEGISLATURE A PRIOR TO TO
THAT YOU HAD PEOPLE WHO WERE
SERVING AS SUPERINTENDENT.
WHO ARE REGISTERED DEMOCRATS
BUT?
INTO WEREN'T YOU KNOW PROMOTING
THAT THAT THAT PHILOSOPHY BUT
WHEN YOU HAVE THIS.
PARTISAN DIFFERENCE WITH HER IN
THE PAST AT LEAST REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR AND A DEMOCRATIC OF
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION.
THERE THERE WERE ISSUES.
.
AND.
THERE WAS.
I COULD.
MENTION A NUMBER BUT THE ONE
THAT COMES WITH THEM MOST
PRODUCTS MIND IS A AND A
GOVERNOR WHO FELT THAT THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION WAS LIKELY GOING TO
BE UPON. ARRIVAL LEAST THAT WAS
THE RUMOR FELT THAT THAT WAS
GOING TO BE A SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION WAS GOING TO
RUN AGAINST GOVERNOR.
AND IT'S RESULT OF THE HAD BEEN
VIEWED AS A POTENTIAL RIVAL AN
OPPONENT.
INTO ACTIONS WERE TAKEN BY THE
GOVERNOR IN TERMS OF BUDGET
TING.
VETOES AND WHAT NOT THAT.
WERE CONTRARY TO THE INTERESTS
THE SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION AND I.
FELT IN THAT SITUATION THAT
THERE'S COLLATERAL DAMAGE IN
THAT SITUATION WHERE KICKOFF
EDUCATION I THINK AND SUFFER IF
THE GOVERNOR. HAS IT OUT FOR THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION.
THE OTHER ISSUE THAT BOB.
SOMETIMES COMES UP AND IT IS THE
ISSUE OF I THINK PERSONALITIES
WHICH IS VERY IMPORTANT POLITICS
IF YOU HAVE A SUPERINTENDENT
THAT HAS A STRONG PERSONALITY
THAT HAS SOME
IT SAY A BRASH PERSONALITY.
AND SAYS ON OCCASION THINGS
THAT THE GOVERNOR. A DOZEN
APPRECIATE.
THAT GOVERNOR ABUSES
INTEMPERATE NOT FAIR
INAPPROPRIATE. UP THAT'S ANOTHER
EXAMPLE WHERE THE THE GOVERNOR
CAN.
I THINK TAKE ACTION AGAINST TO
THE SUPERINTENDENT AND
ULTIMATELY TOWARDS. K. TWELVE
EDUCATION THAT I THINK IS SO YOU
KNOW IS SOMETIMES UNFORTUNATE.
OF REFERENCE WAS MADE TO.
THE DEMARCO POSITION.
SECRETARY OF EDUCATION WHICH
WAS CREATED.
BY GOVERNOR WILSON.
IN NINETEEN NINETY AND
MAINTAINED BY GOVERNOR DAVIS AND
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER AND AS
WAS MENTIONED.
HAS BEEN ELIMINATED BY GOVERNOR
BROWN.
ON THAT THE MINUS SIDE OF
HAVING SUCH AN OFFICES WAS MADE
REFERENCE IT TO SORT OF
INCREASES THE NUMBER OF POINTS
OF.
OF VOTE THE AUTHORITY THAT CAN
BE CONFUSING TO PEOPLE.
THE POSITIVE ASPECT OF THAT IS
THAT IT DOES HAVE SOMEONE WHO IS
WORKING DIRECTLY WITH THE
GOVERNOR IF THEY HAVE THE
CONFIDENCE THAT THE GOVERNOR WHO
IS WORKING ON A DAILY BASIS WITH
THE GOVERNOR ON K. TWELVE
EDUCATION.
AND MOVES AWAY FROM THIS
SITUATION CENTER PAN MADE
REFERENCE TO EARLIER THAT I
THINK IS.
NOT SO MUCH RECENTLY BUT IF YOU
GO BACK.
A COUPLE OF DECADES AS I DO
WHERE THERE REALLY WAS A FEELING
ON THE PART I THINK OF SOME
GOVERNOR'S I WOULD SAY.
IF NOT CONSCIOUSLY UNCONSCIOUSLY
THAT EDUCATION ISN'T MY DOMAIN.
THAT'S WE HAVE ELECTED
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICER AND SO
THE GOVERNOR DID NOT PAY
PARTICULAR CLOSE ATTENTION OR AS
MUCH ATTENTION AS THEY MIGHT IF
THEY HAD SOMEONE IN THEIR
CABINET. IN THE HORSESHOE THAT
WAS ACTUALLY WORKING ON K.
TWELVE I'M ISSUES.
BOB BUT WHEN I WAS SERVING AS
SECRETARY OF EDUCATION THE
GOVERNOR.
RATHER THAN USING THE OFFICE
ENTIRELY AS HE POLICY MAKING
OFFICE WHICH WAS WHAT IT WAS SET
UP TO DO. UP BECAUSE THE
GOVERNOR DID NOT HAVE CONFIDENCE
IN THE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION. DEEP TO THE OFFICE
OF THE SECRETARY OF EDUCATION
SOME ADMINISTRATIVE
RESPONSIBILITIES TO CARRY OUT
PROGRAMS THAT THE GOVERNOR WERE
NEAR AND DEAR TO THE GOVERNOR'S
HEART. SO YOU HAVE THESE ISSUES
PARTISANSHIP OF PERSONALITY
DIFFERENCE OF LACK OF CONFIDENCE
IN THE.
THE OFFICE OF THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION ON OCCASION. AND
THOSE THINGS REALLY GET IN THE
WAY I THINK ON OCCASION OF ARM.
NOT ONLY GOOD WORKING
RELATIONSHIP BUT.
I THINK TO THE DETRIMENT OF K.
TWELVE EDUCATION BECAUSE I
MENTIONED EARLIER THE POWER
REALLY RESTS WITH THE GOVERNOR
AND THE GOVERNOR WANTS TO.
SO IS THAT A POWER OVER THE SUIT
ATTENDANT.
YOU KNOW THEY CAN.
SO THOSE HER.
SOME COMMENTS AS IT RELATES TO
MY EXPERIENCE.
SERVING IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
IN THIS POSITION OF SECRETARY
VEGETATION AND THAT'S. REALLY I
THINK SENSITIVE AND IMPORTANT
RELATIONSHIP THAT EXISTS BETWEEN
OF THE GOVERNOR TOM AND THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION.
PERSONALLY I THINK BASED UPON MY
EXPERIENCE OF THE OFFICE OF THE
ATTEND A PUBLIC INSTRUCTION
SHOULD BE ABOLISHED.
IN WE REALLY OUGHT A HAVE. A
CLEARER ALIGNMENT OF.
AUTHORITY AND IT REALLY OUGHT
TO REST WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THE
AUTHORITY EXISTS IN CALIFORNIA
AND. REGIONAL PEOPLE CAN DIFFER
AS TO WHETHER THAT'S THE.
BUT YOU KNOW TOO MUCH
CONCENTRATION OF POWER BUT GIVEN
THE FACT THAT WE GOT A THOUSAND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WE GOT FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS OF
SCHOOLS I THINK THERE'S ALREADY.
A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF
DISPERSION OF OF.
.
YOU KNOW OF HOWARD THAT TERM YOU
KNOW THAT EXISTS. UP I DID WANT
TO COMMENT JUST BRIEFLY IF I
COULD MISTER CHAIRMAN ON THIS
ISSUE OF HIGHER EDUCATION
BECAUSE I THINK WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT GOVERNANCE.
SENATE MAY NOT BE
UP ON IMPORTANT PART OF THE
HEARING TODAY I'D I DO BELIEVE
THAT.
TRYING TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE OF
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN HIGH K.
TWELVE AND HIGHER EDUCATION IN
GOVERNANCE IS SOMETHING THAT IS
WORTHY OF THE COMMITTEE'S
ATTENTION.
OF AND WE DO NOT HAVE AN OVERALL
COORDINATING SYSTEM FOR OUR
ENTIRE EDUCATION SYSTEM AND
INCREASINGLY WE HAVE ISSUES.
BETWEEN K. TWELVE AND HIGHER
EDUCATION THAT DESERVE ATTENTION
ISSUES
RELATING TO.
COURSES THAT ARE TAKEN TEACHER
REQUIREMENTS IN PREPARATION
ARTICULATION OF BETWEEN HIGH
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
OF I JUST NOTICED A RECENT THERE
YESTERDAY IN THE LOS ANGELES
TIMES THERE WAS A STORY ABOUT.
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION AND
THE NUMBER OF DOCTORS STUDENTS
THAT ARE NOT APPLYING FOR.
CAL GRANTS OF THE APPLICATIONS
ARE DOWN FIFTY PERCENT. ONE OF
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE THAT THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION HAS IS
GETTING THE WORD OUT TO HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS UP VERTICALLY
WITH OUR OUR BADLY.
FUNDED HIGH SCHOOL COUNSELORS
AND SO THERE'S AN IMPORTANT ROLE
FOR THIS TO NAY COMMISSION IN
WORKING
K. TWELVE AND IT DOES SEEM TO ME
THAT NOT ONLY.
HAVING.
THE SUPERINTENDENT.
ON THE.
COMMUNICABLE WHICH PORT OF A
TRUST AND GOVERNOR'S SAYS FOODS
SUPERINTENDENT IS ALREADY ON THE
UC AND CSU.
REGIONS AND BOARDS OF TRUSTEES
BUT HAVING REPRESENTATION OF THE
SUPERINTENDENT ON THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION. MIGHT BE A
WORTHWHILE THING MOST
IMPORTANTLY WHAT WE NEED IS SOME
KIND OF A GOVERNANCE
COORDINATING BODY I BELIEVE OF
FOR ALL OF EDUCATION THAT
REPRESENTS. THE LEADERS OF THE
HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS. OF I
WOULD SUGGEST AT THIS POINT IN
TIME HAVING THE SUPERINTENDENT
AS WELL AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION.
CERTAIN SUCH A BODY MISTER OF AN
INFORMAL BODY THAT CURRENTLY
EXISTS CALL THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION ROUNDTABLE THAT MEETS
TWO OR THREE TIMES A YEAR AT
THIS REALLY DOES HAVE A STAFF A
DOZEN HAVE RESOURCES IT DOESN'T
HAVE ANY.
CLEAR.
MANDATE BUT I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT.
NEEDS TO TAKE PLACE THERE OUGHT
TO BE A STATUTE THAT WOULD
REQUIRE SUCH OF A BODY. OF IT
OUGHT HAVE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TO THE GOVERNOR AND
TO THE LEGISLATURE AND THERE'S
ROLE FOR THE SUPERINTENDENT AND
FOR THE PRESIDENT OF THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION A.
TO PLAY IN THAT REGARD SO IT'S.
IN JUST ONE SUGGESTION THAT I I
WANTED TO MAKE BEFORE.
CONCLUDING MY REMARKS.
VERY INTERESTING AND I'VE TAKEN
A LOT AND THAT'S ALL WE ASK YOU
SOME QUESTIONS WE GET TENSTA. TO
DO THAT SO LET'S ONE WE. TURN.
TO OUR NEXT PANELIST KEVIN PAYNE
WHO IS THE FORMER CHIEF WCW
STRUCTURE AND.
TO GIVE HIS TESTIMONY WHO THANK
CHAIRMAN ALAN AND.
CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL AND MEMBERS
I I I I APPRECIATE EXPLORING
THIS TOPIC I FOR PARTICULARLY
APPRECIATE BEING INVITED TO.
COMMENT.
M.. COUPLE THINGS UP FRONT I
APPLAUD COMMONSENSE FOR TRYING
TO ADDRESS A VEXING PROBLEM IT'S
BEEN A PROMISE OF WE HAVE
ACKNOWLEDGED THROUGHOUT THIS
HEARING IS A. SONG THAT GOES
ALONG AND COMMON SENSE IS A
TRUSTED VOICE IN THE SPACE ACT
TOLD JIM ANYTIME TODAY HELPED
RAISE MY KIDS.
AND THAT WITHOUT COMMON SENSE.
MARKETS WOULD BE MUCH BETTER
SHAPE THAN THAN THEY PROBABLY
ARE NOW NOT TO SAY THEY'RE IN
GREAT SHAPE.
HEALTH SENATOR LITTLE OF A SHOUT
OUT TO YOU SEE ES FOR THE WORK
THAT THEY'VE DONE IN COMPILING.
LE THE THEM TO THE DATA
STRUCTURAL.
BIG STRUCTURES THAT EXIST IN IN
IN STATES THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
AND THE CHALLENGES THAT THAT
DERIVED THEREFROM.
BUT I DO WANT TO THE LIMIT OF
THE BACK ON ME.
FOR SOME OF YOU WHO DON'T KNOW
ME I SERVED FOR FOURTEEN YEARS
HAS LED STAFF.
I IN THE BUILDING WITH SENATOR
SOME WOMEN THAT AND SENATOR JACK
O'CONNELL AND BUT THE DISTRICT
OF THE CAPITAL. IN THAT TIME WE
SERVED UNDER THREE DIFFERENT
GOVERNOR'S TO MAJOR IN WILSON
DAVIS.
WE ARE OBVIOUSLY PART LEADERSHIP
STAFF AND US SENATE O'CONNELL
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
EDUCATION BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
FOR MANY YEARS.
I THEN WENT WITH HIM TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND AND
SERVE TOOK THE LEGISLATIVE HOUSE
HAD OFTEN BUT THAT. EXECUTIVE
HAT ON AND SERVED FOR ALMOST
EIGHT YEARS AS THE CHIEF DEPUTY
A CD <c.green> WE SERVER THAT
UNDER</c>
TO GOVERNOR SAVES FROM
SCHWARZENEGGER.
NOW WE HAD ROBUST CONVERSATIONS
DURING THAT PERIOD OF TIME AT
THE SIZE THE WORK WE HAD TO DO
IT AT THAT. AT THE DEPARTMENT
CONVERSATIONS RUN P. SIXTEEN.
OUR CONVERSATIONS ABOUT CLOSING
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS THAT WE TRIED
TO LEASE SAYS STATEWIDE
CONVERSATIONS.
AND WE WERE THE PROGENITORS IN
AND THE SPONSORS OF THE EARLIEST
OF THE GETTING ON THE FACTS
STUDIES WHICH I THINK.
RESULTED IN MUCH OF WHAT WE'VE
BEEN DEALING WITH THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS.
AND AFTER THAT I SPENT THREE
YEARS WITH THE BILL AND MELINDA
GATES FOUNDATION RUNNING THEIR
POLICY SHOP FOR EDUCATION IN THE
UNITED STATES.
A AND HAD EXPERIENCE FROM THAT
IT IN MANY DIFFERENT PLACES
AROUND THE COUNTRY. AND THE
OVERTURE SORT OF MANY YEARS AT
IN PRIVATE PRACTICE AS A
CONSULTANT TO AN ADVOCATE A
COACH AND A FACILITATOR
CONVERSATIONS MOST RECENTLY I.
STILL ATTEND THE CONVERSATION
WAS VERY SIMILAR TO THE ONE
WE'RE HAVING IN THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON.
OBVIOUSLY MY COMMENTS ARE MY OWN
I DON'T REPRESENT ANYBODY IN
THIS.
BUT THEY'RE BASED ON THESE
COUPLE DECADES OF EXPERIENCE.
DON'T TALK ABOUT THE ISSUE FROM
A FROM A SAMPLE OF POLICY AND
POLITICS.
AND SO THESE ARE MY MAIN POINTS
THE THEY ARE AND I THINK WE'VE
HEARD A LOT OF EVIDENCE HERE
TODAY THE DISH WITH NO PERFECT
STRUCTURE TO ENSURE. EFFICIENCY
AND I THINK EFFICIENCY IS PART
OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET OUT
HERE.
EVEN IF THERE WERE I WOULD STILL
POSITED THAT AND I WOULD CHOOSE
THAT THERE BE A STRONG ELECTED
SPI AS A KEY COMPONENT OF THAT
STRUCTURE.
MY THIRD POINT IS THAT SOME OF
ITS ESPECIALLY CALIFORNIA
HISTORICAL AND PRACTICAL PERSON
CONSIDERATIONS PREVENT BIG
STRUCTURAL CHANGE.
AND I THINK WE'VE SEEN THAT THE
PREPONDERANCE OF STUDIES AND THE
LACK HUNDREDS OF ACTION HAS HURT
GIVEN IT TO THEM.
AND I THINK ALSO MY WOULD LAST
POINT I WANT TO MAKE TO IS THAT
I THINK IT'S BEEN TOUCHED UPON
TO BOTH AND THAT SORT OF THE.
.
CREE QUE AND EARLY LEARNING AND
IN THE POST SECONDARY PARTLY
QUESTION THAT THAT. THE GROUP A
GREAT CONVERSATION TO BE HAS A
CONVERSATION ABOUT LINKAGES OF
THOSE AND ENTER. OUR INTER
SEGMENTAL RESPONSIBILITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY NOTHING IS A
GREAT CONVERSATION. PERHAPS THE
THAT COMMITTEES CAN UNDERTAKE A
GOING FORWARD.
I AM SO OBVIOUSLY A DOUBLE THE
NUMBER OF OF ORGANIZATIONS THIS
IS MY FIRST POINT EVERY
GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE IS FROM
WASHINGTON TO. LOUISIANA TO NEW
YORK TO MASSACHUSETTS THAT.
YOU'VE HAD OF THE PRESENTATION
RECESS AND THERE ARE SOME OF FOR
BAIT GREAT MODELS.
A FORGOTTEN GENERAL BUCKETS OF
GOVERNANCE AND THEN TWELVE
STATES HAVE DONE THEIR OWN THING
OUTSIDE OF THOSE AND. AND IN YOU
KNOW GET SINCE I THINK I HAVE WE
SEEN THAT THERE IS ONE THAT
RISES TO THE TOP AND SO
DEMONSTRATES TO ME THAT THERE.
REALLY IS NO PERFECT STRUCTURE.
TIME FOR OPERATING THIS
ENTERPRISE IF THERE IF THERE WAS
WOULD HAVE IF THERE WAS GOING TO
BE HAVING ROBUST CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW TO ANY SORT OF FIX IT
THAT WAY.
TO MY FUNDAMENTAL CONCLUSION
ALWAYS HAS BEEN AND SORT OF BEEN
THROUGHOUT THE CONVERSATIONS
WHEN I WAS PLEDGE THAT FROM WHEN
I WAS OF THE DEPARTMENT THAT.
STRUCTURES REALLY THROUGH THE
MATERIAL. UNLESS IT ISN'T AND
FOR MANY OTHER REASONS THAT GARY
ISLA OUTLINED.
M.. STRUCTURE IS A STRUCTURES
BLAME IN SOME INSTANCES FOR
ISSUES THAT ARE UNRELATED TO THE
TO
THE ISSUES THAT ARE HAPPENING.
POLITICAL PERSONAL PHILOSOPHICAL
DISAGREEMENTS ARE POSSIBLE AND
PROBABLE IN ANY STRUCTURE THE
HAVE WHETHER IT'S ELECTED OR
APPOINTED OFFICIALS INEFFICIENCY
IS POSSIBLE AND.
REGULAR NOT UNDER ANY STRUCTURE
THAT YOU HAVE IS THE NATURE IN
THE FORM OF OUR GOVERNMENT
ESPECIALLY HISTORY LEADERSHIP.
MY SECOND POINT IS THAT
ULTIMATELY I SUPPORT THE NOTION.
THAT ISN'T TRYING TO OUR
CONSTITUTION THAT THERE IT THAT
THEY'RE BEING ELECTED PERSON
WHOSE SOLE JOB IT IS.
TO PAY ATTENTION TO OUR
STUDENTS.
ONE PERSON THE GUARDIAN OF THE
PROMOTER THE PROTECTOR THE NIGER
THE SUPERINTENDENT IF YOU WILL.
OF THE NEEDS OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE
OF THE STATE WHO REPRESENT OUR
FUTURE IF YOU ARE ECONOMIC
SUCCESS IN OUR SOCIAL SUCCESS IN
FUTURE IN CALIFORNIA.
MY SENSE IS THAT IT EDUCATION'S
A GOBLET EXERCISE WHAT IS MY
SENSE MY EXPERIENCE IS EDUCATION
IS A COMPLICATED A TENER PRAWNS.
LET DESERVES NO LESS LEADERSHIP
AND SINGLE MINDED FOCUS THAN
DOES JUSTICE WHO'S MORE
COMPLICATED WE THOUGHT HAVE.
WAS CERTAINLY WHEN WE GOT THERE.
I'M.
YEAH WHO SINGLE MINDED FOCUS IS
IMPORTANT.
AS JUSTICE TREASURY.
OR EVEN INSURANCE.
SO TO THE HISTORICAL ON
PRACTICAL ISSUES THAT. WE'RE IN
IT AND EXTENDED PERIOD IS NO
QUESTION ABOUT IT OF GOOD
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN THE
GOVERNOR'S A STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION ELECTIVES
SUPERINTENDENT. AND ALONG WITH
YOU FUNDAMENTAL AND LASTING
CHANGE HAS BEEN MADE TO THE
STRUCTURE OF EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA.
YEAH AND IT HAS ALWAYS IT IN
HOUSE HELD IN A VERY POSITIVE
ACTIVITY ESPECIALLY IN VIEW OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE STATE'S
MOST PARTICULARLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING THE PARALLEL.
PREVIOUSLY.
UNDERGOVERNOR DAVIS AT SET TO
PRETEND O'CONNELL WITH A SIMILAR
VERY GOOD WORKING RELATIONSHIP.
ESPECIALLY WHEN GARY WAS THE.
SECRETARY OF EDUCATION.
AND THE SUPERINTENDENTS
PHILOSOPHY THAN WHAT WAS ALWAYS
GOOD GOVERNANCE DOESN'T MATTER
AS LONG AS THE PLAYERS IN EACH
GAME GAUGE WITH EACH OTHER
FORTHRIGHTLY.
FAIRLY AND HONORABLY IT WAS
ABOUT RELATIONSHIPS.
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY REQUIRED US
TO BE THAT TO HEAR THE NOTION
THAT THERE WERE THAT THERE BE NO
SURPRISES AND THOSE WERE OUR
RULES OF ENGAGEMENT WHEN WE
ENGAGE WITH THE STATE BOARD.
WHEN HE WAS THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT AND I HAVE TO
TELL YOU IT WAS EASY AT TIMES
AND SORELY TESTED AT OTHER TIMES
BECAUSE.
ULTIMATELY OF COURSE AS WE ALL
KNOW WE HAD A VERY BAD WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH GOVERNOR
ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER.
I COULD TELL YOU STORIES BUT NOT
BUT OFF MIKE.
AND THE STORIES IS GARY RELATED
TO.
FROM PREVIOUS SBI'S IN PREVIOUS
GOVERNORS ARE ARE LEGENDARY
EQUALLY LEGEND.
FROM A PRACTICAL STANDPOINT
LEASE FROM POLITICAL PRACTICAL
STANDPOINT FROM MY FROM MY
STANDPOINT MOST OFTEN IN
CALIFORNIA THE CONTEXT IS THE
CONTEXT IN ITS TO THE CONUNDRUM
IS CAST AS CONFLICT BETWEEN THE
FBI AND THE GOVERNOR'S THROUGH
HIS OR HER BOARD OF EDUCATION.
THE PREMISE IS THAT TO FIX THE
PROBLEM ONE OF THE PLAYERS HAS
TO BE SUBSTANTIALLY DISEMPOWERED
AND USUALLY THAT'S THE SPI.
BUT OPPOSITE THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL.
SO FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE REAL
CHANGE TO CHANGE THE ORDER OF
BUSINESS.
MEANS THAT IT REQUIRES A AND A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT.
WE'VE SEEN IT THAT VOTERS LIKE
TO VOTE FOR PEOPLE THAT
REPRESENT THEM.
FUNNY THING ABOUT THAT.
SO IT'S NOT A PRACTICAL SOLUTION
OCCUR IN THE FBI.
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST POINTED
OUT THAT THERE WERE THREE TIMES
IN THE PAST ALREADY AND THEY
WERE NOT SUCCESS.
TOOK ME TECH TO GIVEN THE STI
AND THAT ARE THE QUESTION ON THE
OTHER SIDE WHAT GOVERNOR WOULD
OPT TO GET RID OF THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION OR
DISEMPOWERED THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION.
GOVERNOR'S LIKE TO AND ARE
ENTITLED TO HAVE INFLUENCE
CONTROL. AND THEIR VOICE
THROUGH THEIR APPOINTEES AS
CONFIRMED BY THE SENATE.
SO NO GOVERNOR'S GOING TO GIVE
THAT UP.
SO.
THEN I TURNED THEN I TURN TO THE
COMMONSENSE PROPOSAL AND.
YOU'VE HAD IT BOMBING TIMES HAVE
YOU HEARD PEOPLE COME BEFORE YOU
AND SAY YOU KNOW I LIKE HALF OF
THAT BILL.
IN THIS INSTANCE I LOVE THE
CONCEPT I COME FROM A REALLY
GOOD PLACE.
I APPLAUD THE NOTION THAT
COMMONSENSE READ THE TABLE ABOUT
ALL THE SEGMENTS BEING CONNECTED
TO EACH OTHER.
MY READ THEIR PROPOSAL HOWEVER
THIS HASN'T LEADS ME TO BELIEVE
THAT IT WON'T ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES MIGHT OBFUSCATE SOME
OF THE PROBLEMS THAT WE ALREADY
HAVE.
I'M AND PERHAPS HAS
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES.
THE OTHER POINT THAT I'D MENCKEN
WAS ALREADY MADE IN THE IN THE
COMMITTEE TODAY.
IS THAT THERE ARE NON STATE
COMPONENTS TO THIS EQUATION THAT
ARE THAT HAVE RISEN IN IMPORTANT
ESPECIALLY. IN AN ERA OF
SUBSIDIARITY WHAT ABOUT THE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS WHAT
ABOUT THE CTC.
WHAT ABOUT THE ROLE OF THE C. C.
E.?
DISTRICT LEADERSHIP DISTRICT
BOARDS.
AND I THINK.
.
BOTH THE TERMINAL DONALD SENATOR
PAN IN THE SETTLEMENT KILEY HAVE
MENTIONED THAT THOSE FACTORS ARE
PRETTY KEY ESPECIALLY IN THE NEW
ORDER OF BUSINESS WITHOUT HAPPEN
LCF AT.
SO FROM MY PERSPECTIVE ANY
CONVERSATION ABOUT GOVERNANCE
AND OR STRUCTURE HAS TO ADDRESS
ALL THOSE PARTS.
OF K. TWELVE AND THE END AND
SERVE HORIZONTALLY AND
VERTICALLY WITH THE OTHER
SEGMENTS INVOLVED.
TO MY LAST POINT IS THAT I'D
POSIT WE SHOULD HAVE A LARGER
CONVERSATION NOT ABOUT
STRUCTURE.
BUT ABOUT FUNCTION ABOUT SORT OF
JOINT AND SEVERAL ACCOUNTABILITY
OF ONE SEGMENT TO THE OTHER.
EARLY HEAD AND PRETTY EASY AND
THEN CREE QUE LINKED TO K.
TWELVE AND RESPONSIBLE TO EACH
OTHER QUE TROUBLING TO POST
SECONDARY ROOM AND IN SOME
MEASURE RESPONSIBLE TO EACH
OTHER. ALL SEGMENTS ANSWERABLE
TO THE PEOPLE THEY SERVE
OBVIOUSLY OUR SOCIETY OUR
ECONOMY AND OUR STUDENTS
PRIMARILY.
IT COULD BE A BILL IT IF THAT'S
NOT FEASIBLE IT COULD BE BUDGET
ACTION VERY EASILY IF NOT IT
COULD BE ANY NUMBER OF WAYS BUT
I THINK THE TIMING IS RIGHT FROM
THE STAND POINT OF. MISTER STARR
AS PEOPLE ARE WORKING WELL
TOGETHER TO ENGAGE IN A ROBUST
CONVERSATION ALONG THOSE LINES
OF.
I AM HOW DO YOU CHANGE THE
PROCESS TOOK DIRECT CONNECTIONS
BETWEEN SEGMENTS FORCING THE
PLAYERS
THEMSELVES TO COOPERATE AND
COORDINATE.
AND OBVIOUSLY I BELIEVE THAT YOU
THAT IS.
YOUR BAILIWICK AND YOUR
STRENGTH.
I'M OBVIOUSLY IN EAGER FOR
QUESTIONS
THANKS SO MUCH.
WELL REALLY DO APPRECIATE
NEITHER VERY THOUGHTFUL AND
NUANCE A PRESENTATIONS IN AND
DOWN.
NO I I THINK AND I DO I DO
APPLAUD THE FOLKS WHO
COMMONSENSE FOR HELPING TO SPARK
THIS DISCUSSION.
I. I SUPPOSE I'VE A COUPLE
DIFFERENT THINGS.
.
IT SEEMS SO SERVE YOU BOTH
PRESENTED TO ADD TWO DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES I WANT HIM PARTS
APART YEARS A LITTLE BIT. AND
MISTER PAYNE GIVEN SOME OF THE
COMMENTS ARE MADE BY MISTER
HART.
I YOU WERE INNOCENT HEART WAS
TALKING A BIT ABOUT.
BUT AND THIS IS A GROTESQUE
PARAPHRASE PERHAPS BUT HE'S
BASICALLY SAYING.
THE POWERS ARE IN THE HANDS OF
THE GOVERNOR FOR THE MOST PART
LET'S BE HONEST ABOUT AND
COHERENT ABOUT IT. NOW I THINK
IS THATTHE CONCEPT BEHIND THE
COMMONSENSE PROPOSAL.
ALLEN.
WHAT'S YOUR IMMEDIATE REACTION
TO THAT STATEMENT.
.
I CAN I CAN JUST READ THE
STATEMENTS ARE BOTH THROUGH THE
BOTH THROUGH THE INTERACTION OF
THE GOVERNOR HAS WITH YOU IN THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE INTERACTION
AND POWER THAT HE IS INVESTED IN
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCES
SPECIALLY.
THAT.
ULTIMATE POWER RESTS WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND THAT.
IT AND.
.
CAN HAS BEEN THAT WAY FOR SOME
FOR SOME MATTER OF TIME. I WILL
SAY HOWEVER THAT THE
INTERACTION.
BOTH FISCALLY AND PROGRAMMATIC
LAY BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND DISTRICTS AND
COUNTIES. IS A VERY COMPLICATED
AND NUANCED INTERACTIONS WELL
HAVING TO DO WITH ISSUES OF OF.
OF COULD SERVE CURRICULUM HAVE
YOU DO ISSUES OF APPORTIONMENT
HAVE YOU DO WITH ISSUES OF ANY
NUMBER OF THINGS BOTH
INTERACTIONS WITH THEM IN WITH
INTERACTIONS WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. IT IS AS I SAID A
COMPLICATED ENTERPRISE AND ONE
PERSON IN CHARGE IT WITH THIS
WITH A KIND OF.
SINGLE MINDED FOCUS ON EDUCATION
AS THE AND THE OUTCOMES FOR THE
STUDENTS AS A FOCUS IS IS
APPROPRIATE. I THINK IN THE IN
THE CONSTRUCT A CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY AS BIG AS IT IS
ESPECIALLY WITH THIS MANY
DISTRICTS A THOUSAND DISTRICTS
AND TEN THOUSAND SCHOOLS AND.
ANY NUMBER CHARTERS I'VE LOST
COUNT ABOUT THE NUMBER.
DID YOU FIND WHEN YOU WERE AT
THE THE PARA DUCATION CERTAIN OF
SUPERINTENDENT.
THAT IT WOULD.
DID THE.
CONFUSED LINES OF AUTHORITY.
WERE BECOMING REALLY
DETRIMENTAL TO YOUR ABILITY TO
YEAR WORKING IN DID YOU FEEL
KIND OF. A NEED FOR A MORE CLEAR
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE.
.
IT'S A GOOD QUESTION AND I THINK
ITS A MATTER AND I THINK I I
WOULD THEN I WOULD JUST GO BACK
TO REFERENCE MY EARLIER POINTS
ABOUT THAT WHEN THE
RELATIONSHIPS WERE GOOD AND WHEN
WE WERE COMMUNICATING WELL AND.
HAVING.
DON'T DON'T ME WRONG WE HAD VERY
ROBUST CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICES IN OURSELVES
IN THE SECTOR'S OUTSIZE
OURSELVES. NAM WE HAD VERY
ROBUST CONVERSATIONS WITH IT
WITH THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION BUT WE WERE.
ACTING.
US GONNA BLAME TRANSPARENTLY
WITH EACH OTHER. COM THAT.
WASN'T THAT THERE WAS MUCH LESS
CAN HOOK CONFUSION ABOUT WHAT
WAS COMING OUT OF THAT AND WE
WERE VERY CLEAR ABOUT THE JOB
THAT HAD TO BE DONE. OFF FROM
THAT WHEN THINGS GOT CONFUSING
AND WHEN THAT THINGS GOT
ADVERSARIAL IT BECAME.
IT THAT THAT SORT OF IT IT.
CASCADED INTO THE DISTRICTS IN A
CASCADED INTO THE COUNTIES
MOTHER CONFUSION THAT RESULTED
UP HERE AND THIS HAPPENED TOO
MANY TIMES IN RECENT HISTORY
HASN'T I'M NOT NOT VERY RECENT
HISTORY BUT. NO IT HAS IT HAS
HAPPENED OF A LOT OF TIMES IN.
YEAH.
I'M.
IT'S CERTAIN IT IS THEN.
THAT IS UNFORTUNATE NATURE OF
POLITICS AND ESPECIALLY THE
POLITICS IS POLITICS AND
GOVERNMENT SAYS THAT WE DO IN
THE UNITED STATES THAT THERE IS
DISTRIBUTED LEADERSHIP AND
THERE.
AND THESE CONFLICTS CAN ARISE
THAT IT'S VERY HARD TO LEGISLATE
BEHAVIOR IT'S VERY HARD TO.
LEGISLATE CONTROL.
.
THERE ARE WAYS THAT YOU CAN.
AND OBVIOUSLY I WILL LEAVE IT TO
YOU BECAUSE I HAD THE ANSWERS
THAT WOULD OF ALREADY.
JOHN TRIED TO IMPLEMENT THEM AND
THERE ARE WAYS THAT YOU CAN
REQUIRE THEIR TO BE SUFFICIENT
REPORTING THAT THE SEGMENTS FOR
INSTANCE ARE THEMSELVES
COMMUNICATING WELL ENOUGH.
SO SO WHAT YOU'RE ESSENTIAL
CRITICISM OF THE OF THE PROPOSAL
BY THE.
YOU KNOW YOU MEAN TO ALTER THE
THE WAY THEY DESCRIBE IT THE
IDEA IS YOU'RE GONNA. ADDRESS
THE COHERENCE ISSUE BY
ESSENTIALLY MOVING THE CD UNDER
THE GOVERNOR. AND THEN GIVE THE
SUPERINTENDENT.
BOB.
RULES TO DOUBLE DOWN ON THE
ADVOCACY ASPECT OF THE POSITION
THE BULLY PULPIT.
BUT BUT TAKE AWAY THE THE SORT
OF INFRASTRUCTURAL A
JURISDICTIONAL TENSIONS THAT
COULD EXIST THICKET OUT TO
UNDERMINE THE BROADER
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM OF IS A FIGHT
GOING ON THAT INCIDENT IN THE
GOVERNOR.
I I'LL BE FRANK THAT. WITHOUT SU
LEADERS HUMBLY PUPPET ARE
WANTING THEIR VERY STRONG
THEY'RE VERY IMPORTANT.
THEY'VE A VOTE ON THE REGION'S
IS A VOTE ON REGION SAY VOTE A
VOTE ON THE TRUST.
THE SAME IT WOULD BE
I'M WITH
A COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHERE YOU
HAVE A VOTE ON BOTH BUT THAT'S
NOT GOING TO CAUSE CANCER.
THAT'S WHY I LIKE HALF THE
PROPOSAL. THE.
THE.
THE NOTION THAT THERE IS LINE
AUTHORITY AND THERE IS THERE IS
THE ABILITY TO SANCTION EITHER
IN THE APARTMENT PROCESS OR IN
SOME OTHER PROCESS THE. THAT
WHATEVER YOU'RE KIND OF REALLY
PROCESS THERE THERE IS A LINE
AUTHORITY I'M.
MEANS THERE IS LEVERAGE MEANS
AREAS.
TRUE AUTHORITY IN THE IN THE
POSITION AND THAT IS I THINK
ESSENTIAL AND IMPORTANT.
DICK ANSWERS.
YEAH.
NOT AGAINST NOT AGAINST
OBVIOUSLY USE HERE CSU BUT IT
BUT IN THE RELATIONSHIP OF
DISTRICTS AS WELL AS ESPECIALLY.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR WHAT FOR
THERE TO BE LINE AUTHORITY FOR
THERE TO BE.
.
AN ARBITER OF DISPUTE AND
SOMEONE WHO HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR OVERSEEING
THAT WORK.
BUT DOES NOT EXIST UNDER BOTH
THE CURRENT MODEL AND UNDER THIS
PROPOSED MODEL.
AND I'VE ACTUALLY I'M ACTUALLY
HAVING IT RESIDE WITH THE FBI AS
OPPOSED THE GOVERNOR.
THE LINE AUTHORITY THAT THE THE
OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY WOULD REST
OF THE GOVERNMENT'S.
SO.
SO THERE IS A LINE AUTHORITY I
AGREE THAT IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THE TO BE LIVES ALREADY AB BUT
BUT BUT BUT THAT. THAT DOESN'T
GO AWAY DISK MOVES A DIFFERENT.
PERSON
TRUE BUT IT MOVED BUT IT WAS
ANOTHER PERSON BUT IT ALSO
BELIEVE LEAVES THE PERSON WHO
WAS ELECTED BY THE PUBLIC. TO BE
THE.
PERSON IN CHARGE OF THE SCHOOLS.
YEAH.
WRITE TO YOUR ELECTED GOVERNOR
FOR ANY HOUSE FOR A HOST OF
REASONS INFRASTRUCTURE ROADS BUT
ASSEMBLY SO WE ALSO LIKE THE
GOVERNOR TO BE TOWARDS OF THE
ENTIRE STRUCTURE INDEED SENT
THAT PASSED THE BUDGETS IN
EDUCATION.
I I I THINK IF YOU WERE TO ASK.
A LOT OF VOTERS THEY WOULD THINK
THAT EDUCATION BEEN IMPORTANT
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PORTFOLIO.
ABSOLUTELY.
YEAH ALSO BUT ALSO SAY LIKE WITH
LIKE WITH JUST OF LIKE WITH
TREASURY SO ONE PERSON IS FALSE
ALL FOCUSES THOSE ISSUES IS THAT
ESSENTIAL IMPORTANT AND. THE
VOTERS HAVE SPOKEN THAT'S A
THAT'S.
SOMETHING THEY WANT.
TURNED ON.
QUESTION THOUGHTS BOMB NOTICED
LISTENING OKAY. I'D LOVE TO
ADJUSTING AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS AS YOU DO BRING A
WEALTH OF EXPERIENCE TO THIS
TABLE. SO MUCH APPRECIATE YOU
SHARING YOUR.
A DIFFERENT PERCEPTIONS THAT
SOMETIMES THEY OVERLAPS.
CAN I ASK YOU CENTER HARD YOU
BROUGHT UP THIS WHOLE I'M. GONNA
CUT TO FIND THE CALVET
EDUCATIONAL ROUNDTABLE.
AND WHAT IS EXISTED IN THE PAST
THAT. YOU KNOW ALONG HIS I KNOW
WE HAD WE HAD SEPAK FOR EXAMPLE.
WHICH DID WORK ON SHARING DATA
AT THE HIGHER ED LEVEL THAT
CERTAIN SOMETHING THAT A BUNCH
OF US LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW.
.
BUT IS THIS IS WITH A SOMETHING
YOU LOOKED OUT WHEN YOU WERE IN
THE SENATE OR IN AND SECRETARY
POSITION. OUT BY DID EXIST IN
FORMAL BASIS I MEAN I I.
THIS GOVERNOR'S.
YOU KNOW.
THEN.
TYPICALLY NOT VERY INTERESTED IN
CREATING NEW GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURES.
I MEAN
THAT REQUIRED FUNDING.
BUT YOU KNOW.
BUT AN INTERESTING IDEA I LOVE
TO FLY CELIBATE.
IF THIS IS JUST KIND OF EVOLVED
I THINK IT'S KIND OF AN INFORMAL
THERE'S NOT BEEN ANY DIRECTIVE
FROM THE LEGISLATURE THE
GOVERNOR ANYONE ELSE THAT I KNOW
OF A. PARTICULARLY WITH THE
DEMISE OF SEPAK
AND THE HIGHER EDUCATION
COORDINATING.
COUNCIL HAVING SOME MECHANISM BY
WHICH.
OF PEOPLE IN THE HIGHER
EDUCATION LEADERSHIP CAN
COMMUNICATE WITH ONE ANOTHER
THIS WAS SORT OF ESTABLISHED AND
I THINK APPROPRIATELY AS THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC IS.
PART OF THE
CONVERSATIONS BECAUSE K. TWELVE
OBVIOUSLY.
HAS AN IMPORTANT ROLE TO US YOU
KNOW TO PLAY.
UP IN TERMS OF.
.
YOU KNOW THIS GOVERNOR I THINK
ANYTHING THAT WOULD BE DONE
STATUTORILY TO TRY TO CREATE
SUCH A. POEM YOU NOBODY PROBABLY
WOULD NOT BE MET YOU KNOW VERY
FAVORABLY BUT.
YOU KNOW PERHAPS NEXT YEAR
THERE COULD BE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH. I DO THINK THAT YOU
COULD YOU COULD FUND THIS EASILY
BY ASKING EACH OF THE SEGMENTS
THEY WOULD PROBLY WOULDN'T
WOULDN'T LIKE THIS TO SAY THAT
TO NO ONE TENTH OF ONE PERCENT
OF YOUR. OPERATING
ADMINISTRATIVE BUDGET UP OUGHT
TO GO TO FUND ACTIVITIES HAVING
TO DO WITH THE THIS A
COORDINATION ARTICULATION
FUNCTION I THINK THERE'S AN EASY
WAY TO TO DO IT DOESN'T REQUIRE
YOU KNOW HOW UP ELABORATE. YOU
KNOW YOU FUNDING MECHANISMS.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
BUT I'M I'M I'M SURE THAT'S
RIGHT.
WHERE SOME SO YOU MENTIONED
SENATE COMMISSION WE TALKED WITH
THE BOARD GOVERNOR'S WHAT ARE
SOME OF THEIR POSITIONS WHERE
SOME OF THE BOARDS OR
COMMISSIONS AT THE CSU BY TO
HAVE? BY THE WAY THERE'S OTHER
WAYS WE CAN THINK ABOUT THIS WE
DON'T JUST WE COULD GIVE
APPOINTMENT POWER TO THE SOUP.
AS WELL YOU KNOW THEY WOULD HAVE
A SEAT ON THE BOARD OF REGENTS
MAYBE GET.
ONE ADDITIONAL PAYMENT.
HOW TO I DON'T MORE I MEAN
THERE'S DIFFERENT WAYS WE CAN
THINK ABOUT THIS?
?
TOBY INTERESTING ABBA YOU
MENTIONED TO NAY COMMISSION
BOARD OF GOVERNORS OTHER OTHER
OTHERS OUT THERE THAT THAT THAT
ARE VERY AND IMPACTFUL
EDUCATIONALLY COMMISSIONS ARE
BOARDS THAT.
WE OUGHT TO BE THINKING ABOUT IN
THE CONTEXT OF.
THE POTENTIAL SUPERINTENDENT
ROLE.
THEY DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE.
AND THE CDC CERTAINLY ASIDE TO
SYRIA.
QUESTION TO DETENTION.
ACTUALLY IN THOSE COULDN'T
MISSION TEACHER CREDENTIALING
THERE IS.
A DESIGNEES FROM THE
SUPERINTENDENT'S OFFICE THAT
SERVES AND THEY HAVE VOTING
AUTHORITY ALTHOUGH THEY'RE NOT A
FORMAL MEMBER. OF THE YOU KNOW
THE COMMISSION BUT. IN ESSENCE
THEY HAVE HUB. VOTING AUTHORITY
WHICH GIVES THEM
POWER THEY COULD BE MADE OF YOU
KNOW A FORMAL UP YOU KNOW FORMAL
MEMBER AND I I THINK THAT WOULD
BE QUITE APPROPRIATE. ACROSS AND
SO THEY DON'T TAKE CARE OF.
I THINK THIS ISSUE OF TRYING TO
HAVE SOME KIND OF UGH UGH
GOVERNANCE COUNCIL OF ALL THE
HEADS IS IS REALLY KEY.
I'M SURE THERE ARE SOME OTHER
COMMISSIONS THAT. ONE COULD.
FERRET OUT THAT YOU COULD*
WHO PRETENDED TO SERVE ON BUT I
DON'T THINK THAT'S.
.
YOU KNOW THAT'S.
THAT'S GOOD BUT THAT'S IS
CRITICAL IS HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION WORKING
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN. THE OF THE
POWERS THAT BE BETWEEN HIGHER
EDUCATION AND YOU KNOW IT TO
TWELVE AND AS I MENTIONED BEFORE
I THINK FOOD BE APPROPRIATE TO
HAVE PERHAPS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION.
SERVE ON THIS AS WELL TO ENSURE
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S.
YOU KNOW HAS A YOU KNOW.
SOMEONE AT THE TABLE OF FROM THE
K. TWELVE COMMUNITY.
KATE KATE PARTS APART YOU'RE
PREPARED SUGGESTION THAT YOUR
OPINION IS THAT WE OUGHT TO JUST
GET RID OF THAT. BUT POLCY
PRETENDS POSITIONAL TOGETHER. IT
IS THAT IT DO YOU DO I MAKE
THAT.
RECOMMENDATION BECAUSE OR DO
YOU HAVE THAT FEELING BECAUSE.
ULTIMATELY YOU THINK THAT IT.
THAT THE CURRENT STRUCTURE IS IS
DECEPTIVE TO THE VOTERS THAT DID
THE POWERS AND THE GOVERNOR WE
CREATE THIS POSITION THAT.
IT IS VOTERS THE SENSE THAT
THEY'RE VOTING FOR SOMEONE WHO'S
RUNNING THE SCHOOLS AND THAT'S
ULTIMATELY AND.
DECEPTIVE IN AND WE ARE JUST.
DO AWAY WITH IT FOR THAT REASON.
DECEPTIVE MAYBE A LITTLE BIT OF
THE TWO STRONG WORD I DON'T
THINK THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT
REASON I THINK THAT'S A
CONTRIBUTING REASONS TO IT BUT I
THINK MOST IMPORTANTLY IS TO
HAVE TO CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS.
IN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT TO HAVE MAJOR
RESPONSIBILITY FOR.
FUNDING AND POLICY IS.
YOU KNOW DOWN THE ROAD LEADS TO
THESE PROBLEMS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE NOW BUT W'VE HAD A IN IN
THE PAST AND. AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER I JUST THINK THE
GOVERNOR IS THE KEY PLAYER THE
GOVERNOR NEEDS TO ASSUME.
RESPONSIBILITY AND HOLD HER HAVE
SOME SYSTEM OF ACCOUNTABILITY IN
IT ON A REST WITH HIM AND.
SITUATION IS I THINK YOU BEGIN
REMARKS BY SAYING.
NEW THE ACCOUNTABILITY IS YOU
KNOW IN EVERY ONCE IN CHARGE BUT
NO ONE'S ACCOUNTABLE.
I THINK THAT FUNDAMENTAL.
STATEMENT TICKETS IT THE REASON%
FOR WHY THE OFFICE OF AND IN MY
VIEW YOU KNOW IS YOU KNOW WAS
QUESTIONABLE NOW.
WE TRIED THREE DIFFERENT TIMES
TO ELIMINATE THE OFFICE AND
VOTERS SAYS RIGHT.
KEVIN MADE REFERENCE TO.
ARE ARE JEALOUS AND.
OF THEIR OF ABILITY TO YOU KNOW
LIKE PEOPLE TO OFFICE SO
THE CHANCES OF ELIMINATING THE
OFFICE OF THEM ARE NOT. VERY
PUBLIC VERY GOOD ALTHOUGH IT HAS
BEEN TRIED AND IN FIFTY YEARS SO
MAYBE. TO BE TRIED AGAIN BUT I
WOULD NOT BE UP TO MISSING RIGHT
THAT.
.
IT'S RUNNING GOOD VOTERS DON'T
LIKE NEW. POLITICAL POSITIONS
BUT I DON'T LIKE TAKING AWAY ALL
ONCE IT'S THAT'S RIGHT YOU KNOW
BECAUSE. IT'S VERY INTERESTING
WELD SOME YEARS IT WAS OVER
TWENTY YEARS AGO THEY ACTUALLY
ELECTED THEY ACTUALLY VOTED TO
HAVE A NEW. POSITION IN THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER YEAH.
YEAH THAT'S RIGHT BUT I JUST
MAKE ONE OTHER COMMENT ABOUT
THIS.
PET INOTES A SENSITIVE POINT
BUT ANOTHER REASON FOR
ELIMINATING THE OFFICE IN MY
VIEW IS THE NATURE OF HOW WE
CAMPAIGN FOR OFFICES CHANGE THIS
USED TO BE. A SLEEPY OFFICE IT
WAS DOMINATED BY PEOPLE WHO WERE
EDUCATIONAL PROFESSIONALS.
BUT IN THE LAST THIRTY YEARS.
BECAUSE OF EDUCATION'S GROWING
PROMINENCE.
IN THE PUBLIC DEBATE.
AND BECAUSE OF THE COST OF
TELEVISION ADS AND RUNNING FOR
THIS OFFICE
THE OFFICES BECOME ONE THAT ONE
ONLY RUN THIS IF YOU'RE. ABLE TO
RAISE FIVE TO TWENTY OR THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS. AND THAT MEANS
THAT UNLESS YOU ARE A PRACTICING
POLITICIAN OR INDEPENDENTLY
WEALTHY OR. APPOSITE SPECIAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH PEOPLE WHO
CONTRIBUTE LARGE SUMS TO THESE
ARE.
IN PAINS YOUR OF YOUR CAR NOT
ELIGIBLE TO RUN FOR THE OFFICE
OF WORRY UNITE ELIGIBLE.
BECAUSE HER.
OF HOW MUCH MONEY YOU KNOW
DICTATES THE PROCESS SO.
I'M A BIG FAN OF PUBLIC FINANCE
REFORM IN UNTIL WE GET THAT KIND
OF REFORM I THINK. OFFICES LIKE
THIS.
.
ARE YOU KNOW.
SOMEWHAT EARNED.
YOU DON'T CHALLENGED IN TERMS OF
HAVING THE KIND OF PEOPLE THAT
YOU WOULD AT LEAST LIKE TO
CONSIDER RUNNING FOR THIS
OFFICE.
BECAUSE THREE PER PREREQUISITE
IS ONE THAT OF THE YOU KNOW THEY
CAN MEET.
I AM AND WHAT I DO WANT TO GET
INTO A DEBATE HERE BUT. THEY
HAVE AND SAID YOU WANT SOMEONE
WHO HAS A SINGLE MINDED FOCUS.
ON DOING THIS JOB. AND I THINK
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT AND I
THINK RUNNING FOR THE OFFICE IN
TERMS OF THE FUNDRAISING ASPECTS
OF IT. REALLY GET IN THE WAY OF
HEAVY THAT SINGLE MINDED FOCUS
AND HAVING SOMEONE WHO WAS
APPOINTED.
BY SOMEONE WHO HAS TO RESOLVE
THE MONEY THE GOVERNOR WHO IS
REALLY FOR ABLE TO FOCUS ON THAT
AND NOT WORRY. ABOUT THE NEXT
ELECTION AND ABOUT ALL THE
PUBLICITY THAT YOU NEED TO GET.
TO.
THE FREE PUBLICITY IN ADDITION
TO THE PAY PUBLICITY IT REALLY I
THINK GETS IN THE WAY OF HAVING
THAT SINGLE MINDED FOCUS THAT I
THINK THE.
OF THE PERSON IN CHARGE
EDUCATION THE CITY CALIFORNIA
OUGHT TO HAVE REDUCE DOES THE
CONTENTS FOR BOTH OF AND GOT
RATHER ELEGANTLY ADDRESS THE TWO
THINGS YOU JUST RAISE ONE THE
ONE HAND AND.
DEALING WITH THE FACT THAT IT IS
UNLIKELY THAT THE VOTERS WOULD
WANT TO GET RID OF A ELECTED
POSITION.
.
YOU KNOW SO KEEP THE POSITION
GIVE IT MORE OF AN ADVOCACY ROLE
IN TERMS OF MEMBERS OF CITIES
VERY SPORTS A COMMISSION SIMILAR
POWERS. BUT ULTIMATELY.
PUT AN APPOINTED.
PERSON I HAD IN CHARGE OF THE CD
WHO IS SINGULARLY FOCUSED AND
NOT AS POLITICALLY ORIENTED.
I MAYBE HE'S TRYING TO DO MAKE
THE BEST OF THE OF THE POLITICAL
REALITIES IN THE STRUCTURES BUT
ALSO THE. SORT OF IMPERATIVES
YOU'RE DESCRIBING.
I IN THE WAY THAT HE'S CRAFTED
THIS PROPOSAL.
I I THINK THAT THAT MAY BE A
STEP IN THE RIGHT.
YOU KNOW DIRECTION I MEAN ALL
OF THESE MOST RECENT STUDIES
HAVE NOT GONE THE ROUTE OF
TRYING TO ELIMINATE THE OFFICE
BECAUSE I THINK THEY FEEL THAT
IT CAN'T BE ELIMINATED SO TO TRY
TO RESTRUCTURE THE OFFICE AND
CAREFULLY DEFINED.
WHAT WHAT IT IS AND A TWO MINUTE
LONG THAT IT'S?
ROLE ARM OR EXPAND ITS ROLE IN
ADVOCACY AS MISTER STARR WOULD
WOULD YOU KNOW PUT FORWARD.
.
MAYBE THAT WILL WORK I WORRY A
LITTLE BIT THAT AS LONG AS YOU
HAVE SOMEONE WHO'S INDEPENDENTLY
ELECTED. A TRYING TO.
MANAGING CONFINED THERE OF
AUTHORITY IS ALWAYS GOING TO BE
SOMEWHAT OF AN ISSUE BECAUSE OF
THEIR YOU KNOW INDEPENDENCE HAS
BEEN SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN ELECTED
BY THE BY THE PEOPLE THAT.
COULD IT A LITTLE MORE OF BOLDLY
CAN YOU BE A LITTLE BIT
PREGNANT.
IS.
NO ONE WHERE I THINK OF.
BUT YOU HAVE TO SORT OF WORRY A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT YOU TRY TO
RESTRUCTURE THE OFFICE. I AM I
IF AYE MAMMOTH AYE RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE THE AND LAST THREE
SUPERINTENDENTS HAVE BEEN
TEACHER.
AND HAVE COME UP THROUGH THAT
SYSTEM AND THAT WERE INVOLVED
WHEN THEY WERE LEGISLATORS IN
THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE PROCESS
AND SO.
AND WE'RE WELL STEEP A
SUFFICIENTLY FOCUSED.
I'M I MYSELF AM ALSO AN
ADVOCATE OF PUBLIC FINANCING NAM
A OF CAMPAIGNS AND THINK THAT
WOULD BE AN INTERESTING. NAM A
FIGURE APPROACH WAS NOT TO FOR
DEBATE TODAY.
WELL I I AM I REALLY. APPRECIATE
YOUR INPUT IN AND DOWN AYE I
THINK WILL I'M PECAN ON YOU. IN
THE FUTURE AND AND VARIOUS
VARIOUS THINGS IT'S CERTAINLY IF
THAT THERE'S MOVEMENT ON THIS
ISSUE.
TO HELP US CONCEPTUALIZING THINK
ABOUT THE WAY WE OUGHTA.
HOBBY RESTRUCTURING.
THE GOVERNMENT SYSTEM FOR THE
STATE MOVING FORWARD SO. I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE IT AND
TEMPERATURE YOUR YOUR.
INCREDIBLE CONTINUED CONTINUED
SERVICE OF THE STATE.
AND WITH THAT I LOVE TO NOW CALL
UP OUR NEXT PANEL.
WHICH WILL PROVIDE US WITH A
NUMBER OF PERSPECTIVES FROM ALL
ACROSS THE.
EDUCATIONAL POLITICAL SPECTRUM
RISE.
WE'VE GOT FOLKS FROM THE T.
DISSOCIATION FROM.
ACCESS THEIR ADMINISTRATORS
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION
CHILDREN OUT PUBLIC ADVOCATES
FIRST HOW CALIFORNIA THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS IT'S QUITE A.
QUITE A.
A GOOD NEXT SO I'M.
SO WHEN WHEN WE HAVE EVERYBODY
HERE I KNOW THAT.
.
CARLOS ASKED TO LEAVE BY LEN
FORTY FIVE SO.
DID YOU WANT TO PRESENT FIRST.
PRESENT OKAY.
AND WE'RE ASKING EVERYONE JUST
IN THE JUST A TIME TO KEEP YOUR
PRESENTATIONS BRIEF BUT I KNOW
WE'VE GOT SOME REALLY SMART
SHARP FOLKS ARE ON THE TABLE AND
WE'RE VERY DISTANT.
YOUR PERSPECTIVES.
ARMS WILL START WITH YOU BECAUSE
MARKETS GOVERNMENT TERMS COSTS
ASSOCIATION AND THEN. I WOULD
THEN TURN TO TONY.
PATTY GHETTO FROM.
CTA.
GREAT APPLE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AT.
FOR TAKING THE TIME THAT TO
DISCUSS THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
I'M THE SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR THAT
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION.
AND I JUST WANNA THANK AYE CHAIR
ALLEN AND O'DONNELL IN
PARTICULAR. FOR ADD YOU KNOW
TAKING THE TIME AND CARE TO
REVISIT FOR STUDY DATA
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE UNDER WHICH
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM. IS ORGANIZED AND
ADMINISTERED AB CDSA AS YOU MAY
KNOW WORKS REGULARLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. AND THE STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION TO ENSURE THAT THE
DUE PROCESS RIGHTS
TO WHICH CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
GRANTED UNDER THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ACT. ARE EXHAUSTED AT
THE STATE LEVEL ON APPEAL WHEN.
THOSE SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN DENIED
BY THEIR DISTRICTS AND COUNTY
BOARDS OF EDUCATION.
AND WHY WE ARE PREPARED TO
OFFER AN OPINION AT THIS TIME
ABOUT THE VARIOUS RESTRUCTURE
PROPOSALS BEFORE YOU. IT'S
IMPORTANT FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
THAT THE STATE BOARDS CHARTERING
AUTHORITY IN ITS CAPACITY TO
AUTHORIZED CHARTER SCHOOLS. IS
HIGHLIGHTED IN THE CONTEXT OF
THIS BROADER DEBATE.
I IN ADDITION TO ITS POLICY
MAKING POWERS THE STATE BOARD IS
ALSO RESPONSIBLE. OUT FOR THE
COURT ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTION OF
HEARING AND APPROVING OR DENYING
CHARTER SCHOOL APPEALS.
THE STATE BOARD AS IT CURRENTLY
IS RESOURCE AND STRUCTURED BY
THE ADMISSION OF SEVERAL SITTING
STATE BOARD MEMBERS. IS STRAINED
TO EXECUTE BOTH ITS POLICY
MAKING AND IT'S ADMINISTRATIVE
CHARTERING.
AND TO BE CLEAR THIS STATE BOARD
AND THIS CD <c.green> HAVE
WORKED</c>
WELL TOGETHER. UNDER THE BROWN
AND TORE LOOKS IN
ADMINISTRATIONS.
AND HAVE ESTABLISH HEALTHY AND
QUALITY AUTHORIZING AN OVERSIGHT
PRACTICES. AS WELL AS MODELED
QUALITY AND DISPASSIONATE
PETITION REVIEW STANDARDS FOR
ALL OFF THE RISERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT NOT UNLIKE DISTRICT AND
COUNTY AUTHORIZE YEARS WHO ARE
EQUALLY STRAINED BY THE
COMPETING DUTIES OF BOTH POLICY
MAKING. AND CHARTERING THE CARE
AND ATTENTION THAT THE LATTER
RECEIVES OFTEN HINGES ARM ON BE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE BOARD
EMPOWER AT THE GIVEN TIME.
SO IN THE CONTEXT OF THIS
BROADER DISCUSSION AND WE WOULD
INVITE YOU TO REIMAGINE HOW
CHARTER SCHOOLS ACCESS THEIR
APPEAL RIGHTS AND ARE AUTHORIZED
AT THE STATE LEVEL.
KEEPING THE STATE'S BOARDS FOCUS
ON POLICY MAKING FOR THE ENTIRE
CAVE TWO THROUGH TWELVE PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM WHILE MIGRATING
MUCH OF THE BOARD'S CURRENT
ADMINISTRATIVE CHARTERING DUTIES
TO AN ALTERNATIVE. AND MORE
DISCREET.
ENTITY LIKE THE ADVISORY
COMMISSION ON CHARTER SCHOOLS
WOULD FREE UP THE BOARDS
RESOURCES AND ATTENTION TO
ENTIRELY FOCUS ON POLICY MAKING.
WHILE I ALLOWING ENTITIES LIKE
THE A CCS WHICH STILL FALL
WITHIN THE CONSTITUTIONALITY OF
HOW CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM. IS ORGANIZED
WILL ENSURE THAT ONE ENTITY HAS
THE CAPACITY TO FULLY FOCUS ON
QUALITY AUTHORIZING.
THIS CHANGE MAY BE POSSIBLE BY
AN ACT OF THE LEGISLATURE OR ON
A MORE LIMITED BASIS IF THE
STATE BOARD WERE TO GRANT THE
ACCS GREATER AUTHORITY OVER
CHARTERING. WHILE MAINTAINING
AUTHORITY TO INTERVENE IN ACCS
IS FINAL DETERMINATIONS IN
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES.
SO AS YOU DISCUSSED THE WISDOM
OF RETAINING THE CURRENT
SEPARATION OF POWERS AND THE K.
THROUGH TWELVE GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE OR. REALIGNING UNDER A
DIFFERENT MODEL WE DO ASK THAT
YOU CONSIDER THE CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THOSE
PROPOSALS MAY PRESENT ARE
RELATED TO THE MANNER IN WHICH
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE AUTHORIZED
AT THE STATE LEVEL.
YOU DID YOU HAVE A PARTICULAR
THERE'S A.
YOU WOULD WANT TO HAVE THEIR TO
BE SEPARATE. AUTHORIZING BOARD
IS THAT.
SO I WE MUST HAVE THEIR SYSTEM
ARCHITECTURE CURRENTLY IN PLACE
THAT WE THINK.
EITHER THROUGH THAT BY
AUTHORITY THAT WOULD BE.
GRANTED BY THE STATE BOARD TO
THE A CCS PCCS COULD POTENTIALLY
TAKE A GREATER ROLE OVER.
THE AUTHORIZING DUTIES OF THE
STATE BOARD ABOVE AND BEYOND
JUST BEING. AN ADVISER TO.
TO THE STATE BOARD OR AN ACT OF
THE LEGISLATURE COULD MIGRATE
DOES AUTHORIZING DUTIES ENTIRELY
TO THE ACC ES.
OKAY CZS IT REVIEWS WITHIN ITS
THE ADVISORY COMMISSION ON
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND AT THIS TIME
THEY.
THEY MEET BEFORE.
EACH STATE BOARD MEETING
QUARTERLY AND MAKE A
DETERMINATION ABOUT WHETHER.
CHARTER SCHOOL SHOULD BE
APPROVED OR DENIED.
AND THEY.
THEY ARE.
PROVIDED AT SOME ADDITIONAL
PATENT EVIDENCE AND AND ABOUT
PETITION REVIEW SUPPORT FROM
CITY STAFF.
CURRENT THANK YOU THANKS VERY
MUCH I'VE IF YOU COULD SHARE
YOUR TESTIMONY WITH THE. WITH US
I WOULD APPRECIATE THAT.
I'M OKAY GREAT MOVE WILL NEXT
YEAR FROM TONY TO GET.
FROM.
THIS COMFORTED ASSOCIATION.
MISTER CHAIR STAFF.
TONY TRIGGER ON BEHALF THAT
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY THIRTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY AS A
HISTORY MAJOR I'VE ENJOYED THE
US CENTRAL DOWN MEMORY LANE.
REFLECTED IN THE STUDIES I
DON'T NECESSARILY AGREE WITH ALL
THE CHARACTERIZATION.
STUDIES BUT.
.
HERE WE ARE.
WE SUPPORT THE INDEPENDENCE OF
THE NONPARTISAN ELECTED
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION CARRYING OUT THE
DAY TO DAY OPERATIONS OF THE
DEPARTMENT WE BELIEVE THE
SEPARATION OF POWERS. SERVICES
IT CHECKS AND BALANCES BETWEEN
THE BERRIES AND.
WE HAVE FAITH AND CONFIDENCE IN
THE OVERSIGHT AND THE BUDGETARY
INFLUENCE THE LEGISLATURE
PERFORMS IN THE CURRENT
CONFIGURATION.
CTA THAT'S REFLECTED IN OUR
INTERNAL ORGANIZATIONAL POLICY
WRITTEN IN ADOPTED BY OUR
ELECTED MEMBERS.
AT THE STATE COUNCIL EDUCATION.
CTA WE HAVE POLICY CTA PER THEIR
BELIEVES THAT THE SECRETARY OF
EDUCATION POSITION.
AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE SHOULD
BE ELIMINATED AND ALL OF THE
FUNCTIONS OF THIS OFFICE BE
ASSUMED BY THE CALIFORNIA TO.
IN OF EDUCATION.
REGARDING TIMING WE THINK THIS
IS A VERY COMPLEX ISSUE.
.
WE APPRECIATE THE.
PRESENTATION WE. BELIEVE THAT
THERE SHOULD BE INPUT FROM ALL
STAKEHOLDERS.
AND IT CANNOT BE ACCOMPLISHED
IN THE SHORT TIME LEFT IN THIS
TWO ADMINISTRATIONS. WE DO
WELCOME BEING PART OF THE
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS GOING
FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PRESSURE.
ARE OKAY WILL NEXT HEAR FROM OUR
PRESTON FROM ACCESS FROM. OUR
CITIES GOVERNMENT SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS.
FOR INVITING US TO BE HERE OF I
HAVE TO RESPOND IN A GETS
BECAUSE A LOT OF US WHO HAVE
BEEN AROUND FOR AWHILE AND MAYBE
LONGER THAN WE WANT TO ADMIT. A.
IN TWO THOUSAND TWO WHEN THE
MASTER PLAN CAME OUT WE I WAS
ABLE TO TAKE THROUGH OUR
ARCHIVES AND FIND WHAT WE SAID
AT THE TIME. I MANY HASN'T
CHANGED AT ALL BECAUSE WE
ACTUALLY TOOK TIME WE CREATED A
COVER.
FORCE WITHIN ACSA
I'M TO LOOK AT ALL THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND.
EITHER ONE OF THE THINGS I'VE
SUGGESTED TO A COUPLE PEOPLE
RECENTLY IS THE LONGER YOU'RE ON
THIS PLANET YOU REALIZE THERE
ARE NOT A WHOLE LOT OF NEW IDEAS
THEY JUST SORT OF KEEP.
RESURFACING IN SOME SORT OF
ITERATION
AS WE THINK THIS IS.
IT FALLS INTO THAT CATEGORY.
I AM DO WE WHERE WE WERE AT THE
TIME AND WE STILL CONTINUE TO BE
IS WE BELIEVE THAT THERE SHOULD
BE ELECTED S. P. I THAT THAT IS.
A LEVEL OF ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THE PUBLIC. AND BUT LISTEN TO
THE TESTIMONY TODAY I WAS KIND
OF FUN.
WE'VE
LOOKING AND THINKING ABOUT OTHER
IDEAS AND ONE OF THE THOUGHTS I
HAD IS.
AND REALLY MOVING FORWARD IS
THE FACT THAT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
CONTINUITY I'M WHERE WE HAD THE
LEAST ABOUT CONTINUITY IS WHEN
WE THROUGH WENT DIFFERENT
CHANGES WHEN WE HAD THE
SECRETARY OF EDUCATION. AND
SENATOR HART WAS AN AMAZING
SECRETARY AT THE TIME BOTTOM
THAT'S WHERE MY MEMBERS BUT
THROUGH HAD A LOT OF CONFUSION
BECAUSE NOW YOU HAD THIS THIRD
PERSON THAT WAS KIND OF. IN AND
OUT OF CREATING POLICY I THINK
THAT THE THIS FIELD FEELS THE
WAY IT WORKS NOW IS FINE. AND I
THINK THAT.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY TO BE HONEST THE
CAPABILITIES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
I'M IT IS A LONG WAY FROM A
DISTRICT TO THE STATE TO WHETHER
IT'S THE STATE BOARD WEATHERS
THE LEGISLATURE. SO KEEPING THAT
IN IN MIND IS WHERE WE REALLY
POINT OF VALUE THE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THAT IS WITH
REACHING OUT TO. OUR LOCALS UP
AND I THINK HAVING A STATE
ELECTED S. P. AYE IS PROBABLY
SOMETHING THAT WE WORRY ABOUT IT
HERE A LOT MORE THAN I THINK THE
PEOPLE ON THE FIELD REALLY WORRY
ABOUT.
WITHOUT THINKING.
FROM WHICH ROOM.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
NEXT WE HEAR FROM TERRY BURNS
IN THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION.
AND IT LARA'S RIGHT SOME OF US
HAVE BEEN DOING THIS FOR QUITE
AWHILE AND HAVE BEEN THROUGH.
DAYS BACK WHEN THE HOENIG
DECISION JUST CAME OUT.
AND.
WE WERE ALL KIND OF IN A
DIFFERENT PLACE FIGURING OUT
WHAT THOSE RELATIONSHIPS WERE
AND HOW THINGS CHANGED NOW.
AND I THINK THAT HAS BEEN PRETTY
WELL ESTABLISHED OVERTIME.
WE'RE WE'RE IN A PLACE WHERE WE
GET HOW IT'S SUPPOSED TO WORK.
ON MISTER PAYNE WAS RIGHT YOU
CAN'T ARE.
LEGISLATE RELATIONSHIPS ON
HEALTH FOLKS GET ALONG AND WORK
TOGETHER.
BUT.
.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT.
EVEN IF WE HAVE. GOVERNOR NSP
AYE WHO ARE IN ALIGNMENT WILL
HAVE A LEGISLATURE WHO IS.
SIMILARLY ALIGNMENT WE WILL
ALWAYS HAVE THOSE CONFLICTS.
WE'RE JUST NOT FEELING THAT
NEEDS TO SEE A MASSIVE CHANGE
HERE RIGHT NOW WE'RE IN A TIME
OF SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN
EDUCATION WE'RE CHANGING THE
ASSESSMENTS.
WE ARE CHANGING THE
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM WE'RE
CHANGING THE FUNDING SYSTEM
WE'RE CHANGING THE TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS ALL OF THOSE THINGS
ARE HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
WORD PLACE WE THINK THIS IS KIND
OF A DISTRACTION FROM THAT. OUT
WITHOUT A LOT OF SIGNIFICANT
BENEFIT FOR IT.
.
WE ARE LOOKING AT LOCAL CONTROL
AND MR DONALD'S RIGHT PEOPLE
AREN'T GOING.
TO THE LEGISLATURE TO SAY MY KID
IS NOT LEARNING THEIR COMING TO
ME AT THE SCHOOL BOARD AND SAY
WHAT ARE YOU DOING.
AND.
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS.
.
IT IT.
THE AT.
THE IDEA OF A LONE VOICE.
CRYING OUT IN THE WILDERNESS
SEEMS TO BE THIS PROPOSAL.
.
WITH THIS S. B. I HE WAS ELECTED
WHO SITS AS ONE MEMBER OF MANY
OF THESE BODIES.
.
WHO?
IS ONE VOTE OF MANY.
WHO DOESN'T HAVE POWER TO STAND
BEHIND OUR BACK UP THOSE
POSITIONS? IS PROBLEMATIC TO US
WE THINK THAT AND SPI NEEDS TO
HAVE.
SOME.
SOME GREATER ROLE IN SOME
GREATER FUNCTION THAN SIMPLY.
A A BULLY PULPIT WHO NAM IS
JUST CRYING AND WENT.
OKAY I'M GONNA FOLLOW UP ON THAT
WE HAVE DISCUSSED AND I'M
THRILLED THE TREND FROM CHILDREN
NOW.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON THAT
SPECIFIC SCOPE OF THE ENTITIES.
AND HOW THEY WORK TOGETHER WE
THINK IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION. THAT SAID AND
ALONG THE LINES OF THE OF THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE BY
MEMBERS IN AND VARIOUS
PANELISTS.
CHILL NOW BELIEVES THE BEFORE WE
START TALKING ABOUT STRUCTURES
IT'S REALLY CRITICAL THAT WE
FIRST IDENTIFYING CLARIFY WHAT
THE STATE'S FUNDAMENTAL
COMMITMENT IS GOING TO BE.
TO KIDS AND FAMILIES AND THE
BROADER.
ADULTS WHO PARTICIPATE EACH OF
THE.
OF WHAT THE STATE'S ROLE IS IT
AND FUNDAMENTAL IN.
WHAT COMMITMENTS ARE WE GONNA
MAKE TO THOSE CHILDREN AND WHAT
IS THE STATE'S ROLE AS THE
GUARANTOR OF THOSE COMMITMENTS?
UP ONCE WE HAVE CLARITY ON THAT
FRONT AND THEN HOW THE DIFFERENT
STRUCTURES MIGHT BEST BE
ORGANIZED CAN FLOW FROM THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY WITHIN AND THAT'S
ESPECIALLY
PROBLEMATIC FROM EQUITY
PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE IT'S OUR
MOST VULNERABLE KIDS THAT SUFFER
WHEN ADULTS DON'T HAVE CLARITY
OR THE CAPACITY TO.
ACTUALLY DELIVER ON A HIGH
QUALITY PUBLIC EDUCATION.
A SO WHAT ARE THE CONDITIONS AS
THEY CURRENTLY STAND WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE EARLY LEARNING
SECTOR.
IT IS PROBABLY THEM THE MOST
CHALLENGED IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
FUNDAMENTAL STATE ROLE IS.
AND YET WE KNOW WITH THE RECENT
BRAIN RESEARCH AND ECONOMIC
ANALYSES THAT THIS IS WHERE WE
CAN HAVE THE MOST. PROFOUND
IMMEDIATE AND LONG TERM IMPACT.
I THINK IF WE HAD THI
INFORMATION MANY YEARS AGO WHEN
WE WERE CREATING OUR PUBLICS.
SYSTEMS OF EDUCATION WE WOULD
HAVE MADE SURE THAT WE WERE
STARTING MUCH YOUNGER AND THAT'S
NOT WHAT WE'RE DOING TODAY ONLY
FOURTEEN PERCENT OF INFANTS AND
TODDLERS THAT ARE EVEN DEEMED
ELIGIBLE FOR. SUPPORT.
IN THE EARLY WARNING SYSTEM GET
ACCESS TO IT.
WE KNOW THAT HIGH QUALITY
INFANT CARE COST AS MUCH PER
YEAR.
ACTION MORE THAN THE USE YOU
SEE TUITION AND OUR.
APPROACH TO THREE AND FOUR YEAR
OLDS IS A PATCHWORK WHERE
THERE'S NO ONE ENTITY THAT'S
FUNDAMENTALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
QUALITY ACCESS AND OR
AFFORDABILITY. I'M ALL OF THESE
OUTCOMES ARE SYMPTOMATIC OF THE
FACT THAT THE STATE IS NOT FULLY
CLARIFIED WHAT IT WILL OR WON'T
PROVIDE TO KIDS. AND WE BELIEVE
THAT BASED ON THE RESEARCH AND
PUBLIC SENTIMENT THAT THE STATE
HAS TO. MAKE SURE THAT ALL
CHILDREN HAVE ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY AFFORDABLE EARLY
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES AND THAT
THE STATE SHOULD BE THE
GUARANTOR.
TO ENSURE ALL FOUR YEAR OLDS
HAVE ACCESS THAT CHILDREN ACROSS
I ECS OF IT WHAT IS THE STATE
GOING TO HOLD ON TO AND WHAT IS
IT GOING TO DELEGATE AND WE
BELIEVE THERE AT LEAST FIVE
AREAS WHERE THE STATE. NEEDS TO
STEP UP AND PROVIDE EVEN MORE.
SUPPORT ENGAGEMENT AND THAT
INCLUDES ACCOUNTABILITY WHICH
WAS I REFERENCED A LOT TODAY
FISCAL TRANSPARENCY DATA SUPPORT
AND.
FUNDING AND ON THE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY FRONT CALIFORNIA
HAS MOVED IN THE DIRECTION OF
RELEASING A NEW STATE DASHBOARD
WHICH WE BELIEVE IS THE RIGHT
OVER ARCHING APPROACH HAS
MULTIPLE MEASURES SIMS ONLINE
FOR FUNCTION ABILITY. WHICH IS
REALLY GREAT.
BUT THERE ARE SOME KEY AREAS
THAT WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO REALLY ENGAGE IN AND
FOCUS ON.
AND AND AND POTENTIALLY.
ENGAGE IN.
LEGISLATIVELY OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS AND THAT IS.
DOES THE DOCTOR FOR AN ENOUGH
INFORMATION ON WHETHER OR NOT
GAPS IN ACHIEVEMENT OR CLOSING.
DO WE HAVE ENOUGH INDICATORS IN
THE SYSTEM A SPECIAL AROUND
COLLEGE AND CAREER READINESS
WHICH WE TALKED ABOUT THAT
ARTICULATION BETWEEN K. TWELVE
AND HIGHER ED.
PARENT TEACHER. STUDENT SURVEYS
AND A GROWTH MEASURE SO THESE
ARE SOME OF THE ROLES IN THE
ACCOUNTABILITY SPACE THAT WE
THINK IS
ICAL.
ON IN TERMS OF FISCAL
TRANSPARENCY THE STATE SHOULD BE
UP ANSWER SOME FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTIONS AND ESSENTIALLY.
DID WE PROVIDE INCREASED IMPROVE
SERVICES A SYSTEMATIC LEVEL FOR
OUR LOW INCOME ENGLISH LEARNERS
AND FOSTER YOUTH AND WAS THAT UP
IN ABOVE. THE.
AVERAGE.
SUPPORTS THAT WOULD PROVIDE FOR
FOR ALL KIDS.
AND IN ADDITION ON DATA.
IT'S CALIFORNIA'S WOEFULLY
BEHIND THE REST THE NATION IN
TERMS OF THE TYPE OF INFORMATION
WE COLLECT AND HOW THE SYSTEMS
THAT WE USE TO ALLOW POLICY
MAKERS EDUCATORS. AND THE PUBLIC
TO REALLY UNDERSTAND HOW SCHOOLS
ARE DOING AND HOW STUDENTS ARE
DOING AND THAT'S IMPACTING
INSTRUCTION AND THAT'S AN AREA
WE CAN IMPROVE.
ON SUPPORT ANOTHER AREA THAT'S
GONNA BE A BIG.
THE TOPIC OF CONVERSATION THIS
YEAR AND AND AGAIN WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE REALLY HAS A ROLE TO
PLAY IN THE STATE HAS A ROLE TO
PLAY. IN ENSURING THAT WERE
PROVIDING HIGH QUALITY SUPPORTS
THE OVERARCHING VISION THAT'S
WHY I'M ROLLING OUT IS IS THE
RIGHT ONE.
AND WE NEED TO DO.
WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN EVERY SCHOOL
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE ZIP CODE
IS.
SHE HAS ACCESS TO THAT SUPPORT A
FAMILY ON FINDING I THINK YOU
ALL. WE WE HAD THIS CONVERSATION
BEFORE KNOW THAT I CALIFORNIA.
INVEST LESS BEEN BEEN OTHER
NATIONS ARE OTHER STATES.
WHILE WE HAVE THE SIXTH LARGEST
ECONOMY A IN TERMS OF PRE PER
PER PUPIL SPENDING WERE ABOUT
FORTY FIRST AND I THINK THAT THE
RECENT ESTIMATE LAST ESTIMATES.
AND THIS RESULTS IN KIDS HAVING
LIKE LESS ACCESS TO ADULTS AND
WE HAVE AMONG THE HIGHEST RATIOS
OF.
IF NOT THE HIGHEST RATIO OF TEA
OF STUDENTS PER TEACHER
ADMINISTRATOR COUNSELOR
LIBRARIAN AND. EACH OF THESE
FIVE AREAS OF OF.
ACCOUNTABILITY FISCAL
TRANSPARENCY DATA SUPPORT AND
FUNDING ARE CRITICAL RULES FOR
THE STATE AND AS WE THINK ABOUT
STRUCTURES. THOSE STRUCTURES
AGAIN NEED TO FLOW FROM WHAT
THOSE FUNDAMENTAL ROLES
RESPONSIBILITIES AND COMMITMENTS
ARE OUR TWO CHILDREN I'M
INFERRING THAT JUST WANNA
MENTION HIGHER IT REALLY
QUICKLY.
THAT WE'VE WE'VE OF ASYLUM WING
OF THE THREE PUBLIC.
SEGMENTS CREATES A DYNAMIC WERE
NO SINGLE. IS FOCUSED ON A
RESPONSIBLE.
FOR HOW THE BEST INTEREST OF
STUDENTS BOTH WITHIN AND ACROSS
THE SEGMENTS
BUT AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER
SEPAK ó WAS WHAT'S CONCEDE TO
DO THIS BUT IT NEVER HAVE THE
AUTHORITY. OR THE RESOURCES AND
CAPACITY TO REALLY CARRY OUT
THAT CHARGE AND WE BELIEVE AT
THIS COORDINATING FUNCTION
SHOULD BE CARRIED OUT THE STATE
LEVEL. AND THAT AS WE DO THAT
THAT WE'RE DEFINING SUCCESS IS
MORE THAN JUST KIDS GETTING INTO
COLLEGE BUT THAT THERE
ULTIMATELY SIX
SCHOOL IN WHATEVER PATH AND THEY
TAKE.
AND IN THE MINIMUM THE STATE
SHOULD CLEARLY ARTICULATE THE
EXPECTATIONS FOR EACH OF THE
SEGMENTS OF HIGHER ED BEYOND
JUST WHAT'S IN THE BUDGET ACT.
AND A LINE THOSE TO KEY TWELVE
OUTCOMES AND THAT THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT.
CLARIFY WHAT ITS COMMITMENT
WILL BE TO ENSURE THE SCHOOLS
ARE CAN BE ACHIEVED.
SO IN CLOSING IN AND REFLECTING
ON THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
ABOUT THE DIFFERENT STRUCTURES
THAT THAT MIGHT BE MOVED IN AND
REORGANIZE AT THE STATE LEVEL
AGAIN A VERY GOOD CONVERSATION
TO HAVE. BUT WE HOPE THAT AS A
CONVERSATIONS OCCURRING IT IS
TRULY GROUNDED IN WHAT IS THE
STATE'S ROLE AND ALSO A
COMMITMENT SO THAT THE KIDS THE
FAMILIES AND.
THE EDUCATORS THAT ARE PART OF
IT THINGS ARE MUCH OF NOT NOT.
OKAY THANK YOU.
I WILL NEXT YEAR FROM.
BUT I DON'T RIGEL RIGEL MASATO
PARA FROM PUBLIC ADVOCATES.
I WAS THE NAME FROM.
A STAR.
OPEN A SOLUTION BRIAN. BELL
MEANS LEG FOOD AND RECONSIDER
ITS O'BRIEN'S LEFT LIKE IT'S
IT'S UNNERVING OKAY PROTESTED.
THE A GRANDFATHER LIKE LOOKING
AT THE STARS IT.
CHAIRED ANNOUNCER ALAN STAFF
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US HERE
THIS MORNING PUBLIC ADVOCATES
HAS ADVOCATED A AND LITIGATED IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH.
AND IMMIGRANT STUDENTS AND
PARENTS IN CALIFORNIA
OR FORTY YEARS.
FROM OUR POINT OF VIEW.
PROVIDING STATEWIDE KEY TWELVE
EDUCATION GOVERNANCE AYE YOU
WHILE IT IS ADMITTEDLY FLAWED IS
BASICALLY WORKING AND WE HAVE
EXHIBIT A AS AS A LOT OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROPER
FORMS.
THAT WE'VE SEEN.
HAD THAT THE DEPARTMENT THE
BOARD THE LEGISLATURE BILLY
GRAPPLE WITH IN THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS.
WHILE IT IS NOT PERFECTLY WE
WANT TO KNOW THAT THE UNIQUE
ROLE THAT PUBLIC EDUCATION
HOUSES THE ESSENTIALLY THE THE
PRIMARY AFFIRMATIVE BENEFIT. AND
ARE UNDER STATES CONSTITUTION
HASN'T IT TAKES UP MORE THAN
FORTY PERCENT OF OUR STATE'S
BUDGET IT'S A BIGGER AND MORE
COMPLICATED SUCH.
AND MOST OTHER FUNCTIONS OF OUR
GOVERNMENT.
WE ALSO NOTE THAT WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THE PEOPLE HAVE
CHOSEN FOR THIS IMPORTANT HAVE A
SEAT A SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION SEPARATE AND APART
FROM THE GOVERNOR. AND THE
COURTS HAVE BASICALLY WORKED OUT
THE POLICY VERSUS IMPLEMENTATION
BACK.
AGAIN NOT PERFECT.
WE ADMIT THEIR TENSIONS
AMBIGUITIES IN THE SYSTEM AND
WE.
SEE THAT CERTAIN IMPROVEMENTS
COULD BE MADE WE WE MIGHT
SUGGEST A NONPARTISAN BUDGET
SETTING FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
INCREASE ITS CAPACITY TO MEET
ITS LEGAL RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW.
AND ANOTHER IDEA MIGHT BE TO
GIVE THE BOARD A FINALIST
ALREADY IN THE REGULATION IN THE
IMPLEMENTING THE REGULATIONS IT
PROMULGATES.
APART FROM THESE ISSUES TIME WE
AYE I WANT TO ECHO AND MISS
TRANSIENT ANNOUNCED COMMENT
ABOUT ADEQUATE FUNDING THAT IS
IN OUR VIEW THE THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE FACING QUALITY OF
EDUCATION THAT OUR KIDS RECEIVE
IN THE STATE.
AND APART FROM THAT WE WE
REALLY WANT TO ARTICULATE OUR
OUR DESIRE TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
YOU TO INCREASE THE CAPACITY. OF
LOCAL ELEAZAR DISTRICTS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES
TO TAKE CONTROL OF THEIR
EDUCATION UNDER LCF STAFF.
AS WAS STATED WE AND WE AND WE
STRONGLY AGREE THAT FAMILIES SEE
THEIR LOCAL LEADERS.
AS AS GOVERNESS IN IN IN
CALIFORNIA DUCATION AND AND
WHILE WE KNOW THAT THAT'S BUT
THE WITH THE CRITICAL ROLE THAT
STATES AND COUNTIES PLAYED. ARE
OUR REFORMS OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS HAVE REALLY
HIGHLIGHTED THEM THE LOCAL
CONTROL AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
ALL STAKEHOLDERS.
HOLDING THEIR DISTRICTS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND COUNTY
OFFICES ACCOUNTABLE FOR OUTCOMES
THAT STUDENTS RECEIVE.
WE NEED YOUR HELP MAKE DEMOCRACY
REAL AND PUBLIC EDUCATION.
BECAUSE LOCAL BY AN
ACCOUNTABILITY AND PUT ARE
CRITICAL TO TRANSFORMING
OUTCOMES FOR.
UNDER LCF OUT STILL COME SCHOOL
COMMUNITIES NOW HAVE MULTIPLE
MEASURES OF SUCCESS IN THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD.
AND THE LOCAL CONTROL THEY NEED
TO FACE THEIR UNIQUE CHALLENGES
WE HAVE ANY STATE AGENCY IN NYC
AND THE CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE
FOR EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE WE
HAVE A COUNTY OFFICES. TO PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE OF PROVIDING
DESPERATELY NEEDED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT TO
DISTRICTS.
I CHARTER SCHOOLS AS THEY STRIVE
TO CREATE EQUITABLE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL STUDENTS.
WE'RE EXCITED TO SEE THE SYSTEM
WORK AND WE THINK THAT ADEQUATE
FISCAL RESOURCES AND OVERSIGHT
FROM THE STATE.
IS NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT
LOCAL RESPONSIBILITY IS MATCHED
BY LOCAL CAPACITY.
WHEN IT'S WORKING WE THINK THE
SYSTEM WILL EMPOWER COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY CHINESE STUDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES TWO WAY EN ON
WHAT THEY NEED AND AND AND
OBTAIN WITH THE NEED TO EXIT
EXIT TO SUCCEED WHETHER IT'S
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
FOR TEACHERS TO ENGAGE IN
PROJECT BASED LEARNING. POSITIVE
BEHAVIOR INTERVENTIONS SYSTEMS
SCHOOL COUNSELORS CULTURAL
COMPETENCE TRAINING FOR
ADMINISTRATORS.
WE BELIEVE IN THE SYSTEM'S
WORKING IT'S GONNA PROVIDE
ROBUST RESEARCH BASED SUPPORT TO
ELEAZAR.
FROM THE COUNTY OFFICES CC
TO MEET THE NEEDS. OF OUR SINCE
IT DISABILITIES FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS ARE ENGLISH
LEARNERS HOMELESS STUDENTS.
WE THINK ONE THE SYSTEM'S
WORKING IT'S GOING TO ENSURE
THAT FUNDS GENERATED BY HIGH
NEED STUDENTS ARE SPENT
EFFECTIVELY ON MORE AND BETTER
SERVICES FOR THOSE STUDENTS.
THAT TRANSPARENCY IS KEY TO LC
EFFECTS EQUITY PROMISE.
I.
AND WE THINK THAT WHEN THE
SYSTEM IS WORKING IT WILL
AUTHENTICALLY MEASURE SKIP
SCHOOL CLIMATE PARA ENGAGEMENT
AND SOON ENGAGEMENT WHICH ARE
TRULY THE FOUNDATIONS FOR
STUDENT ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT.
FOR THE SYSTEM TO ORK WE NEED
CONTINUED RESOURCES TO SEE C. E.
COUNTY OFFICES TO ENSURE ROBUST
SYSTEM IS A.
POR IS AVAILABLE TO ALL ELEAZAR.
AND THAT TIME AND THAT ALL THE
CC <c.green> COUNTY OFFICES
AND</c>
DISTRICTS ARE ABLE TO STE TRULY
SUPPORT STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
IN THE CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT
PROCESS.
ROBUST MEASURES OF CONFINEMENT
AND ENGAGEMENT SHOULD INCLUDE
ANNUAL SURVEY.
EXCUSE ME SURVEYS OF ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AND CAN AND WE KNOW
FROM SPEAKING WITH WORKING WITH
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT
PRACTITIONERS. THAT THAT THAT
THERE IS A CRITICAL ROLE TO PLAY
BY PARENTS AND STUDENTS AND
IMPROVING OUR.
THE CURRENT K. TWELVE EDUCATION
GOVERNANCE IS NOT.
POSING A THREAT
TO OUR STATES PROMISING REFORMS%
AND WHILE THERE'S ALWAYS ROOM TO
IMPROVE ULTIMATELY WE HAVE MORE
PRESSING NEEDS. TIME TO MAKE
DEMOCRACY REALLY PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND WE URGE LAWMAKERS.
FOR AUTHENTIC COMMUNICATION.
SO THAT DISTRICT DECISIONS MEET
THE REAL NEEDS OF STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES THANK YOU.
BUT YOU.
WELL THANK EVERYBODY FOR YOUR
PERSPECTIVES I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE IT OVERHEAD.
ERIN.
I'M SO SORRY TURNTABLE FROM FOR
SUCH CALIFORNIA I'M SO SORRY.
AARON GAVE ON BEHALF FIRST TYPE
CALIFORNIA AND I'VE BEEN ASKED
TO SPEAK AB BRIEFLY SO I WILL BE
BRIEF INTERRUPTION
IN GOVERNANCE OF THE ENTIRE.
IF EDUCATION UNDER THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION AND WHAT
IMPACT EARLY LEARNING IN CHILD
CARE UNIQUELY TO ANY ISSUE.
AND WE WOULD ASK THAT YOU BEGIN
ANY THESE CONVERSATIONS AROUND
GOVERNANCE WITH THINKING ABOUT
HOW A GOVERNANCE CHANGE WOULD
ELEVATE AND STRENGTHEN COHERENCE
IN THE DELIVERY OF EARLY
LEARNING IN OUR SYSTEM. RATHER
THAN BURYING IT PERHAPS WITH
ANOTHER INSTITUTION WHERE IT
MIGHT BE A NEW ISSUE. IN THE
SEVENTY FIVE YEAR HISTORY OF
EASY E. IN CALIFORNIA SEVENTY
FIFTH ANNIVERSARY BY THE WAY.
EARLY LEARNING PROGRAMS
CHILDCARE AND PRESCHOOL HAVE
BEEN SOLELY UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THE S. P. AYE
UNLIKE OTHER PROGRAMS ARE IS NO
BIFURCATION BETWEEN
ACCOUNTABILITY TO THE STATE
BOARD. AND TO STATE
SUPERINTENDENT INCLUDING FOR
CURRICULUM ACCOUNTABILITY AND
WAIVERS OF STATE LAW.
EASY IS UNIQUE IN THE CD E.
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE AND SO I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO THINK
ABOUT IT THAT WAY. REPORTING
SOLELY TO THE FBI FOR THE
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM OUT
ALTERNATE PAYMENT PROGRAM THAT'S
OUR VOUCHER BASED CHILDCARE.
TITLE FIVE CENTER BASED
CHILDCARE PROGRAMS PRESCHOOL AND
CAL WORK STAGES TWO AND THREE.
THE NATIONALLY ACCLAIMED
PRESCHOOL LEARNING FOUNDATIONS
SUCH AS OURS ZERO TO FIVE
CURRICULUM FRAMEWORK.
AND THE SANDERS ARTICULATE TO
THE COMMON CORE IS SOLELY UNDER
THE NEED THE JURISDICTION
CURRENTLY OF THE S. P. AYE*
CONTRACT MANAGEMENT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
AND HE SAID HE IS NOT A LOCAL
CONTROL MODEL.
AFTER MANY POLICY WARS ON THAT
FRONT SOME OF THE RECENT.
EASY HAS REMAINED A STATE
GOVERNMENT SYSTEM AND A STATE
GOVERNMENT SYSTEM UNDER THE FBI
BECAUSE I'VE TO DATE HAS BEEN
BELIEVED BY THE FEEL THAT IT'S
BEEN THE BEST STATE AGENCY.
OUGHT TO SUPPORT THE TWIN GOALS
OF CHILD DEVELOPMENT WORKING
TOWARDS ABORIGINE TREATMENT GAP
AND MEETING THE NEEDS OF WORKING
FAMILIES IN OUR DIVERSE SYSTEM.
EASY IS ALSO NOT SOLELY ARE
DELIVERED THROUGH OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEMS BUT RATHER IS A PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP.
IT'S ALSO PARTIALLY FUNDED
THROUGH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS IN THESE KEY
ADMINISTRATIVE PARTNER SAM HELP
KEEP THE PROGRAM MOVING AND MANY
DIVERSE DELIVERY ENVIRONMENTS
AROUND OUR STATE.
NEITHER OF NO DOUBT BEEN GREAT
CHALLENGES FOR THE EASY
COMMUNITY TO BE BURIED IN A K.
TWELVE FOCUSED AGENCY. NOR HAS
THIS LOCATION YET FULLY ACHIEVE
THE PROMISE
AB ARTICULATING PRE K. THROUGH
QUE AND TWELVE INTO HIRE AT IS
MANY OF OUR PARTNERS TO DISCUSS.
BUT THIS AGENCY LOCATION AGAIN
HAS ALWAYS HELD THE MOST PROMISE
IN KEEPING CHILD DEVELOPMENT AS
A NORTH STAR. AND CURRENTLY AS
CERTAINLY LEADERSHIP OF THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION HAS BEEN
MOST ARTICULATE ON THE SCHOOL.
I COULD NOT RECOMMEND A MOVE TO
EVEN MORE K. TWELVE FOCUSED
AGENCY AS SADNESS BEEN SAID BY
MANY OF OUR PANELISTS HERE.
ESPECIALLY ONE FACING OUR
CURRENT TSUNAMI OF CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION REFORMS HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED VERY SIGNIFICANTLY OVER
THE LAST SEVEN YEARS AND
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION OF
WHICH HAS BEEN PLACED IN THE
LAPS OF THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION MEMBERS. LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMON CORE NEW
ASSESSMENT SYSTEMS JUST TO NAME
A FEW SMALL THINGS.
HAS BEEN RECOMMENDEDBY NUMEROUS
REFORM BRIEFS OVER THE DECADES
ANY SHIFTING GOVERNANCE FOR UC'S
SHOULD BE FOR THE SAKE OF
ELEVATING E. C. E. AND FINDING
SOME CLARITY AND SOME
CONTINUITY.
FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE AND FROM
THE INTENT TO PROVIDE A MORE
EFFECTIVE STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
SYSTEM FOR EASY. I WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT THE COMMITTEES
LOOK INTO THE LEARNING POLICY
INSTITUTE BRIEF THAT YOU HAVE IN
YOUR PACKETS.
AS I WELL AS THE HIGH COMMON
SENSE KIDS ACTION RIGHT START
COMMISSION'S RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN A
COMPREHENSIVELY.
I HAVE SOME OF SUGGESTED THAT
YOU SEE. I'M. THAT ONE EARLY
CHILDHOOD AGENCY WHETHER BE THE
CONSOLIDATION OF MULTIPLE AGENCY
ROLES AT CD <c.green> OR</c>
CONSOLIDATIONS OF PROGRAMS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES IN SOME OTHER
WAY. I'M BUT REGARDLESS OF THE
MODEL ALL RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE
ELEVATED AND ATTEMPTED TO
COORDINATE IN SOME WAY EASY
PROGRAMS.
AND.
ADDITIONALLY TO TRY TO FIND
SOME WAY TRANSITION TO CAPE
TWELVE AND THINK MORE
SYSTEMATICALLY ACROSS THE
SYSTEMS.
REGARDLESS OF THE AGENCY REAL
ESTATE PLEASE SEIZE THE NEXT FEW
YEARS TO ARTICULATE A SENSIBLE
SYSTEM FOR EASY TO BRING OUR
DIVERSE FUNDING SYSTEMS
TOGETHER.
INTO A REAL SYSTEM FOR THE FIRST
TIME AND AS YOU'LL SEE INCLUDED
IN THE LEARNING POLICY INSTITUTE
BRIEF AB FOR THINGS FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER.
ONE A TWENTY FIRST CENTURY NO
WRONG DOOR PORTAL PREPARED
ENROLLMENT IN REFERRAL TO
QUALITY CHILDCARE INFORMED
PARENT CHOICE WHETHER YOU'RE
LOOKING AT CHILDCARE VOUCHERS OR
TEA QUE.
NUMBER TO A SINGLE SYSTEM FOR
FUNDING RATES PER CHILD THAT
RECOGNIZE THE COST OF QUALITY IN
BOTH OUR SCHOOL AND COMMUNITY
BASED SETTINGS.
A SINGLE SYSTEM FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR ALL OF OUR
TEACHERS AND ALL CARE SETTINGS.
AND FINALLY TO FIND A WAY TO
CONSOLIDATE OR QUOTE WORD NEED
OUR ECT STATE SYSTEM ROLES IN A
WAY THAT MAKES SENSE BUT NOT
NECESSARILY UNDERNEATH THE STATE
BOARD.
I THINK YOU.
WHICH REMINDS.
I'M OKAY.
DO WE HAVE SO WHEN WE PUT THE
FOLKS STAY HERE FOR JUST ONE
QUICK SECOND AS THE AS AN
ANALYST BECOME PUBLIC COMMENT
BEFORE THE COMMENT OKAY. LET'S
HEAR FROM YOU.
LAST COUPLE QUESTIONS OF THE
PANEL ON WILL BELLIGERENT YES.
GOOD MORNING SUE BANG ON BEHALF
OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION. TOM TRUCKS
AND WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION ON QUE TALK
GOVERNANCE BUT ONE OF THE CLEAR
THAT SUPPORT HIM TORRANCE AND
DOES NOT HAVE A POSITION ON THE
COMMONSENSE PROPOSED SO. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE OF THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT THEY CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS YEAR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YES SIR.
GOOD MORNING CREATURE MIRACLE
FOR THE ON THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA HEAD
START ASSOCIATION ADDS WINNER
REINFORCED THAT THE COMMENTS
THAT AARON MADE ABOUT THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD AT WORLD.
I'M.
I THINK IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
ENSURE THAT.
GOOD GOVERNANCE CREATES A PLACE.
WHERE ARE THE EARLY CHILDHOOD
WORLD HAS AN APPROPRIATE PLACE
IN THAT GOVERNMENT'S TABLE THAT
IS COMMENSURATE WITH OUR ITS
IMPORTANCE IT IS BORNE OUT BY
THE RESEARCH ON INVESTMENTS IN
THE BENEFITS OF THE INVESTMENTS
IN EARLY CHILDHOOD?
AS A PART OF THAT IS GOING TO
SAY I YOU KNOW WE HAVE A HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX HEADS FOR AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA MANY OF THEM ON THE
STEEP PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS.
AND.
AFTER EIGHTEEN MONTHS IN THE
JOB I CAN TELL YOU I I I BELIEVE
THAT.
.
HEAD START IS ALMOST A SHADOW
ECONOMY HERE. BY AND DOESN'T
ALWAYS GET THE ATTENTION THAT IT
DESERVES WHEN THE DISCUSSIONS
AROUND EARLY CHILDHOOD. OUT
FUNDING AND SLOTS AN ACCESS OR
DISCUSSED.
I IT'S A BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA AND SO
I THINK AS YOU THINK ABOUT THE
GOVERNANCE. OF EDUCATION FOR
CHILDREN AND FOR OUR YOUNGEST
MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN. THAT
JUST ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A
SYSTEM WHERE. THE GOVERNMENT
HAS.
THE CAPACITY TO COLLABORATE
THIS VERY COMPLEX
SYSTEM OF DELIVERY AND OVERSIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU KNOW LEVINE IS AT A DID SO I
UNDERSTAND AND MAYBE I MISSED IT
BUT WHAT WHAT IS IT ABOUT THAT.
HOW DOES THAT?
ON WHAT WHY WITH DID THE
CONTENTS FOR BOTH UNNECESSARILY.
LEAVE EARLY CHILDHOOD.
PART OF THIS THAT OF THE LOOP I
THINK THE CONTEXT WE'VE LOOKED
AT IF YOU THINK ABOUT TODAY'S
HEARING AND HOW.
WITH BARELY EVEN IF THE SKIM
THE SURFACE AND THE HOURS WE
SPEND TODAY ON EACH OF THE
CRITICAL ISSUES FACING KEY
TWELVE EDUCATION. IN THE NEW
FAST FORWARD TO A TWO DAY LONG
STATE BOARD HEARING THAT ALREADY
IS THE WAY IT'S STRUCTURED IN
EXCESS HOW IT HOW CRITICAL ISSUE
LIKE EASE
THE E. WOULD ACTUALLY BE
ELEVATED. IN A CONTEXT RATHER
THAN BE BURIED IS SOMETHING WE
ARE GREATLY CONCERNED ABOUT
PARTICULARLY CONSIDERING THE
WONDERFUL EXTREME THINGS OF THE
STATE BOARDS GRAPPLING WITH VERY
WELL RIGHT NOW. IN TERMS OF
SEVEN YEARS OF SIGNIFICANT
EDUCATION REFORM IT'S HAPPENED.
RIVER ARGUABLY HE'S SEEKING TO
HOWARD THE BOARD FURTHER.
YEAH ABSOLUTELY I MADE THERE ARE
WAYS TO THINK ABOUT THIS IN
TERMS OF THE APPOINTMENTS THAT
ARE MADE IN TERMS OF VALUED AT
THINK YOU TALK ABOUT THIS WITH
THE EARLIER PANEL. OBVIOUSLY
THERE ARE CRITICAL COMPONENTS TO
THE PROPOSALS BUT AS IT'S BEEN
MADE IT WITH A BALANCED
APPOINTMENTS MADE BY THE
LEGISLATURE VERSUS THE GOVERNOR
THERE ALL KINDS OF DYNAMICS
HERE.
THE COULD CHANGE THE WAY
SOMETHING WOULD OPERATE AND
FUNCTION
BUT IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE
PORTFOLIO OF THE STATE MORE
TODAY. AND WHAT IT HAS DONE AND
HOW DISCONNECTED IT HAS BEEN
FROM THE ENTIRE ECG WORLD. I'M
AND CONSIDERING THAT OUR WORLD
IS VERY UNIQUE AND NOT SCHOOL
CENTERED LIKE THE REST OF THE
STATE PORTS WORK. IT DOES SEEM
THAT IT WOULD NOT NECESSARILY BE
THE MOST APPROPRIATE FIT TO
GOVERN MOVING FORWARD WITH A
VISION COMPREHENSIVELY FOR EASY
OPPOSE TO SAY I'M. OTHER
PROPOSALS WE'VE SEEN FROM THE
RIGHT START COMMISSION OR FROM
LEARNING POLICY INSTITUTE DOCTOR
AND LINDA DARLING HAMMOND.
AROUND CREATING A STANDALONE
EARLY EDUCATION AGENCY OR
THINKING ABOUT OTHER WAYS TO
COORDINATE.
PERHAPS PIECES OF THE SYSTEM
THAT COULD LIVE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF AT THE CURRENTLY
DON'T SUCH AS LICENSING.
HOME VISITING OTHER KINDS OF
PROGRAMS OF THAT NATURE THE DO
AFFECT THE SAME POPULATIONS OF
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN.
CONFIGURED SO YOU WANT THE MONEY
BUT NOT THE GOVERNMENT'S.
I'M SORRY AT SO YOU MEAN TERMS
OF THE STATE BOARD.
I I GUESS I DON'T KNOW WHERE
YOU'RE GOING INCOME CONFUSED
WITH.
I'M CONFUSED WHERE YOU'RE COMING
FROM ON THE GOVERNANCE OF EARLY
OF.
MAYBE.
A PRESCHOOL. REALLY CHARLIE SAID
YOU'RE SAYING YOU WANT THOSE OUT
OF THIS DISCUSSION.
NO I I ACTUALLY WOULD LOVE FOR
IT TO BE IN WOULD ENCOURAGE FOR
YOU TO HAVE IT BE A PART OF THIS
DISCUSSION I'M JUST TRYING TO
POINT OUT HOW UNIQUELY. THE
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
PROGRAMS DON'T HAVE THE SAME
KIND OF POTENTIAL FOR FIT
UNDERNEATH THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION AS PROPOSED HERE BUT
ABSOLUTELY ISSUE WERE TALKING
ABOUT GOVERNANCE OF THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM WE WOULD WANT YOU TO BE
THINKING ABOUT HOW.
FITS
IN THAT BECAUSE.
PART OF THAT SYSTEMS ABSOLUTELY
FUNDED UNDER THE SCHOOLS.
AND THERE'S A THE VINTAGES PART
OF A.
I MEAN BUT I HEAR A LOT AS
THEY'RE PART OF A CONTINUOUS
VERTICAL EXPERIENCE RIGHT VIRTUE
WE WANT CHILDREN IN THE.
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND
THEN YOU ON THAT GOVERN
SEPARATELY IS IT I MEAN I'VE
BEEN CONFUSED I'M NOT ADVOCATING
FOR ANY PARTICULAR PROPOSAL
RIGHT NOW WHAT I WAS DOING WAS
OUTLINING CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSAL THAT WAS. YOU ABOUT
MOVING HE C. E. UNDER THE STATE
BOARD WE DO NOT HAVE CONCERNS
UNDER THE CURRENT STRUCTURE OF
IT BEING RUN BY THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION.
BUT HE.
OKAY I THINK BOTH OF US HAVE
TWELVE NOON MEETINGS WE GOT
ARRESTED YOU ADDS I REALLY DO
PERCENT PARTICIPATION. AND DONE
STATUS ARE OFFICES IS THIS
ALMOST FORD AS AS IS TYPICAL THE
INTERESTING.
HEARING GOVERNOR'S RAISE MORE
QUESTIONS THAN IT ANSWERS.
BUT THAT REALLY DO APPRECIATE
IT WAS IMPLIED AND TIME IT
CERTAINLY GIVES A WHOLE NEW SET
OF THINGS TO THINK ABOUT WITH
ADDRESS THE COMPLEXITY OF THIS.
PLEASE PROPOSAL SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR